[Musique]
he
he he he
he he
[Musique]
he
salut à tous et bienvenue pour pour ce
nouveau live on est en train de rigoler
avec PAP essayie de se cadrer avec des
caméras minuscule on est pas mal on est
pas mal on est pas mal mon Fab donc on
va suivre
aujourd'hui combien c'est la 8e ronde
c'est la 8e ronde il en reste 4 8 9 10
11 donc on va regarder deux parties en
priorité on va regarder Baky avec les
Noirs contre carwana c'est ce que vous
avez à l'écran et on gardera sur la
petite comme on sera plus sur la partie
de Baky probablement la partie d'alirea
comme ça on aura un peu les un peu les
deux un peu les tendances des des deux
et on jettera évidemment aussi un œil
sur Maxime qui va tenter le le 4 sur 4
et et sur nakamuravidit qui est
quasiment tout aussi importante que la
partie de firouja pour pour la calife au
candidat donc on va suivre on va suivre
quatre parties en gros je dirais qu'on a
trois cartouches Fab pour aller au
candidat actuellement on a Baki pour la
Calif Alireza encore une petite chance
aujourd'hui et Naka qui qualifierait
probablement alirea au
au oui pour le hlo et compagnie comme on
en parlait et puis la microochance mais
qu'il faut bah saisir si on peut celle
de Maxime faut gagner aujourd'hui il
faut gagner demain faut gagner
après-demain et il faut encore gagner la
dernière donc autant vous dire qu'il y a
un long chemin mais il en a déjà gagné
deux de suite alors bon donc on a
aujourd'hui il est pas mal hein contre
Pichot il peut il peut gagner quand même
avec les Blancs on peut dire qu'on a
trois cartouche dans le barrier ouais
trois cartouches etre une cartouche
surprise on sait pas trop quoi c'est
c'est Maxime qui a joué en premier il
veut il veut qu'on a le voir Maxime
allez let's go voir ce que fait Maxime
sVAN ça a jouer aussi E4 il y a des E4
partout ou pas il y a des4 partout il y
a des E4 partout ouais c'est E4 E4 E4
evidit
evidit il nous fait un suspense suspense
on reste sur Maxime au début parce qu'il
clique tempo ouais n'importe je sais pas
allez toute façon sera les grands enfin
on va on va au début on va un peu voir
mais Maxime j'imagine va tout CCK
tempo espagnol pour
Maxime sicilen pour Alireza Alireza joue
le G à fond parce que sinon il aurait
joué 45 donc il tend tout il tente tout
il tend tout et sicilien pour Baky e 6
ça va être chaud aussi bon c annoncé
annoncé je t'en ai parlé hier en fait
ouis tu m'as dit
hier
mer nos cartouches sont pas les
meilleures mais elles sont là bah c'est
vrai que pour le moment on n pas on n
pas super bien quoi
mais il suffit que tuas une victoire de
Baki aujourd'hui ou une victoire
d'alireza ou une victoire d'ikarou un
des trois et des nuls dans les autres et
tu te passes très bien en fait si sur
Ikaru firou et Baki on fait de sur 3 on
sera très bien si on fait un demi sur 3
on sera ENF journée de c'est une journée
pour rien mais comme il faut qu'il a
journées pourel quelque chose on on
s'éloigne quoi donc on va voir c'est
c'est c'est tendu donc Baky là c'est
pour Mo c'est enfin c'est très théorique
bien évidemment cvant il y a eu le D4 ça
va partir dans une nche d'orf Maxime
est-ce qu' est là pour tout click tempo
je crois que Maxime il est là pour
clicin
ah gouerti qui en VO la lapine bon ça on
avait prévu nul je pense qu'on se trompe
pas
fabon c'est le plus probable après on
verra bien après svian donc qui ouvre la
Sicilienne cont
contre contre alira bon ben lui au moins
il fait pas une alapine ou un fou B5 euh
bon Maxim on verra qu' quelle le sa et
et Fabi Étienne men verra Étienne donc
du coup qui connaît bien là c'est une
Sicilienne qui qui depuis le début de ce
tournoi il maîtrise très très bien il l'
jouit pas avant mais là bon clairement
c'est c'est la ligne qu'il a préparé
pour le tournoi et
euh c'est qui la kuberakov là
l'Australien alors moy pour me rappeler
ouais Cubio cubiokarov ouais cubiokarov
qui avait joué un peu n'importe quoi
donc en fait Ettien n pas encore été
poussé dans sa retranchement niveau
prépa donc on verra en tout cas Fabi qui
joue un petit coup avec ce
à3 moi mon prono c'est TR nul alors
qu'il y a un truc intéressant
directement la partie de de sévian
contre firouja je te coupe parce que on
a un coup qui est pas habituel fou des
tro ouais désolé de te couper mais ce
coupl j'ai pas mémoire de l'avoir vu
donc je remonte le début de la partie
parce que c'est la première grosse
surprise dans dans une ouverture
aujourd'hui puion prend cavalier prend
donc c'est Viant qui a les blanc va se
mettre côté côté alierza cavalier F6
c'est là tout le monde joue cavalier C3
et Sam cvant qui envoie un fou D3 un
coup
Fab un coup un coup B en fait faut
défendre 4 donc tu as k C3 qui est quand
même normal fou3 qui semble un peu
pourri mais bon pourquoi pas maintenant
on voit des nages d'or F D3 ou quoi donc
et bon il y a F3 aussi qui est jouable
qu'on avait déjà vu F3 c'est plus enfin
F3 c'est le moins logique de tous ouais
bon non mais ça peut pas être enfin ça
peut pas perdre mais je veux dire en
visuel après évidemment c'est ça prépa
il a des idées mais visuellement c'est
le coup le plus bizarre d'ailleurs
cavali c6ah direct on touche le CAH des4
qui n'est plus
protégé alors c'est quoi l'idée est-ce
que c'est de prendre est-ce que c'est de
se partir est-ce que c'est faire C3
ou non mais d'accord mais c'est Moch
quoi euh je sais pas on verra bon pour
l'instant c'est pas très impressionnant
on va dire est-ce que tu penses que
c'est un truc pour jouer le mais c'est
bien on en parlait hier au dîner enfin
après pendant le dîner ouais on a eu les
apparims et on disait ben normalement
bon c'est instant enfin tu veux faire
instant nul quand as les noir contre
firou parce que tu vas lui laisser
prendre tous les risque et tu joues un
peu le jeu qu' qu' a joué Baky qui est
le jeu intéressant d'après nous à jouer
c'est de jamais tuentreprends jamais
rien quoi tu laisses les autres
s'exploser et c'est ce qui nous paraît
aussi le plus intelligent cette
stratégie là mais on se disait que c
Viant bizarrement il allit enfin tu as 8
chances sur 10 qu'il fasse ça mais il
peut un peu péter des câbles quoi je
sais pas on va voir ce qu'il fait bon à
sa place moi je jouis pour nul hein mais
bon
euh si ve s'exposer qui s'expose hein
alors Baky Baky réfléchit après le A3 il
a raison de bien réfléchir dans
l'ouverture contre carwana bien préparé
Fabi après Fabi c'est pas un gars qui va
forcer à fond dans le sens où euh lui il
est qualifié dans tous les cas donc il
joue plus pour le ho puis pour pour la
kayas he aussi on va on va le dire
franchement et puis il est peut-être un
peu voilà ça fait ça fait presque 20
jours d'affilé qu'il joue quoi bah il pr
des États-Unis juste avant donc
évidemment ça doit commencer à tirer un
peu dans les pattes donc on va voir mais
bon après avoir les Noirs contre Fabi
c'est jamais une partie de plaisir non
non mais moi je vois bien une nul non ça
moi je suis confiant je suis quand même
assez
confiant je suis assez confiant parce
que bah B qui joue vraiment bien dans ce
tournoi et et Fabiano il joue pas mal
mais il joue toujours bien mais genre
voilà ça peut commencer à tirer bah qui
va bien réussir son ouverture il est
bien préparé moi je sens bien une nul en
fait je je suis relativement confiant il
para que ce sera un très bon résultat
nul pour Baky et ensuite il aurait on
espère deux fois les blancs une fois les
Noirs alors ça c'est pas sûr non plus
parce qu'il y a tout le jeu il y a des
joueurs qui vont doubler qui ont
beaucoup les mêmes couleurs et B qui
peut être de ceux qui bah by a déjà
doublé les blancs donc si tu doubles les
un moment ça r quel part c'est normal
quoi enfin donc à voir à voir après ça
on verra mais déjà nul contre carwana
avec les noirs de bases euh mais tu es
toujours content Caron cont faut pas
trop demander non plus après bon bah si
Caron t'ouvre la porte tu tu rentres
mais de base tu signes volontier pour
nul contre faille
quoi euh donc
alira on va voir l'idée moi je suis
curieux en fait de la variante avec fou
D3 fou3 là bah c'est le devenir de Sky
B1 en fait a priori hein l'idée normale
de retarder k C3 c'est de faire C4 enin
si jamais c'est pour je k C3 dans
quelques
coup bah ça sera vra mais peut-être F G7
et C4 maintenant
ou je sais pas enfin oui a priori c'est
c'est ce genre de truc qui devrait
vouloir
euh enfin je le comprends comme tel si
si c'est pas
salidé il fait fou G7 donc C4 paraî
logique bon voilà donc voilà c'est
l'idée derrière son fou D3 c'est de de
vouloir jouer avec C4 il le faire et si
je te fais un truc assez maétien G4 tu
prends je bouffe du Fou tu bouffes et je
te joue quand même le rapport matériel
alors bon c'est une position qui change
un peu que ce pion a changé en G4 tu
vois mon feras G5 tu vas avir du mal à
roquer il aur toujours des problèmes sur
la colche après j'en sais rien peutas
les meilleures pièces mais tant que j'ai
mon cavalier
écoute bon il doit un peu connaître
c'est
vient c'est pas net mais k G4 5 coup bon
évidemment P rock c'est un coup alors k
PR4 n'est pas un coup l'idée de K GK sur
k C6 juste pour montrer he c'est quand
même important rebondit sur E3 qui
rebondit sur la dame il prend la dame on
rebondit en plus il y a B2 pour le fou
si jamais enfin bon en fait on rebondit
partout quoi euh ouais ça c'est pas
jouable et k prend 4 oui le problème
c'est qu'il a peut-être qui prend 6 mais
aussi fut prend 4 ouais
doncç
les deux quo donc double double
problémos euh donc non k G4 évidemment
un coup petit rock pour jouer juste
moroxy normal
euh ouais mais alors est-ce que il
transpose petit rock ou pas par que le
Fou est plutôt en de norm ouais ouais
ouais il bah en fait en gros j'imagine
que c'est Vian et prê une petite
concession pourir la
structure tu vois genre fou D7 et
peut-être cavalier
C2 bon en gros tu t'as perdu un tempo et
il sait comment s'organiser parce qu'il
analy à l'ordi quoi bon ou enfin de
toute façon voilà B qui vraiment fou de
bon ça pas trop avancé côté Baky on
attend un peu de découvrir la prépa de
Fabiano
ouais ben écoute fou 2 bon ben ça ouvre
des portes au petit rock et aussi ce fou
2 peut aller vers F3 pour menacer de5 et
contester cette grande diagonale
norement c'est encore très théorique
hein Fab B7 va être joué a priori a
priori ouais euh Maxime qui joue comme
l'éclair ouais bon ben c'est buz
l'éclair en fait ok c'est une pe la
rendre de Vlad
ouais nurtf comme l'appelle
Vlad mais il a décidé de clic he Maxime
il a décider de tout clic tempo bon de
toute façon là il connaît enfin je veux
dire c'est encore très théorique et puis
quand même ça ne le serait pas on a vu
hier que il absolument rien à faire
c'est passé guerre C de réfléchir mais
il a raison he ce qui lui donne des
résultats pour le moment et s'il gagne
aujourd'hui Maxime il sera encore très
très loin bon tuas tro victoires
d'affilé il faut refaire tris quoi mais
tuas mis chemin tu as mis chemin puis tu
cliques quoi tu t'en fiches façon tu as
tournois perdu donc tu dis au meccoute
démerdez-vous les faire nul nul vous
avez perdu j'ai perdu aussi tant pis
c'est pas grave façon j'ai déjà perdu
toi toi tu as peut-être pas perdu moi
j'ai
perdu pas non non bien sûr mais non je
sais pas il doit encore y croire un peu
Maxim légèrement je ve
dire bah écoute si tu gagnes aujourd'hui
pourquoi pas
quoiit bon ben donc c'est une alapine
plus ou moins classique cavalier A3 dame
D8 ouais ouais plusins normal cavalier
A3 c'est toujours les mêmes idées he
c'est d'aller vers B5 pour faire les
forchettes en C7 et ou rir en C4 ou
mettre le fou donc voilà et dame D8 ça
s'entend ça va parer toutes les futures
menaces s'enlève cette dame du centre et
donc B visite de jouer mais
probablement bon soit un coup comme F de
ou C C4 pour revenir vers ver05
l'avantposte c'est plutôt normal euh
voilà mais en général oui la lapine
c'est fait pour pour jouer une partie
sachant que nul c'est pas si mal et
vidit bah vidit serait pas mécontent du
nul à mon avis il garderait la tête il
carou il ferait nul avec les noir il
aurait deux blancs pour finir il per pas
trop de hlo oua c'est pas si mal donc je
pense nul c'est le qui arrange un peu
tout le monde dans cette partie et je en
fait dans C interview hier il disait
qu'il était malade mvl c'est ça ouais
ben nous on le sait moi je le sais
depuis le début du tour en fait donc
après moi je veux pas dévoiler ce genre
de chos avant que les joueurs les
dévoiler parce que ça donne des
informations donc je pouvais pas le dire
en live mais je savais qu'il était qu'il
était assez malade et c'est pour ça
quand tu as des gens qui voilà bon moi
je pouvais pas en dire plus he
évidemment mais quand tu as gens il joue
mal machin il aura toujours les bons
rendez-vous oui bon il était vraiment
bien malade
quoi donc bah c un peu la raison de son
manque de forme en début de tournoi et
c'est pour ça que j'ai que c'est c'est
pas de bol de choper un virus quoi
ou benah ouioui est qui était tu es
vraiment vraiment bien bien bien
malade ça va
mieux euh
ouais je crois que c'est va un peu mieux
mais bon ça ça parlait de cracher du S
moment quand même enfin non mais c'était
pas enfin tu vois il jouit vraiment dans
des conditions difficiles
quoi c'est
pas mais bon rien de grave rassurez-vous
c'est bon mais
mais oui c'est
pas oui il est vraiment
finito c'était pas facile mais bon on a
voilà on a dû passer par là Maxime qui
revient dans le tourin pour ça moi
j'étais inquiet qui continue mais bon là
ça va mieux il a retrouvé la forme et
c'est pour ça qu'il remet les points
mais il est un peu tombé malade au pire
des moments après ça tu contrôles pas
les virus tu peux pas
contrôler
tu ne peux pas
contrôler moi je quand même qu'il habite
à
Paris tu habites pas tu habites à Paris
ah c'est vrai que si tu es tranquille à
la campagne tuas moins de chance de
croiser des gens et bah ouais mais c'est
c'est c'est quand même tu as beaucoup de
problèmes qui sont liés à met tu met
comison de de
spaionut cosmonaute ou
quoi protèges
quoi
tuas pas cherché au chose bah ouais St
c'estit tous les malheurs de ta vie sont
li à
Paris non mais bon ça ça arrive mais
c'est juste au pire moment quoi c'est
juste au pire
moment
après moi c'est beau quand quand je vois
qu'il y a les épidémies et tout je tu me
vois plus aller boire un café dans un
truc ou quoi tu V plus marché que moi je
regarde le non mais les endroits ouverts
sais que je regarde le site Sentinel
enfin je suis vraiment complètement fou
je déteste les virus non mais je te je
pense personne aime trop quoi non mais
je que je je les trque avec le site
Sentinel je regarde s'il quand il les P
d'épidémie
caché je fais très attention
fa livrer jeis désinfecter les sacs avec
qui va boire un café je vois qu'il y a
pas beaucoup de monde ou quoi je vais
mais si je vois que c'est bon de jou B
non j'ai pas très ouis non mais je te
jure premier degré quoi je déteste quoi
ou même je suis dégoûté de devoir
prendre le train et maintenant qu'il y a
les masques FFP2 je te jure je l' enfin
j'en ai rien à faire quoi je les déteste
en fait je je déteste la grippe en fait
je le dis non mais je le dis ouvertement
je ne supporte pas ce truc je l' attrapé
l'an dernier j'étais c'est
écuré non mais en dernier j'ai fait
covid grippe gastro enfin le triplet et
je fais gaffe mais bon je suis monté à
Paris non mais
vraiment moi je déteste je
déteste
ch fois que je reviens de Paris je tombe
malade mais pareil je sais pas comment
les gens réussissent à habiter à Paris
peut-être qu'il s'habitu quois ont un
système immunitaire
spécial essa de se rappeler je pense
qu'il essaie de choisir surt je sais pas
il peut jouer t C8 il peut jouer F C5
mais dame C6 c'est sûr qu'il avait hein
ah non mais c'est sûr ou et euh je sais
pas peut-êre y a d'autres coups ENF je
suis pas trop expert de la position donc
je peux moins vous dire que hier euh euh
mais j'imagine fou C5 et un coup tour C8
et un coup
voilà donc ça c'est svant firouja donc
voilà il a choisi la structure
de
de maroxi de maroxi et euh donc ça de
jouer mais c'est pas un mauvais choix
j'ai l'impression la part s Viant de
faire jouer une position comme ça moins
dynamique que d'autres siciliennes je
rappelle qu'il avait joué une partie
catastrophique dans le mar contre
cindarf en Coupe du Monde il y a 2 ans
ala en fait sindarf il nous la colle
tout le temps
quoi et euh et donc voilà bon avec les
noir soit il fait rien de SP il ro on a
dit soit il essaie de jouer sur le C D4
pas protéger avec K D7 ou C G4 donc k G4
voilà l'idée c'est de découvrir le fou
G7 forcer h Pranger prendre D4 e mais
bon ça ouvre cette colonne h du coup je
sais pas de visu je suis pas méga fan
mais bon euh
[Musique]
il a mat qui nous dit les coups pour
pour la position de
by ça pas bougé du tout et vid non plus
et by on dit c'est soit T C8 so soit f
oui mais
c'est5 c'est pas ouf déjà d jouer mais
que
s qu'il connait là il choisit il choisit
entre tour C8 et F6 il connait les deux
je connais B il connait les deux c'est
sûr
ok mais tu avais joué un truc comme ça
avec les Blancs g fait fou C5 à priori
et il avait joué fou D4 qui a prior donc
l'idée blanche dans la dans la
position et en cas d'échange en des4 ça
te ramène la dame centrale elle sera
bien et puis peut-être tu faire F F35
après j'imagine des choses comme ça quoi
demande si F5 a un coup F5 je pense
qu'après F F3 tu fais la gueule he bah
tomb quelqu'un qui te prend tu es très
heureux mais
sinon en fait le problème en fait F5
pourquoi c'est pourri c'est que tu es
mal développé avec les Noirs tu tuqu
c'est une dame un fou quoi voilà les
blanc ils ont roqué ils ont tout bien
mis tu es en train d'ouvrir le jeu alors
bah il se fit que le mec soit pas sympa
et à te faire 5 ou prend F et puis bah
tu t'es auto éventré quoi et puis c'est
foutu en plus tu t'as affaibli la
diagonale h 5 et 8 donc ouais tu touches
pas au pionf dans l'ouverture en gros
c'est une bonne règle et tu touches une
fois à l'occasion quand tu as une bonne
raison mais normalement tu pens pas à ce
genre de C là ça avance pas Maxime il
joue tout tempo mais ça me bute en fait
il est vraiment venu jouer tempo une
nouvelle fois non mais là il connaitt
non mais je sais mais je il est il fait
pas le truc que certains font que même
lui fait parfois dhésiter 30 secondes
machin
paramamam mais moi je suis sûr que c'est
une bonne enfin je sais qu'ils le font
jamais mais je sûr qu' faut mieux se
tromper une fois sur 10 mais tout
envoyer tempo non mais surtout quand tu
as le cveau qui marche pas HM
même quand il marche quoi ouais mais
peut-être tu joues mieux non mais j'ai
au moins dans l'ouverture tant que tu
connais vraiment parce qu'au final tu as
le temps de te rappeler sur son temps tu
mets un peu la pression puis à un moment
donné lui enfin tu vois il y a un vase
communiquant c'est que lui il va devoir
quand même plus se rappeler à un moment
donné si au lieu d'avoir 1h35 contre
1h25 tu as 1h44 contre 1h 28 je sais pas
en fait c'est pas forcément le temps que
tu as gagné mais le temps que ça lui a
coûté aussi la pression ouais puis le
mec déj réflection il est plus fatigué
pour momentir vraiment réfléchir de de
même si tu te trompes ça fait un truc à
la lev de bluff en fait où tu joue tempo
donc il sait pas si tu es dans ta prépa
il peut hésiter donc pourquoi
pas après je sais pas ouais ça aussi je
sais pas moi le F avec les
noirs du coup je te joue tempo ah mais
c'est sûr qu' jou tempo enfin par C 5 je
veux dire j'ai pas trop la rêf dans
l'espagnol mais dans l'italienne ça
arrive quand même quoi cl cette manœuvre
donc
le défaut c'est quand tu dois vraiment
réfléchir tu es en mode je joue vite
c'est pas simple de se calmer ouais mais
tu te calmes pas en fait Mathieu je suis
pas calme regarde je tu fais comme F
quoi non mais oui mais en fait ça va
avoir des en fait ça se défend mais
c'est pas optimal non plus quoi mais
mais je pense que oui surtout céit pas
en état de bien réfléchir faut le faire
mais je peux te dire que la dernière
fois à Paris enfin l'avant dernière fois
à Paris on allait jouer un match de de
Hook dans une salle d'arcade là ouais au
palais on a fait un matchp quo il m'a
battu 32 mais le match était épique mais
tu Ctait un peu ça
quo tu cherchais pas à cadrer tu vois
PAL tu fress de faire des rebonds ça
faisait jamais espèce de reprise pour
contrôler enfin on faisait que ça quoi
mais tu pas tu soulèves pas un peu le
pal pour faire contrôle de l'arrière et
c juste on se balancer truc dans la
tronche à fou quoi était très heureux
tous les deux
c'est vu qu'on est aussi con l'un que
l'autre on était très heureux de notre
match s félicité très beau match
c'est tu ne fermes pas le jeu tu es très
heureux quoi enfin joue contre se
respectter je pense que Maxim il
respecte beaucoup si continue à jouer
aussi oui bravo on finit tous les deux
avec
1h55 très bonne partie merci Alan Alan
il est pas parti pour
çaà un quart d'heure de
réflexion il un truc àer chez Pinko a
priori on pe aller
voir il joue qui ah ouais c'est beau
c'est
bizarre c'est n'importe quoi en fait il
joue tout
tempo il a fil une pièce ouais mais
tempo euh
ouais j'aime bien j'aime bien
intéressant bah il a donné une pièce
mais ce roi exposé et compagnie
[Musique]
euh bon ok he j'imagine faut regarder
plus en détail que ce que je raconte
bêtement mais je pens pe don un truc
comme ça ouais puis dame
de 3 3 quelque part un truc important
c'est que si tu fais ça ça marche pas
clé ouis parce que si tu avais tour PR1
fou F1 et fou H3 ça serait mat dans
l'autre sens mais mais cloué pas de
chance et du coup ouais on peut jouer
sur ce TR un peu au
centre gen t un fou dame de RO F8
peut-être je sais pas D4 et euh et tuas
pas G6 g fou H6 et c'est pas facile avec
le noir mais surtout s'il connait bienen
tout les astuces c'est si c'est logique
c'est tr bouff je te bouffe bou bou bou
bou j'ai envie de faire ça c'est le truc
on va dire plus logique fach un
peu mais ça peut très très mal se passer
pour ça peut être la partie de l'année
que si gagne qui se qualifie au
candidat ça pourrait être une des
parties de l'année parce que c'est beau
ce qui fait là i Pen ça c'est les beaux
échecs
ouais oui ça fait penser à des parties à
l'ancienne il va falloir bien défendre
qui con pour bien préparé et qui là est
surpris pris au dépourvu lorsque la bise
F
venue a jou cavalier ça l'avait pas il
de l'avoir mais
[Musique]
mais mais c'est pas sa recommandation
quoi tu penses que Fabiano
mais il a tout Fabian se rappelle pas
ah a deux parties dessus et c'est
bien tempo
c'est bien ou pas
Mathieu pas le mieux mais ça joue
ok il peut se rappeler de
tout normal il tout comment il fait ben
je pense qu'il fait beaucoup il fait que
ça plusieurs heures par
jour mais comment il
fait là non mais là en plus moi à sa
place j'aurais parce aujourd'hui si je
jouis contreti je sais qu'il va me faire
une C de 6 je passe pas matine à
regarder je vais pas être surpris par K
7 après 10 coups hein mais hier il a
joué 7h tu as pas envie de dormir non tu
tu travailles le matin je veux dire si
je décide que je joue le fou 3 à 3 bah
j'ai tout le plus loin que je peux quoi
mais tu as jamais mal à la tête pendant
les parties ouais enfin si mais non mais
bon tant pis enfin tu es là pour ça
c'est ton métier quoi tu tant pis tu
fais mais peut-être que lui il a pas du
tout mal d'ailleurs mais et toi ta ou
pas des fois ah mais des fois je je suis
pas bien et puis bon moi on s'en fout en
fait je mais
mais oui des fois je me sens mal
ouais je sou la coupe d'urope je sais
pas la première ronde j'étais
complètement KO je sais pas de quoi en
fait c'était plus la durée
mais mais non Fabi il va normalement
avoir très
loin on va voir moi c'est un truc ça
m'impressionne toujours non mais par
contre si B qui avait jou 066 du tournoi
tu t'attends pas tu il joue je sais pas
il joue ce qu'il veut dans le tournoi la
français ou quoi et que là il te
surprend avec si 6 et que tu as tout
jusqu'au là bon ok
euh c'est un peu le scénario de la
partie de U en fait où il a voulu
surprendre et du coup il avait pas
vraiment tout et B avait pas forcément
vérifié donc il avait pas les réfutes
non plus quoi alors que là c'est un
scénario différent ok bon là alira il
tank c'est un très bon choix je trouve
la part de Sv en fait ouais très très
bien joué intéressant peut-être que Mazo
va étudier ça avec
plaisir non mais en fait ouais le
c'est pas plaisant pour tout le
monde soit pour les blancs et pour les
Noirs mais un joueur comme firou qui a
mettre un peu l'activité ou quoi c'est
sûr ce doit pas le ravir
quoi il a ramené le fond 7 il a fait des
ok je pas il peut jouer plein de coup là
Maxime
mais- qu' va jouer tempo c'est la
question fait ouais moi je suis pas trop
experte C avec le F H4 ça fait penser
aux italienn ou quoi quoi mais euh du
coup je sais pas si tu joues tour 1 k de
comme d'hab tu veux mettre le C à 3 tu
pe des plans différents des idées tour
j'imagine ça mange pas de pain mais bon
c'est peut-être pas le plus précis non
plus he mais voilà une carou ouais
réfléchi chez vit mais
bon eter ça réfléchi toujours il il a
joué en fait c'est le coup dont Mathieu
nous parlait la ligne qu'il avait
analysé lui 5 tour T 1 pour clouer dame
7 tu défends tu déclous tu dégages avec
dame c'est quoi fou G4 ça F3 fou prend
pas mal mais sur fou prend calier prend
tu peux pas faire dame prend tuas la
tour qui
traî dame à 4 échec roi D8 ça metton D4
tu contreclou tu attaques la pièce
clouée et quoi y GK tu prends dame
C5 ok bah écoute s'il a vu tout ça Ker
c'est pas mal je pense qu'il connaît
hein sinon il peut connaît pens'il
connait il s'est juste rappelé c'est
terrible et genre ça finit en 0 nul
parce que tu es obligé de
oua on verra ok on reviendra dessus pour
voir on s'en fout sans s'en parce
que ça joue la Calif mais ok il y a un
PERP mais c'est pas nos
joueurs bah en fait le seul qui est
important pour Calif entre guillemets
pour nous enfin à part les joueurs
français bien évidemment c'est Naka qui
qui rendrait service à firouo com après
si Naka perd et fou gagne peut-être on
enfin on sait pas trop en fait mais Naka
de base vaut mieux qu'il gagne gagagah
disons de toute façon on est ou qui perd
perd perd perd perd on a un intérêt à
suivre ce que fait Naka quoi ouais on
sait pas trop pourquoi on est mais on
est intéressé c'est une info
importante mais de base base base base
base celui qui a les meilleures chances
d'aller au candidat encore côté français
c'est de loin firouja grâce à ce truc de
Hello parce que même si Naka passe pas
il
peut il peut très bien là bien finir
finir à égalité de Naka avoir deux
points de moins avant le grand chest
tour et puis le le Raso poteau et
peut-être après tout le monde va jouer
comme des enfin je sais pas ce qu'ils
vont faire en fait
ah faut voir enfin à la fin Dee façon ça
va être un B s ce tournoi parce que bah
tu joues que pour le gain là tu étais
pas encore en mais je dire si les deux
jouent encore pour ce Calif Aléo que
nous on organise des faux tournois
truquer pour le faire ah ouis non mais
ça que aussi ils organisent des faux
tournois ouais mais il y aura pas non
mais par contre que Naka il joue des
Open ou firou qui se démerde mais
après
B nous on a déjà les mallettes d'espèces
prêt on a les 20 les 20k dans la banane
quoi on est déjà là à vouloir distribuer
quoi le point vaut cher il jeam il
connaissent lui sûr qu'il connaî mais je
pense que l'autre
aussi mais là du coup G4 donne envie si
tu F
F3 tu là c'est une petite tactique en de
coups quoi
donc ce qui est beau c'est que fou G4 tu
es content de faire F3 pour lui mettre
le F F3 pour lui enlever les C Val F3
ouais tu dégages comme ça tu dégages ta
dame parce que si tu dégages ta dame en
premier ben ça recommence ouais bah tu
prends tu prends B5 ça C6 ça et ça on
pourrait la faire en vidéo cette partie
ça fait la nul HM joli enfin sera ce
sera le résumé du soir une vidéo de 3
minutes quoi non mais l'idée est belle
et c'est bah c'est con que enfin une
réutation une égalisation en force enfin
ça tu bien que soit ça et que tu joues
tu as une pièce de moins et tu as une
position à la con et ouais ça faight et
là le problème ça risque d'être très
vite très sec
quoi et nous on serait capable de
truquer le tourno en fait he si
làb ça ferait marrer mais bon je bien
que non en fait un beau métier ce sera
agent de joueur un peu comme au foot tu
es agent de joueur d'échec tuis que je
suis sûr que ça a dû exister non mais tu
as plusieurs joueurs et du coup tu tu
passes des appels c'était là un peu
comme M valencienne quoi ouais machin tu
as entendu parler du tournoi grand chest
tour apparemment Naka pourrait se
retirer pour te laisser jouer mais mais
bon faut aujourd'hui enfin tu vois tu tu
es là tu passes des appels de partout
toute la journée quoi tuapp tu
appppelles s f lui tu veux un américain
au mais en gros c'est plus ou moins ce
que Fisher reprochait au russes dans les
années 60 ouais en ou mais oui c'est euh
après je sais pas à quel point c'était
réel ou si f avait une paranoou pis tu
as trois téléphones tu es là tuappelles
machin ouais il y a vidit qui me
confirme qu'il veux bien perdre et TOUT
Rex du coup tu l'invites au grande chis
Naka c'est bon on est sur le coup tu as
pas besoin de préparer la Game c'est bon
c'est bon je suis sur le coup c'est un
métier qui est énorme tu truces tous les
tournois toutes les parties tu es aussi
avec non mais tu es aussi avec le site
de paris machin tu écris un sms WhatsApp
fais gaffe faut que tu changes la côte
parce que c'est sûr ça y est j'ai acheté
la tu finis comme Tonali quoi après tu
es suspendu à vie ouais mais bon enfin
tu as truqué trois candidats quatre
matchs de championnat du monde enfin tu
es de partout quoi aucun temp n'avait
aucune valeur enfin tu es très heureux
il sable 60 qui tu vraiment paranoïqueah
il
éta mais le truc c'est qu'il avait
peut-être des raisons deêtre aussi après
peut-être qu'il était trop par rapport à
ce que c'était vraiment
mais il trro original
ouais bon après tu vois j'ai pas connu
l'époque tu vois j'ai que vu un peu dans
les livres les trucs ici ou là donc dis
erreur de firou bah
non enfin oui tu tu peux faire fprend
des quat B nous on avait plutôtprend des
qu c'est ce qu'on pensait pour avoir le
rapport matériel ou ouais mais il fait
pas les stages avec mazoou non mais
c'est le rappelle vraiment de la partie
contre sindarof elle était horrible sa
partie mais horrible mais moi je suis
pas ravi deou voir ce colonage je sais
pas je le sens pas parce que je sais pas
trop quand je vais rocker il y a la
torchin du coup qui s'est développé par
elle-même sans
efforts bon on
verra
[Musique]
mais dit bah qui prend une grosse prépa
en fait il pour les deux ont prépa donc
il jouent leur truc l'un l'autre mais
Carona conna évidemment enfin mais ça
c'était sûr enfin il y avait aucun doute
quoi qu'il savait que serait CEN aussi
c'est que bah c'est carwana hein c'est
[Musique]
pas désolé j'ai j'ai du mal à sortir de
mon délire là là non mais là dans ma
tête là je suis agent de joueur AG tu
vois là je fait je suis dans un délire
où je suis agent de joueur et et je suis
en train de savoir comment je fais
gagner à Naka les les les candidats si
tu veux là moi je suis quasiment en
train d'appeler ramche pour lui dire
mais ça c'est je pense c'est trop dur
d'arriver à le faire qualifié peut-être
tu peux tu peux mais en fait je sais pas
pour moi si tu es joueur d'échec tu les
candidats c'est le truc de ta vie quoi
bah moi je suis déjà en train d'appeler
RAM c'est comme si tu trucques une
finale de Coupe du Monde de foot moi je
sais pas combien il faut donner mais en
fait moi je pense que je prends enfin je
écoute tuas tu as pragan dedans tu as
peut-être qui va y être tu as er qui
peut aussi être dedans
ouais en fait je pense ça pas de prix
d'être champion du monde d'échec si si
tu peux
l'être
ouais mais bon après si a mi parcours tu
es un peu derrière machin est-ce que tu
peux un peu lever le
pied c'estd contre qui Bab
Bab pour les
blancs moi je suis en je suis déjà dans
un délire où où Corneto il est secondant
d'un joueur où il m'envoie ses prépas ù
je lu dis laisse un trou dans T un trou
variante après je lu rends je suis déjà
dans le délireù je rends un service
ouais c'est ça je un peu le je fais un
peu la plu le BE
temp et puis tu peux un peu tout mais
pourquoi il joue pas visite tu es un peu
le peut-être il y a ramche qui lui a dit
ne joue pas je sais c'est ça j'ai r au
téléphone il est passé ouais ou je
chapote un peu tout si tu
[Musique]
veux je te conseille de parler qu'un fa
venir sur la cas G7 je dis ça je dis
rien j'ai même la fille qui m'appelle
machin et tu sais je j'organise c'est
dans tel pays machin enfin tu vois non
mais tu peux tout scénariser après ouais
tu fais
star
ouais love story quoi
enfin je sais pas combien on arrive du f
G7 le chat je pense va
être de quoi il parle quoi le bordel ce
serait un mercato
d'échec bah ce serait beau en fait en
fait ça serait pas si mal euh mais il
faudrait que tu joues que pour un club
parce que là en fait dans l'état actuel
des choses
bcoup tu as pas tuas pas un gros mercato
mais si tu joues pour un club seulement
et que tu as pas trop le choix tu peux
être recruté dans un pays dans un autre
machin moi j'aurais dit ce serait une
des premières réformes si je un
président de la feed c'est un club par
joueur je veux rien savoir et on arrête
de changer de pays comme on veut et de
fédération pour représenter 40 milliards
de pays en fait mais ça déjà oui non
mais ça et ça ça s'arrête déjà c'est
instantané et après je lance le projet
des agents de
joueur et toi et toi tu es l'agent des
agents quoi et ais je suis au-dessus
quoi faut te payer la licence d'agent et
bon
ouais ça existe déjà pour les interclub
ouais mais vite fait il y a pasité de
transfert et de de ouais c'est vrai que
ça fait un peu bizarre de voir les mêmes
équipes dans tous les pays quoi c'est
catastrophique en fait c'est et ça
laisserait plus de chance au aux joueurs
locaux de leur club machin enfin c'est
pas si mal en fait comme idée évidemment
c'est juste absolument même pas pas si
mal c'est juste c'est une évidence tu
pas un weekend au Real la semaine
d'après au PSG 3 semaines après Arsenal
enfin c'est tu fais pas une coupe dévis
avec la France la semaine d'après j'ai
changé j'ai changé puis après tu re
rechanges enfin c'est il y a un moment
donné c'est pas possible bah nous c'est
possible depuis longtemps hein mais mais
oui je sais pas pour on est sur cette
partie on Fa on est rest parce que c'est
la plus belle partie pour le moment donc
on s'attendait et by bon on va voir donc
il a fait F5 donc le en prise mais
évidemment pas vraiment puisque le pion
est cloué et Carana juste enlever son
fou il est venu en
F4 bon voir comment ça continue mais
mais donc d'après Matthieu lui connait
la position c'est plutôt avantage blanc
alors je sais pas à quel point
mais je veux bien le croire enfin déjà
je fait à ce qu'il dit mais même
visuellement ce que je vois je veux bien
croire que ça puisse être mieux pour les
blancs simplement parce que bah plutôt
mieux développer les tours vont arriver
au centre et euh SK F5 faut voir où
est-ce qu'il va atterrir parce qu'à un
moment il va enlever son totem d'imunité
faut regarder si qui desin qui a un coup
pour les blancs ouou des trucs comme ça
quoi met qu'un club si tu commences à de
jouer au lendemain la moitié des joueurs
sont dans la grosse merde la différence
au foot il y a un match chaque semaine
en France ah ouais mais Mathieu au bout
d'un moment c'est la normalité peut-être
je te prends pas du jour au lendemain au
début je fais deux clubs quoi enfin tu
descends étape par étape descend par
étape par étape mais je te préviens que
dans 5 ans c'est finito mais mais moi je
pense que le marché il s'autorégule en
fait je fais confiance à la main
invisible du marché et je me dis que du
coup bah les clubs ils vont devoir payer
un peu plus cher pour les joueurs et que
au final ça va s'équilibrer hein puis
bon du coup la saison elle peut être
organisée différemment pas obligé qu' 11
match d'ailleurs ouais et mais en
contrepartie aussi pour les joueurs bah
du coup j'organiserai un championnat par
équipe rapide et Blitz c'est championnat
France c'est 38 matchs ok mais 11 ça va
pas ouais mais c'est un sport individuel
Mathieu le foot tu as pas de compète
individuel enfin tu c'est comme ça
hein mais bon je suppose que si tu fais
ça que tu organises sur 3 jours un truc
en rapide un autre truc en 2 jours en
blitz
oui puis tu peux faire un championnat 20
équipe match àer retour puis du coup la
Coupe d'Europe ça payera plus
cher mais c'est pas c'est pas possible
d'avoir autant de club enfin ça n'existe
nulle part en fait ça peut pas exister
en soi ça peut juste pas exister en
soi HM pu jouer dansutre
club et le changement de nationalité
c'est changement de nationalité c'est
pas possible aussi ouais ça peut pas
marcher comme ça c'est deux trucs
différents mais qui vont pas ouais enfin
ou moi le changement de nationalité ça
me j'ai jamais aimé et peut-être tu le
fais une fois si vraiment tu déménages
tu changes de pays pour de bon mais là
en fait c'est tu tu bouges pas
physiquement et tu joues à la carte pour
qui tu veux quand tu veux quoi non en
fait moi je pense juste que en fait moi
dans mon esprit faire ça ça ça peut que
être positif à moyen terme h non je
pense que ça va marcher enfin c'est
l'objectif c'est pasenever truc c'est
sur le coup mais en fait je pense que ça
peut être que positif à moyen terme du
coup de créer un vrai
truc parce que peut-être les joueurs
pourra récupérer une partie sur le
transfert ou je sais pas quoi après
ouais tu as des joueurs qui sont dans le
même club d'un pays et qui s'affrontent
dans un autre ah ouais complètement ah
bah oui
oui c'est ton coéquipier ici c'est plus
le coéquipier là-bas le le pire c'est
quand c'est ton coéquipier enfin que T
plusieurs clubs qualifi tous en Coupe
d'Europe et que tu vas planter ton je
sais pas dire t pas un club allemand un
club espagnol et tuis jouer avec le club
espagnol et que bah il se trouve
toujours contre ton club allemand mais B
oui mais tu es là et puis tu tu la
col nationalité com certain Vadis moi en
fait je laisserai les joueurs changer de
nationalité jouer dans une autre équipe
si N jamais jouer dans leur équipe
nationale dans l'autre équipe
nationale d'Europe ben ou en championnat
d'Asie enfin de ton continent tu veux
plus changer de pays ou en tout cas
faudrait des règles beaucoup plus
strictes peêtre 5 ans après ou 10 ans
après ou j'en sais rien mais que ce soit
pas tu puisses pas instantanément tu
joues pour la Hongrie lendemain tu joues
pour la Roumanie enfin ou non tuas un
lien de parenté très proche genre si
c'est un parent ou mais tu peux pas
changer de nationalité comme ça comme tu
as envie en fait
non en France tu as besoin de
nationalité pour jouer dans le pays il y
a des pays tu peux dire
ou sais ou ouais non en France bah il y
a des gens qui ont changé bah Vlade OK
ou quoi mais ils sont vraiment devenus
Français ils parlent la langue ils ont
vécu ici o ils vivent
encore mais ils ont envoyé la caillass
quoi voilà c'est pas juste juste tiens
ah ouis tiens ben je vais reprp une
année d'après ah là-bas
et ça c'est sûr que ça va pas
ouais
donc firou c'est ok bah moi firou il
aurait pas pu jouer en enfin représenter
la France avoir la nationalité française
il a tout à fait le droit mais jouer en
équipe national pour moi oui vu ce qu'on
dit on aura dit non en fait non mais
peut-être un 40 j'en sais rien moi mais
mais bon après c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça
hein après on n pas à Sauto mettre des
des ball les sélections avant 21 ans
pourrait ne pas compter voilà après
peut-être que voilà il peut y avoir des
cas aussi où sélection avant 18 ans ou
21 ans voilà mais tu dois pas pouvoir
faire comme tu veux maintenant
mais
euh mais pour les interclubs moi je suis
sûr que limité à un
club bah disant je pense que tu crées
une identité en faisant ça je pense ça
moi je pense qu'à moyen terme c'est
positif en fait j'en suis sûr mais comme
je te disais je multiplierai peut-être
un petit peu les compétitions oui du
coup je rajouterai quand même le truc en
rapide et en blitz qui pourrait
compenser quand même pour les joueurs un
petit peu plus il pourrait payer quand
même plus cher parce que bah tu donnes
ton exclusivité à un club ouais donc
quand même c'est plus intéressant la
Coupe d'Europe ça lui donne peut-être de
l'intérêt et et de deux tu peux faire
plus de rencontres et puis des matchs à
domicile machin peut-être tu pour avir
des investisseurs locaux qui mettrai
dans ton club qui tu auras des matchs à
domicile tu je sais pas enfin bon ça a
jamais trop été fait il y a pas un
engouement de fou mais et j'obligeraiis
aussi que ce soit les mêmes dates pour
les interclubs dans dans chaque pays
oui comm ça tu peux faire un calendrier
où les tournoi et des dates dis spécial
interclub ou
quoi
voir non après tu aurais deux choix
peut-être des trucs qui veulent marcher
par weekend qui a le droit de marcher
par weekend et le truc qui veut marcher
sur 10 jours qui a sa date pour faire
son truc mais ça c'est vraiment un truc
que je
ferais ils ont déjà pas mal de compè en
club B non pas vraiment en fait
c'est juste que comme tu peux jouer dans
autant de club que tu veux tu as
l'impression qu' parce qu'en plus ils
sont des dates qui se collent pas pour
vraiment tu puisses faire le tour de des
club
quoi mais tuis j'irais même jusqu'à
peut-être essayer de faire un truc
Mondial des clubs
par Internet du coup à la fin tu es dans
ton club avec des arbitres machin et le
gars qui gagne la Coupe
d'Europe le mec qui gagne le championnat
d'Asie qui gagne chaque équipe qui gagne
son
Contin fais par Internet du coup
[Musique]
mais tu dois surveillé ça pour le truc
en rapide qui ce qui gag des trucs en
rapide à la fin tu vois tu peux comme ça
tu fais un peu
un tu peux faire un petit show dans ton
cl dans ta ville tu vois tu es là tu
peux avir les support les gens qui
viennent dans ton club tu as les joueurs
qui sont dans ton club tu vois un petit
truc mais tu vois j'ess de plus inclure
les gens en fait le public les
spectateurs crée un peu une identité
locale mais tu vois moi si c'était comme
ça je serais capable d'investir de la
cillass dans un club he juste là ça
aucun en fait le truc c'est que là faut
comprendre que pour les gens qui sont
dans les écheces ou quoi quoi ça aucun
intérêt parce que le club n'existe pas
enfin du coup en fait c'est débile le
truc
ouais non ça mais sinon je pourrais tu
vois aider un club dire B tiens on a
notre club machin est là tu aimes bien
les joueurs tu aimes bien bien la ville
tu aimes
bien tu le mets où le foot en C2 ou A2
moi je mets en
C2 moi je joue pas l'Espagne non mais
Maxim il va jouer tempo
après donc B écoute sa récite un côté
Fabi F4 qui H4 tourd1 première petite
réflexion t Fd1 mais on petite il
connaissait hein c'est sûr euh donc
j'imagine qu'il doit vouloir se laisser
la case F1 pour le fou
éventuellement mais ce Kage 4 je sais
pas trop enfin je ben en fait en fait
comme je connais pas bien la position
j'ai du mal à dire mais je me dis que
les blancsement ils sont pas mécontents
de te faire fou G3 il te il te retirent
le cavalier d'où il est et après il a
plus que G6 tu fais H4 désolé je coupe
une seconde parce que chess by step
quand on parle un peu des clubs P ça
intéresse aussi les gens il dit un truc
très intéressant que j'ai oublié de dire
c'est pour ça que je le reprendre il dit
les clubs de taille moyenne avec une
bonne équipe locale pourront enfin
rester plusieurs années en Top 16 et
c'est ce que je voulais dire c'est qu'au
final les équipes elles sont quand même
financé de manière très directe par de
l'argent public donc par nos impôts par
ta cayass ma caillass la cayass de tout
le monde et quelque part le fait que les
clubs qui font de la formation qui vont
dans les écoles et qui font de la
formation pour les joueurs soi
récompensés puisque du coup ils ont un
meilleur terrier quand même dans ces
cas-là le terro ouais un terrier aussi
mais du coup bah du coup ça fait baisser
le niveau moyen mais donc si ça fait pas
mal de formation bah tu as quand même un
avantage quo enfin je comprends que ça
se défend et je trouve que c'est aussi
un autre côté sympa si tu ouais bah
tiens on est allé dans les écoles machin
bah on fait jouer notre mais que tu es
des joueurs locaux qui do tissu local
qui joue quand même et finalement V que
c'est de l'argent public qui finance
tout ça c'est aussi normal que ça
récompense les clubs qui le non non mais
je qui le dépense bien quoi je pense
c'est un cercle vertueux de faire ça en
fait d'accord que des joueurs locaux
doivent jouer dans les clubs quoi mais
mais bon
euh après bon tu as des clubs qui ont
quand même des partenaires
privés moi je
part moi je suis partenaire privé d'un
club on a rien à faire de vos écoles de
machin on envoie la cayas sur les
meilleurs tiens regarde un petit jeune
qui joue bien VI te récupère oui bien s
mais on sa que tu es agent mais oui moi
je suis agent après je truc les matchs
tiens tu veux nous rejoindre dans le
club l'an prochain ouis Tiy donne le
point C
année on a une place en 2è division
tiens en top jeune aussi regarde
j'organise un tour à ferm dans 3
semaines norme de Grand Maître et j'ai
deux trois grand maîtres que je connais
sur la liste qui pouront te laisser des
punos tu veux ta norme faut laisser moi
ça serait
terrible mais en France l'État finance
les clubs d'échec à complètement oua les
clubs ont des subventions des mairies
machin quand tu payes ta taxe foncière
ou quoi j'adore appeler aux gens qui
payent quoi pour les échec ouais tu
payes en fait c'est toi qui non mais
après selon les villes tu as pas les
mêmes budgets évidemment tuas des villes
qui vont donner plus moins tuas pas la
même taxe fonci et cetera
quoi mais en général les assauts ils
reçoivent plus ou moins une
subventionchecs les clubs c'est des
assaut
ouis qui payent les joueurs tes impôts
quoi globalement du X ou
Y ça fait très
plaisir estce que il était content qui
paye ça c'est toi du coup merde je pas
payer Mo tu as payé quand même les
sponsors aussi ouais mais il y a pas
beaucoup de sponsors et puis les
sponsors de toute façon comme il donne
une association à but non lucratif ils
font de l'optimisation fiscale donc en
fait c'est toi qui
paye ça est ça m'a rendu tellement
heureux là entre le délire d'agent et ça
Fab là je suis je suis au top du live là
c'est le le live est réussi la partie
Carana Baki qui va être sympa il y AA
qui fait des trucs voà c'est un des
meilleurs live de l'année pour moi tiens
au cas où euh ici il ils ont jouer ou ça
ça réfléchit à fondou je crois qu'il se
met dans dans une dans dans un caca noir
ouais peut-être qu' est content ça va
être compliqué il veut faire tour C8 te
provoquer B3 te faire des merdes sur la
[Musique]
diagonale Maxime il réfléchit ok il
hésite entre les deux cases vidit bon ça
il a joué4 ici p ouais mais c'est sûr
qu' con ouais il doit savoir que c'est
nul en force il veut vraiment mais mat
nous av dit un truc tout à l'heure que
tu peux avir une ligne peut-être où tu
files une qualité et c'est pas clair et
ça joue donc on va voir SP si euh si
vous voulez juste tester pas risquer ou
s'il va tout trentter et jouer avec la
qualité de moins alors je sais pas
quelle est la ligne he pour tomber
dedans
mais on va voir et donc dame à 4 ici
plus ou moins forcé enfin pas plus ou
moins forcé tout court
il do avoir le SE et si pien qui ah bon
tu peux te douter
que il peut connaître tu espère que que
ça va passer mais ouais là ça passe pas
mais bon fa jouer roi des8 c'est pas non
plus si évident parce tu as des coups
comme K fd7 ou quoi qui sont peut-être
inférieurs mais dis pourquoi je me
droque ou après il est peut-être pas fin
psychologue et sipenco de jouer tempo
tu vois du marlou type Gricha non mais
tu as dit que tu voulais que ça clique
mais alors là mais non mais alors là
pourquoi je te dis ça que tu dois faire
semblant que l'autre s'est
trompé tempo là il sait que c'est prépa
tu s s'est trompé du coup tu fais dame à
4 et il est moins sûr de lui je me suis
trompé tu vois ouis tu tqu un bon 15 20
minutes mais peut-être que l'autre il
sait que c'est ça oui mais si c'est pas
en fait tu as tanké ou machin tu le
laisses
paniquerou mais bon c'est sûr si tu
comprends que tu dois mettre le kf6
plutôt en G4 tu joues pasd7 mais faut
comprendre pas mal de
choses Maxime qui hésite sur quelle
diagonale MRE le fou j'imagine que les
de être jouable estce que serait pas le
moment de faire la la petite pause parce
que c'est un peu l'heure et je crois que
c'est voilà ça c'est on s on s'est
arrêté d'envoyer des coups un peu
partout et donc on va pouvoir vous
laisser avec le grand écran et on se
retrouve dans une diaine de minutes
allez B à tout de
[Musique]
suite
he he
he he he
he
he he
[Musique]
he
les amis on est de retour alors la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'il s'est passé ça ça
joue la varante avec la qualité de plus
là il a pas joué le cavalier fg4 il a
fait le foupron
G2 Ker alors bonne nouvelle pas
forcément pour les joueurs français mais
juste va y avoir une partie sympa ouais
donc avec une qualité d'avance pour les
Noirs contre un pion mais c'estes pion
centraux qui bah qui prennent de la
place qui prennent de l'espace et
une position
peu peu commune mais intéressante les
tours qui ont pour l'instant du mal à
s'exprimer et on va voir ça don dans ce
combat qui clairement c'est ce qu'il
fait il encore he 41 à la pendule donc
il doit savoir sûrement l'agencement des
pièces à suivre après Fabiano Carona
contretien il a jou Fd1 et ça réfléchit
côté
B
B je sais pas je sais pas ENF le
problème c'est comme je connais pas bien
la position et que j'imagine qu'elle est
censée être connue je sais pas trop
j'imagine que sur un coup comme F 7 il y
a peut-être F G5 qui est relou ou pas je
sais
pas pour qui fou prend dame prend du
coup ça amène la dame vers G5 ça va
forcer k G6 et là peut-être H4 et tout
d'un coup on est un peu embêteré alors
je sais pas si c'est ça la ligne ou quoi
tu peux peut-être développer F C5
peut-être en G6 mais pourquoi faire le
tour de alors il a joué fou E7 et donc
bon ben le coup moi j'imagine c'est fou
G5 prise dame prank et G6 et je pensais
à H4 intuitivement H6 dame G3 j'aurais
dit G4 je sais pas quelque part par là
rock pous
encore7 que tour D6 on
peut puis l'autre tour en AD1 après je
sais pas si c'est une bonne idée tour D6
parce qu'elle peut plus trop bouger à
cause d pr G3 j'en sais rien bon ce
genre de position qu'est-ce que ça donne
j' j'urais l'impression de préférer les
blancs mais peut-être tu fais C vite tu
dégages la tour et cetera et et que là
justement ceux qui proposaient F5 tout à
l'heure ça devient un thème donc à voir
mais bon en tout cas fou fou G5 semble
me semblerait le coup logique à essayer
de faire fonctionner après à voir la
suite quoi al en fait il fait fou G5 fou
prend dame prend cavalier G6 et dame D2
il veut pas que tu ro mais bon ok tour
D8 dame D4 rock 4 ben ça pas l'air si
grave
ouais bon c'est un petit truc surtout
c'est pas facile avec les blans de
trouver ça non or peut-être qui sait
hein moi je reste confiant pas pour
gagner attention mais pour nul je reste
confiant on verra ce qui va nous jouer
là le
Fabi qui s'étouffe j'ai failli envoyer
du thé partout
ouais donc F 6 jouer par alira donc bon
on nime pas trop comment il a traité la
position mais bon maintenant c'est fait
c'est fait et avec F6 donc j'imagine
qu'il veut tour C8 donc pour attaquer
attaquer C4 et provoquer B3 à ce
momentlà tu auras peut-être des Cali F3
des trucs comme ça donc est-ce que
euh moi je sais pas le cou qui
spontanément c'est tour C1 quoi en fait
pour les blancs ça sur tour C8 je peux
faire B3 en
et euh puis après on verra je peux avoir
des B5 qui marchentuc comme
ça je
pas en fait mon idée c'est cavalier
prend cavalier prend dame dame à 5 tu as
pas dame D2 à cause de tour prend C1
pour montrer parce que ça me paraissait
être la vente la plus logique non mais
peut-être he que B5 a une idée mais bon
après c'est à lui de voir est-ce que
est-ce qu'il fait se tors un est-ce que
il joue pas tour C1 mais
F4 bon parce que quand même tu as envie
F4 F5 euh ça l' difficile à parert tour
C attaque
C4 bon c'est une position compliquée
avec beaucoup de calcul mais ça peut
être du jeu à trois résultat même si on
voit que la jauge préfère nettement Sam
sviant bah en fait visuellement j'aime
mieux les blancs mais je vois que c'est
pas des coups trop simples tu des Vendes
compliqué et peut-être ça peuter à à
alirea ce style de je après bon c'est VI
il s'est calculé c'est pas plus un idiot
donc on verra Maxime ouais bon ça clique
hein G3 ça c'est de c'est 5 bon c'est
des coups normaux un peu de part et
d'autres qu'on a l'habitude de voir dans
les Espagnols après voir comment le jeu
va se développer voilà la différence
d'habitude
c'est c'est cette histoire de fou3 qui3
est
pensé j'imagine le jour où tu fais des4
tu mets quand même plus de pression sur
le centre noir parce que tu tu tapes 5
bien comme il faut et ce et cetera donc
en tout cas clairement c'est c'est
l'intention des blancs d'arriver à jouer
cette percée
centrale VI bon ça se développe vidit
voilà ça joue sans trop de risque chez
vidit euh voilà après a d'autres parties
peut-être qu'on ira faire un tour plus
tard dans parmi les leader mais donc là
c'est c'est kimer qui a décidé de jouer
avec la qualité bon il a joué FC al
leord dit interrogation mais je sais pas
enfin je peux pas vous dire s'il dit
n'importe quoi ou pas façon ça jou 6 là
c'est sûr bon c'est pas tellement
logique parce que que en fait justement
les blan qui veulent pas se faire pion
prend puisque après pion prend en train
d'ouvrir des colonnes à droite à gauche
et justement les tours c'est ce qu'elle
réclame donc ça c'est pas trop l'idée
des blancs à priori hein ce serait de
garder le jeu fermé la masse de pion
centrale avec 6 alors peut-être que je
sais pas s'il veut faire fou D6 puis C6
un jour quand même pour pour ouvrir mais
tuas faire k C3 cavalier E4 machin je
pas c'est compliqué juste c'est très
compliqué c'est
intéressant Baki ça réfléchit côté car
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle quand
même pas dit quiil trouve hein mais je
sais même pas à quel point c'est grave
hein non mais ça se peut qu'il est même
pas l'avantage en fait Fabi au final
h tellement dur même quand tu as les
prépa après de les de les transformer ah
bah ouais bah ça serait trop simple
sinon quoi juste tu es mieux préparé
avec l'autre tu as gagné bon
parce que là vraiment le truc avec F G5
machin revenir avec Dame D2 mais je sais
pas c'est la M c'est la turbinette qui
raconte ça bon pas l'air idot quand même
fa une confiance juste très limitée quo
çaait l'air
fort qu'on a vu avec le A4 à la fin un
petit avantage a
priori le défaut 6 B5 c'est que ça peut
être une structure qui se fait toucher
justement par un coup comme
4 et donc c'est assez jolie
bon on est un peu en attente là des coup
on a un peu fait le tour des des
échiqués pourtant on a pris beaucoup
mais on est dans le dans le ventre
mou Fab est en prépa jusque là après
fou7 comme c'est pas un des premiers
coups ça peut l'avoir sorti un peu à
l'image de You qui avait sorti Baky de
la prpA en ayant fait en faisant une
erreur et
h et les femmes ça donnent quoi fa tu pe
peut-être jeter un coup d'œil sur sur le
téléphone Sophie qui fait un beau
tournoi c'est son anniversaire
aujourd'hui euh qui joue contre la sœur
de Prague vasaliie Vali vchali enfin je
ch euh bon écoute ça joue c'est une
Espagnole c'est une Espagnole quoi ouais
bon c'est ça joue quoi euh on verra on
fera un petit fil rouge on vous dira
Pauline Guichard c'est compliqué c'est
quoi ce truc c'est une
catalane je regarde un truc sans jauge
quoi donc euh j'ai l'impression que
c'est mieux pour son adversaire mais bon
tu vois c'est vu
comme ça et je crois qu'il y a deux
leadus leader je comment qui s'affronte
mus Stepanova et pareil
compliqué on verra et dans les autres
parties chez chez les hommes enfin
mixte qu'est-ce qu'on a
donc
suit c'est grand structure de Carl BAD a
recommencé un peu son délire qu' avait
eu rondin qu' jou avec au centre il pas
OK et donc il garde l'opportunité de
balancer ses pions à l' droit donc
intéressant on verra on verra ce qu'il
en est deatch face à vtassek
assez égal assez égal c'est une
italienne il a peut-être un léger plus
avec les Blancs doit se tenir sans trop
de mal pour pour Vassek pr que fait être
intéressant il un tellement bon
départage ce pr que écoute il a donné un
pion pour avoir une pression dans la
Catalane genre de position classique
donc
position à compensation
et tout peut se passer en fait enfin
soit il va aller racler les trucs soit
soit f CF va dérer son avantage et
avance ça s'équilibre ok donc il peut se
passer des choses chez pr que F CF en
tout cas et puis après on a le groupe
avec un peu moins de points donc Bonon
n' pas joué il a fait nul contre contre
nan donc Aronian abandonne toute vité
toute vité toute intention d'essayer de
rattraper les les joueurs devant mais
c'est dur il a déjà du retard mais voilà
rapport il contre Sarana c'est une
hollandaiseoute rpport il prend sa
chance l'hollandaise c'est une ouverture
risqué donc on
verraarinov Doua sa
fight il essaie de mettre une petite
pression à
sindarov l' de connaître ce qu'il fait
et param qui tente avec avec les pièces
noiresfin qui joue contre contre
terarian pas un adversire facile mais
euh écoute si param gagne celle-là il se
replace donc voilà c'est un peu ça le
truc che parinov gagne sans jouer euh
bah écoute moi j'ai pas les j'ai pas les
évaluations donc je sais pas jouer une
position compliquée mais peut-être c'est
écrasant hein euh c'est possible hein
que tu plantes un tour C1 et que il
reste 1h38 contre contre 50 minutes hein
et du coup bah si tu sais pas plante une
prépa euh bravo à lui il aura attrapé
euh Douda mais il sait ou il sait pas
bah écoute s'il est 1h38 contre 53
minutes je me dis qu'il sait ce qu'il
fait quoi non tu t'appelles je sais
pas mais c'est C5 le coup clé à priori
qui devait pas trop s'attendre
Douda c'est un joli coup tu on prends
j'imagine
c'est on regardera avec les gens plus
tard une fois que ce sera terminé mais
normalement Douda qui serait éliminé de
la course ouais et che parinov qui se
replacerait alors lui bon ce serait
étonnant qu' qu' se qualifie mais
bon il
peut il
peut en tout cas il se bat pour quoi
c'est bien ok B dou façon c'est jamais
facile et il se remettrait pas si mal il
reviendraitère de envie de voir Maxime
ça joue ma ça va se décomter dans un
moment
quoiess coup des un autre
non pour l'instant un son que et l'un et
l'autre jouent des coups raisonnablees
c'est position normale
quoi c'est Viant qui tank bien écoute ça
fait plaisir hein
ouais bon il doit analyser bah come on
dit t C1 F4 c'est les coups c'est lui
qui avait défoncé le roi de Nan te
rappelles il Ava pris son roi il avait
enlevé la croix il avait reposé ah oui
je sais plus pourquoi enfin même lui
savait pas trop éta vénre il pété un
plomb pris son roi il avait enlevé la
croix ilaitait rejeté à la gueule quoi
non mais vraiment je sais je souvis plus
tu m' parle je de
l'histoire j'avais jamais vu ça encore
non j' déjà vu des gens péter les croix
mais pas pendant une
partie il voulait pas lui rendre aussi
ah
oui je sais pas il a pété un
câble le je pense non peut-être pe plus
cette période
là jou par Fabiano ouais bon après
c'était le coup logique bon il y a eu F
G5 moi je pensais H4 mais donc le coup
peut-être de la turbinette c'est de
repartir en D avec la dame qui V pas un
coup facile mais qui a son sens c'est de
se dire que la dame blanche serait bien
placé en D4 et de de on empêche le
pendant un moment une fois qu'on a dame
D4 on rayonne onôle plein de cas et on
va pouir faire à4 sans se prendre B4
donc ok c'est pas très naturel mais dit
comme ça ça a beaucoup de
sens H4 c'est le coup que tuas envie de
fairevec la main quoi mais c'est
peut-être pas si grandiose en fait pas
juste ça l'air logique surtout par les
temps qui courent
[Musique]
mais mais en fait et si tu veux jouer un
truc comme ça
ok non ça a l'air débile en débile pas
débile mais mais rien de non euh
ouais donc cas bon çaattends H4 ou moi
je m'attends H4 voilà et peut-être que
dam2 le meilleur coup mais je dis bien
des peut-être ça dépend
moi je reste conscient pour je sais pas
je le sens bien
ah tu le sens bien déjà ouais depuis
depuis depuis que tu connais
l'appariment en fait bah je sais pas
ouais mais après moi tu sais je suis un
peu bizarre dans le sens où le truc des
étoiles qui se sont tellement aligné
hier de partout je sais pas moi tu sais
je suis je suis une personne de r j'ai
l'impression que quand la réussite est
là elle elle te quitte pas te quitte pas
alors peut peut-être pas pour aller
jusqu'à la Calif mais en tout cas tu
auras plutôt une pour un moment donc j t
bon qui me semble coup le plus logique
mais après faut voir donc tu avec Tor B5
ou ou
autre mais tors je trouve c'est le coup
logique pour enlever un peu le contre
jeu si
possible on va voir
mais moi moi je crois vraiment ces trucs
de rush en fait ça donne une deuxième
idée he tour C1 c'est tu peux aussi
jouer avec fou bêtement pour enlever le
fou et attaquer le
D4 pourquoi qui prend des4 c'est une
erreur parce que dans les Maroy tu as
envie d'échanger les fous en fait mais
c'est une semi-erreur mais c'est c'est
plus fort en fait d'échanger les fous
alors ouais je sais que ça vont
surprendre plus d'un parce que
normalement le fou ketonut pas les
changer et ça va dépendre de la
situation du roi et plein de choses mais
basiquement en fait le plan des Noirs à
long terme dans ce genre de structure
c'est de les laisser avec le fou de cas
blanche là le fou des3 qui qui est
plutôt affreux au demeurant parce que
bloqué dans ses propres pions et donc tu
as envie de lui enlever les autres
pièces et et voilà et d'ailleurs ça se
voit par la structure de pion qu' avec
autant de pions sur case blanche mais
ils ont un très bon contrôle des cases
blanches contre les cases noires il y a
que les pièces qui peuvent les couvrir
et donc le fait d'échanger ce fou E3 et
ben ça enlèvera une pièce qui justement
aidait à colmater un peu il travaille
bien en symbiose avec les pions dire les
pion font les cas blanche je les cas
noir donc ça travaille bien ensemble bah
si tu l'enlèves il
manquera un atout au blanc donc
normalement stratégiquement c'est un bon
échange pour les ns regarder au cas par
cas mais bon si vousz pas de
contre-ordre faut plutôt le
faire Maxim a fait cavalier F1 h bon
c'est tout normal fou F8 normal euh les
deux joueurs se mettent en place pour
justement quand l'action va se mettre en
place au centre être en mesure de réagir
qui eu TR jouet donc je sais pas s'il va
faire G6
je Saen
quoi vidit c'est bon pour le moment ça
se décante encore et si pienko il a fait
le6 ça c'était
évident et et Fabiano qui a réfléchi
donc dame D2 H4 ou un autre coup
peut-être que tu peux juste jouer un
coup de tour D2 tour je sais pas
pour doubler et çaêtre ça doit être
raisonnable tour tour quelque part t des
TR d'ailleurs tu peux pour plutôt pour
aller sur la 3è
ranger pourquoi pas tour d
TR
raisonnable résonnable
Fab
pr le T
C1 si Maxime gagne aujourd'hui fa nul
ils ont autant de points ben mais bon TR
parties d'affilé tu marques des points
mais en fait c'est un tellement départ
et tout d'un
coupamam tu restes derrière au départage
mais après tu peux finir devant B6 jouer
d'accord donc il veut contrôler la case
D5 par ce coupl un peu hor jeu de ce
côté cela dit quand on fera D4 tu aura
peut-être un meilleur accès à la ce C4
ok euh mais je suis pas sû enfin je sais
pas je sais pas à quel point c'est si
bien comme comme ce pour le
cavalier est-ce
que je est-ce que B4 on
peut bou bou C6 à 5 et en D5 ou tard je
sais pas
logique pour remettre le F en B3 pour
faire
D4 en fait c'est pour ça que l'ORD
propose F H4 pour mal te mettre la
dame D7 le truc normal tu fais D4 pu on
prend pu on prend à
5 est mieux cavalier
e76 et l'autre cavalier7 juste F il peut
pas prendre du
cavalier éch a bien fou B3 j'imagine tu
vas être mieux et bah plutôt mieux fa
penser un peu auing enfing genre de
rapport ou des non mais c'est agréable
pour les blancs ça c'est bien c'est cool
ça c'est très très bien donc ouais c'est
un peu enfin je sais pas trop comment
les n doent jouer mais je sais je sais
pas mais H4 c'est dur comme coup mais
c'est trouvable pour un Maxime bah
surtout s peut-être c'est un thème qui
revient ici ou là dans ce genre de
position je sais pas comme je dis moi
j'ai souvent ces positions avec le foncé
plutôt donc je connais moins les détails
comme ça
[Musique]
mais
après faut H4 questionce que fut
7 mais je pense que tu es content quand
même ce que tu
ouais je pas8 petre F6 tu
veux8 du G wou ok mais je sais pas ça
joue ça
je suis content
ouais ouais peut-être fa H4 x 7 aussi
une option non mais peut-être pas enfin
H4 F5
effectivement 3 prend H4 et la dame
débarque ou prend G7 f5as pas trop de
dame G5 a des en Chud
ça sur G6 d
G4 tu reviens F5 et puis on verra mais
on donne des trucs
ok BIM BIM machin tour au 3 on arrive en
force quoi
c'est une bonne tête
quoi ok donc F H4 part 7 sur un coup de
merde il peut aller où en C7
sinon mais ok j'aime bien les blancs s
mieux Maxime en chaque fois ce th mais
la différence c'est que là maintenant tu
as tjours F en fait on est d'accord
c'est un joli c'est un joli coup
H4 vidit ça pas jouer Alireza ça a pas
jouer by ça a pas joué et sipen ça a
joué C c'est pas forcément on va
regarder en fil rouge mais
F non on aime bien pour les échecs mais
pas pour oui on s'en fiche pour pour
notre intérêt des Français mais mais en
soit position intéressante et
déséquilibré donc c'est toujours
cool je rappelle he les parties si vous
si vous êtes là sur pour la première
fois sur des parties d'échec le match va
semb aller vers vers les 19h donc là
c'est normal d'être dans un temps un peu
de mise en place mise en place
ouais après maxime a peut-être une
chance de prendre le l'avantage
ouais
et Pichot ouais Pichot est argentin il
est passé espagnol il vit en Espagne he
h omoni d'un certain Augustine pit
shot un gros joueur de rugby
H qui a fait le plaisir du Stade
Français si je dis pas de bêtises il
faisait des cuillères il faisait des
cuillères
ouais je pense cétait Stade
Français
encore la qualification écoute il faut
tout gagner mais bon il déjà gagné de il
fa gagner 6 d'affilé pourquoi pas TR
pourquoi pas qu et puis on verra je
pense y a du jeolien le perse les qu à
la suite à la suite ah j'ai dit
oui je suis un joueur d'échec de
nationalité espagnole né à Buenos Aires
en
1983 homonyme qui a fait une grande
carrière dans fr français grand amateur
de
cuillère je m'étais aussi qualifié pour
une phase du champion de chest tour
vousavais fait un score de 4 sur 21 je
suis Augustine Pichot vous l'aviez
monsieur livizevski ouais je
l'avais mais oui mais c'est important de
prendre la main pas prendre la main
savoir gérer un indice pour vous qui
êtes chez vous dans le public mais je
rappelle que les candidats ici n'ont pas
l'indice artiste artiste hollandais du
17e siècle 17e
siècle c'était beau le Larou c'est pour
ou gagé quelques cadeaux
magnifique collection Larousse Larousse
illustré tour des 4 joué par Fabi et
vous nvez pas ce dictionnaire chez vous
je suis V très
heureux est-ce que c'est si
grave vous reportez pas les mains vite
de la rose des châteaux de la rose
issance ça fait plaisir céit une table à
caler ou quoi tu es bien quoi très beau
[Musique]
cadeau mais c'est bon quoi il gagnait
1000 balles ou 500 balles il fallait sir
s'il restait ou pas quoi en tu veut
gagner des Millions après avec des
questions des questions vraiment débiles
et la troisème
victoire pour 50 € de plus mais moi je
serais parti dès la première en fait he
c'est fou ouais mais d'autres qui juste
là il kiffit je sais pas mais ouais
c'était vraiment dur enfin c'est
peut-être toujours je regarde pas du
tout mais bah depuis qu'il a plus logo
de Julien le PER ouais c'est plus
vraiment question ça donne mon envie
quoi c'est plus du question pour
champion de jeunesse on va
dire c'est plus main
quoi c'est plus du tout
main
bon t des CAD logique cétait dans nos
coups
de
principaux alors veut juste faire dame
B6 ou dame C7 tu fous ta tour en D1 il
fait F6
quoi moi je pense que B il a une
position
correcte
c'est dur
d'aller moi j'y crois de
ouf moi j'y crois de ouf pour
Baky mais non Fab a pas vraiment réfuté
les erreurs là non mais est-ce que céta
des grandes erreurs ou pas après c'est
c'est aussi savoir hein comme on dit on
a pas le gros ordi pour analyser H4 ça
paraît logique avec la main mais en fait
qu' on regardait c'est pas évident et le
dame des2 dam D4 joli plan peut-être
fort possiblement mais céit très dur
mais euh dur et ce qu' fait doubl tour
sur la colonne D je trouve ça normal
alors après je m'étais dit peut-être
tour D3 pour coulisser un côté logique
euh après voir peut-être que tu te
prends un truc avec lequel dans le 5 tu
perds des temps et que tu peux pas hein
mais sur dame C7 il veux peut-être jouer
avec
A4 mais du coup tu peux faire dame B6 H
3 D1 c'est
sûr et fou
C6
et si tu veux jouer avec un truc comme
ça
ouais peutêre tu prends de
F je sais pas c'est juste suggestion à
la
comm mais ça va moi je pense qu'il est
il est il est pas mal Baky enfin pas mal
au vu de l'ouverture et tout je pense ça
va ça aurait pu être pire quoi ouais non
ça va ça va ça
joue est-ce que FO a joue un truc il
s'est barré
il veut il veut 5
euh
ok bon
F4 Maxime ça
réfléchit bon on va voir si la forme a
changé dans cette partie réfléchit un
peu du coup est-ce que le cerveau est
bien remis en
état qu'il va trouver c'est subtile mais
c'est
fort
bah qui son partage excellent ouais il
est plutôt très bon après c'est pas le
meilleur des meilleurs il pr que je sais
pas s en a un autre mais il y a prê que
déjà après il faudra voir qui joue dans
les dernières enfin bon c'est ça va
dépendre toute façon il faudra faire au
moins plus à partir de
là mais aujourd'hui ça a l'air
d'aller moi je suis confiant mais après
moi je suis toujours
confiant
a joué qui prê que ah pr que il un tour
vraiment dur en fait il a joué moins de
très fort que bcky mais bcky il a joué
cubokarov là et hen
Bert auudelà de la première ronde mais
là première ronde ils ont joué à peu
près pareil alors que près de que il a
joué full 2007 je peux te dire je vais
voir son parcours après de que ouais il
non mais juste pour pour voir il a pas
eu de il a eu des il a pas eu les plus
difficiles mais il a pas eu temps de
repi
quoi pr
que prêtre que il a commencé par adiban
il l'a battu après il a joué Douda il
l'a battu ça il a joué après il a fait
nul spinko il a fait nul Risi il a fait
nul keer pas malin il a battu shankla il
a fait nul Naka en plus il a joué des
jeunes parce que ouais même ch tu vois
il a jou CER machin il jou les joueurs
les plus c'est celui qui fait le tourno
le plus difficile de tous en gros ouais
ouais ouais enfin le plus faible qu'il
est joué c'est 2683 par la première
ronde quoi c'est ça donc il a vraiment
il a battu il a battu douudda ouais donc
il a fait trois victoires àban Douda et
chankland ouais ouais non en plus il a
joué à diban à la première qui ouais qui
est 2550 mais
qui était qui avit 100 points l're plus
ouais lui il a joué viment un tourno
horrible pr que c'est Baky c'est le
deuxième tournoi le plus dur et pr que
c'est le tournoi le plus dur il est du
du coup près de écoute on verra déjà
dérouille aujourd'hu dans sa partie
contre mais c'est sûr que s'il venait à
gagner il serait bien quoi parce que je
pense qu'il pourrait faire que des nuls
et probablement finir dans les deux son
bon
départage on a dû voir le débat sur le
classement entre Nil regard j'ai vu de
loin maiséress pas du tout en fait je
sais pas
pour le coup je sais pas de quoi on
parle je sais j'ai l'évaluation d' Gard
dans les finales ça m'a fait assz peur
non mais ça confirme ce que dit Vlad en
fait ça pas envie d'acheter ces livres
sur les finales mais ce sur les calculs
oui ce que n avez dit Vlad regarde très
bien pour le calcul les
finales passe ton chemin et c'est vrai
que de ce qu'il a écrit ça te donne
envie de passer le
chemin Caravan
passe
mais sur le calcul pour apprendre à
calculer il est excellent vu que c'est
le truc le plus important aux échecs
actuellement pourquoi pas alors pourquoi
pas ouais plutôt
bien qui qui
réfléchit après il va le faire soit dame
C7 soit soit d pour F C6 ça c'est sûr
j'ai même pas de doute en faitç faut le
blind
D7 prior max d'près ce que je vois dans
le chat bien joué très bon c malade ça
change quand même de TR
truc peut-être qu' revient comme une
furie quoi comme un Tyon
fure Tyon
Fury
et ben écoute on va voir mais il est
mieux Maxime
voilà mais ser bon qui double les blancs
qui regagne demain après tu as tu dois
faire deux sur deux après là tuas tes
chances je pense c'est très improbable
qu' double les blanc parce que le plus
fort qui alterne en général donc à moins
qu'il fasse un truc de flotteur ou je
sais pas quoi mais normalement quand tu
as quand tu as un bon hlo tu tu doubles
pas mais bon qui c'est je dis pas que
c'est impossible mais faut pas compter
dessus quoi dans 10 jours je tape des
gens pour
vivre B qui qui a joué rock ok
doncett tour
en8 mais j'aimais bien le F C6 en fait
je sais pas j'ai un son WF Anderson jou
ça une fois dans un rapide ce fou qui
bougeit pas très stable C
chiantour c'est écrit quand
Mme
à moin qu' faire à
4 tu commences par dame D2 peut-être
ouais mais tu te redonnes la case 5 C
PASF c'est le coup logique de chez
logique
mais mais bon 4 il y a peut-être même 5
dégage la tour de là en 3
B4
c'est bien je fou de il s il s'anticipe
qu' 5 ok pas bête je crois que c'était
laomation numéro 1 de la
turbinette mais j'aime
Pasir tout ce qu'ils veulent il va se
consolider avec B3 il va mettre
peut-être le P G5 le C en D5 il va
placer toutes bien ses pièces pas contre
jeu tu peux pas trop roquer a C elle
peut faire mal la s' la perd ah ciao
après il joue Leo maiso même Leo du coup
va falloir cravacher après bon benah
disons si Naka se qualifie tu es quand
même très bien il y a tellement un écart
mais mais bon si se qualifie pas oui non
tu es pas bien du
tout ça va faire Maxime 1emier
français la furie
quoi ah B qui je suis
confiant
pass un truc sur C6
ok bien
bien le dame5 et fait H5 je sais pas
moi je crois que tu es trop
content faire quoi va faire
D2
tu fais ça
quoi non mais tu peux survivre mais tu
es mal quoi suicide Squad un peu mais en
fait c'est la meilleure décision d' so
mais c'est un peu murtassesque quoi des
fois un de plus quoi au moins tu sais tu
joues pour un truc comme disait murtass
au moin déjà tuétais mal donc de toute
façon tu restes mal mais si tu surv gas
peêtre gagner puis tu mets une pression
tu as quelque chose
quoi bah qui a
joué bah ENF il a non mais c'est une
question mais du coup
après H4 vid
ok bon ben
voilà on a fait le
tour et marquant euh on peut all voir pe
aller voir ouais je crois que cétait
assez équilibré une sorte de un système
de
Londres euh
ouais ok joli Caval en C5 est que tu
peux nous jeter un petit œil sur sur le
tournoi féminin avec le le téléphone sur
F prend pis on prend le problème c'est
que ça ouvre vers F6 donc on gagne pas
spion si vous demandiez tour féminin
allez Sophie
Sophie
euh je sais pas quoi dire parce la
position est pas évidente je sais pas si
ça va ou si une petite pression j'aurais
tendance à penser que c'est un peu
dangereux mais euh écoute peut-être
qu'il a 6 pour les noirs et à voir mais
son adversaire essayer de lu mettre la
pression en tout cas donc la sœur de
pragananda
vaali et euh et euh et et voilà mais
donc Sophie fait vraiment un beau
tournoi je crois qu'elle 4e si je dis
pas de bêtises avant avant la ronde et
elle a enchaîné les victoires contre les
joueux Georgienne et hier
contre Marcel et fremski le je
israélienne qui est 2440 et donc bah
très beau tour de Sophie et du coup et
Pauline
euh bencoute elle joue pour les
conversations avec sa qualité de moins
mais peut-être qu'il en a vraiment enfin
je faut trop se pencher dans i pour
savoir mais en
gros pourquoi pas quoi mais bon Pauline
jera pas la enfin était pas mal partie
Pauline je sais dans le tournoi mais
elle a eu deux défaites de rond à un
moment un peu de réussite pour battre la
jeune Hollandaise euh
et écoute elle est là elle est dans la
course mais donc tournoi très correct
mais pas pour aller à la Calif Sophie
pourrait
[Musique]
enfin donc
OK
t joué par caroana donc le coup
logique et on s'attend à tour à D8 à
moins qu' mette l'autre c'est marrant
sur tour fd8 je sa pas pourquoi sur tour
D8 ça marche pas mais il veut faire A4
ouais et sur BA dame à 4 dame à 5
ok on te fix on bouffe un peu les
pionsettre la pression quoi pourquoi
pas
ça va très
bien ça ça paraî quand même chiant pour
après pas facile à trouver une nouvelle
fois et peut-être B qui va pouir envoyer
du F5 et
contre-attaquer déjà tour C4 adieu d Adu
petite dame on t'aimait bien
jolie c'est rarement vu on c'est dit
c'est 6 est très en sécurité et puis
[Musique]
bah
c'est kata Maxime c'est
bien une partie ils peuvent
répéter des de ou je sais pas quoi F6 F4
mais j'aiim moi vu ce que fait ala on
est de plus en plus pour Naka en
[Musique]
fait
look
like F don't have to the just like take
couple
juicers make
some
over ch may help with
prep be live on
BL c'est là le cavalier F5 cavalier
h très bien
LEP VO pr c'est pas grave mais je crois
que l'autre était
écrasant
il va prendre ce qu'il veut5 toute
[Musique]
façon on voir ce que ve faire il
pourrait
faire4 il a pris ce truc va
donner6 OK
bon ça a pas été mon premier réflexe
avec les noirs de dans cette structure
et mais bon peut-être que c'est pas si
grave que c'est que visuel on va
voir C6 ça réfléchit
chezpinko bah qui ça réfléchit bon ben
ça réfléchit de partout ça réfléchit pas
jouer tour à D8
OK et donc est-ce qu'il va jouer le
fameux A4 je comprends pas A4 puis on
prend les dame a 5 pourquoi tout d'un
coup c'est plus si terrible que ça pas
mal F4 F1 ouais D5
ok bon
ok
et tout hasard
hein ça ça l'air dur hein non G3 tu dois
aussi te demander est-ce qu'il y a pas
des
dépr non mais sûrement ça marche pas je
veux dire je comprends a pas dit mais
euh D5 G3 da ah mais t par pardon
je reg regardis pas du tout dans ce sens
je regardais le C F4 3 bon ou tuavais
pas du tout non mais des5 je sais pas si
on veut tellement en
fait mais A4 du coup ça paraît fort
parce que H6 intermédiaire je pense tu
as pas trop à cause de AB
non tu r 6 toujours des chances de la
non mais bon ok bah c'est sûr quec les
tu es content de jouer ça que oui donc k
tu es vraiment obligé de prendre et
damass mais je sais pas je sais pas à
quel point c'est dur en partie Mo c'est
truc que je peux avoir que c'est des
trucs un peu consu géométrique un
peu je suis tellement heureux de le
faire même si c'est pas bon je suis
heureux par que c'est joli par que c'est
joli ouais car il aime bien transvaser
ses tours transaser les dames on
verra dam C8 dame prend à4 F4
F1 que c'est mieux blanc
je sais pas à quel point mais c'est
mieux
blanc parce que D5 en plus on a le droit
de jouer avec le 5 avec les blanc obligé
de jouer les trucs avec G3 pourquoi pas
mais G6 ça ça reste fa ouais je sais pas
ça peut se tenir avec les Noirs mais on
va voir s'il a et l'autre option il
disent que c'est dam G3 ouais oua ouais
bon pourquoi
pas C8 H4 ou mais c'est un peu ce qu'on
tout à l'heure ça et pourquoi pas devir
faire ça ça
ça tu mets le F c6re en B7 et puis
après-êre C8 pour dégager la pièce sur
D6 peut-être F5 pour libérer un
moment c'est tu as l'air un peu étriqué
avec les Noirs mais peut-être c'est très
solide en fait c'est assz à la baille je
dirais tu mets ta carapace
et on va voir ça fa a le choix ça chchi
max il joue le B4 maintenant toute façon
il faire B4 à 5 et D5 en fait ok B c'est
écoute il est plutôt mieux Maxime en
tout cas c'est clair il a son avance
auut temp et euh voilà qui qui hésite à
à faire la répète
hein bah je sais pas comment il se sent
dans la position en fait mais sil se
pense pas particulièrement mieux autant
faire nul hein tu fais pas de risque tu
gardes ton ton avantage au classement
peut-être il y aura un mec qui va te
rejoindre on verra
quoi sachant que si c'est carwana c'est
pas grave du tout
HM donc euh je pense pas qu'ils doivent
risquer vidite après s'il pensent avoir
euh s'il pensent avoir
euh une meilleure position sans risque
il peut tenter
mais
ça réfléchit de
partout du coup tu veux qu'on fasse une
petite pause et qu'onevienne quand aura
eu la fin des réflexion allez on attend
jusqu'à 35 o on a un truc un
peu POS 50 minutes
quoi espérant avoir un coup
avant ici ou
là
qui vois bien un combat de ha Volti et
une
nul par qu'en fait on fait une pause
toutes les heures donc c'est vrai que là
c'est le moment un peu creux mais d're
côté le moment creux va dur encore un
peu plus d'une heure
donc creux il sera il sera encore là
quand on vient de la pause donc on la
fasse maintenant dans 5
minutes change pas grand chose peuton va
voir un coup avant la pause ou même pas
est-ce que vidit va nous faire un petit
fou
F4 c'est ça il a quand même un petit
suspense estce que Fabi va jouer le A4
dame
A5 en fait je sais même pas quel est
meilleur pour les
blancs
dur à
dire tu peux faire un coup comme fou fin
tu GES toutes tes options c'est pas
trop
B ça a pris là ça va reprendre chez
Maxime le C av il va faire 5 des7 et
des5 ça c'est c'est écrit
d'avance moi ça joue des
coups dommage qu'il ait pas eu
le cavalier F5 pour cavalier 3 pr H4
mais c'était pas si simple non après
Vaah à voir à quel point c'était fort
enfin ça avait l'air j'aimais bien les
pièces branches qui arrivé sur leseris
le paté de pièce noire là le fou B7 les
deux cavaliers en B6 à5 qui participe
pas du tout à la défense de l'ERI ça
donne envie avec pe-être des tour 3 tour
G3 la dame qui arrive ça va l'air
cool alors ce que je te propose Fab
avant de de partir de faire un petit
bilan des des Français plus siaro allez
euh al on va commencer par par marcan
Mar alors il est un peu moins bien ça se
voit il a un moins bon fou des trous sur
case noir cela dit il y a plus tellement
de matériel le Roi peut être un peu en
danger mais bon ça doit aller donc on va
voir mais plutôt avantage à son
adversaire mais des chances raisonnables
de
tenir Fabiano carwana contre Étienne il
vient de jouer à 4 un peu mieux pour
pour Fabiano qui voilà une pression au
centre sur ceion D7 un peu arriéré mais
qui peut se tenir par le fou B7 qui
pourra peut-être venir en C6 un jours ou
quoi et donc par A4 il une pression sur
B5 pour essayer de créer un deuxième
front donc Etienne va devoir défendre de
manière un peu précise
et et voilà mais on va dire position
raisonnable svant qui a les blanc contre
pouja donc c'est une position de de type
marozi avec TTO de pion là en plus il en
a un troisème qui est venu faire son
apport dans ce genre de
situation donc il est plutôt un peu
moins bien ENF moins bien euh position
pas évidente à jouer alors il a rien en
moins ou quoi mais c'est pas trop le gen
de position qu'il aime bien dansqu il a
son s donc on est un peu inquiet pour
lui Maxime de son côté va arriver avec
un beau cavalier en D5 très
prochainement a priori ou en F5 et il a
un peu plus d'espace si le pion B4
attaqué il peut aussi faire dame D2 pour
le défendre le fou C de va revenir vers
B3 donc il est un peu mieux Maxime il
est plutôt mieux voilà euh à voir he si
ça pourra faire la différence ou pas
mais l'ouverture s'est bien passé euh
pour lui
et enfin table une vidite contre ikarou
on peut assister une répétition de coup
ils viennent de répéter une fois la
position ils font des petites
allersretour à voir si carou va revenir
mais je pense enfin toute façon on en
avait parlé avant c'est Le Rest
raisonnable de cette partie et pour l'un
et pour l'autre donc je serais pas
étonné que il se répète les coups et
chez Baki juste pour revenir est-ce
qu'il a eu un coup pour notre partie fil
rouge on a deux partie fil rouge non le
A4 B qui qui réfléchit et surpis on
prend il y aura l'option entre dame à 5
on a bien aimé mais aussi aussi juste
tour C4 hein qui peut ramener la dame
vers B6 prendre du cavalier en A4 et
puis pourquoi pas aller ailleurs aè dame
a 7 et peut-être maintenant dame a 5 ah
salut de voir ouais tu peux avir dame B5
aussi d la
7 c'est va risqué hein tu te mets dans
le visill du Fou de mais bon s'il y a
pas de découverte il y a pas de
découverte en tout cas bon bref ouais à
voir ça va ça on le on le saura après la
la pause c'est pour ça que Baky
réfléchit après je sais pas s'il y a
vraiment d'autres options que de prendre
très honnêtement peut-être commencer par
H6 tu enlève peut-être des dames à 5
comme ça mais tu donnes autre chose à
voir à voir à voir donc on on vous
laisse pour une petite dizaine de
minutes et on est de retour après cette
petite pause cette petite respiration à
tout de suite les amis à
toute
[Musique]
he
he he he
[Musique]
he
he he
[Musique]
he he he he
mesames et messieurs on est on est de
retour alors il s'est passé quelques
petites choses que vous avez pu le voir
il y a un ou de coup mais déjà le le
dame 5 est parti de de la part de
Fabiano et c'est vraiment fort que si on
joue un coup enchaînement de coup
logique comme cavalier f4ou F F5 pour
tenter de mettre l'énorme pression sur
le Roi adverse le tour C4 qui enferme la
dame en plein milieu des chiqu c'est
vraiment un thème qui n'est pas
classique rissime et en gr c'est la
menace après d 5 c'est class c'est blanc
j C4 en fait donc il faut faire quelque
chose contre ça et redonner un peu d'air
à cette dame noire et a priori donc
faudrait partir en C8 pour souffler et
en qu tour C4 pouvoir bah soit
intercepter F C6 soit partir en B8 ou A8
ou en tout cas voilà on perd pas la dame
euh jouer du dame prend à 47 si tu fais6
dame prend à 6 maintenant non mais ce
qui veut pas dire que c'est insignifiant
ce que font les blancs mais en tout cas
il faut faire un truc comme ça avec le
ne pas perdre la dame et sinon l'autre
option c'est D5 mais pion prend pion
prend fou F3 ça donne vraiment pas envie
parce que le pion D5 devient faible on
voit que les blancs on les priorités de
partout les pion a 6 et à4 aussi il y a
encore une petite chance de tenir mais
c'est la difficulté côté noir ici ouais
donc ben en fait Caron jou un bel
enchaînement avec ce dam à 5 il a bien
trouvé cette idée dont on parlait avant
mais en tout cas il l'a trouvé
et et
voilà donc Samuel séviant on voit que
dans la partie eu tour C1 on en était à
peu près là t C6 dame a 5 on l'avait vu
D2 grand rock et B3 on voit pas pourquoi
c'est une faute c'est tjour l'ordi qui
fait des siennes là ouais alors je suis
pas complètement d'accord avec toi ah
ouais pour le B3 parce que je le trouve
pas très utile non mais pourquoi pas un
coup si tu veux jouer5 tu es content de
l'avoir fait tuas plus B2 en
l'air ouais mais ouais non je sais pas
un peu non mais je crois qu'il voulait
faire G5 mais je suis plutôt d'accord et
c'était pas une urgence en fait ce B3
une urg mais tu te dis que là tu ce que
tu veuxver tu vas faire H5 AC évidment
ouais on prend tu une
faiblesse que tu as envie de
çaend estce que j'ai le choix je sais
pas mais disons ça AC les blanc tu es
pas mécontent d'avoir position après je
sais pas quel point tu es m ou pas mais
mais évidemment de toute façon je peux
pas aller trop contre l'ordi et
probement que G5 était plus précis mais
bon tu as aussi H6 comme option c'est de
l'ordi ça VO mais bon ça te crée un
petit point faible long TER prend des
deux faut prendre des deux j' peut-être
pris du roi
moi non le problème en fait c'est que tu
as zéro chance de gain avec les noirs et
c'est un peu mieux blanc après c'est pas
la fin du monde he
mais mais c'était pas la partie dont on
rêvait avant le la ronde mais bon
maintenant que c'est comme ça c'est la
vie
hein Maxim il s'est un peu trompé aussi
il est pas parti vers F5 pour attaquer
le roi bon il a fait le truc normal mais
il se fait chasser les pièces de la case
D5 et là on s'attend à cavalier F6
pourah pour contrôler justement la la C
D5 et comme ça il y a plus de pièces qui
viennent dessus peut-être même que les
feront D5 quand même un jour et donc
Pichot
qui qui a passé le plus dur alors après
c'est pas pour autant que il y a pas
d'espoir paril y a plus d'espace pour
les blancs éventuellement on peut faire
un plan comme dame D2 dame A2 mettre un
peu de pression sur cette longue
diagonale et essayer de faire des4 quand
même un jour et donc rien n'est fait
mais on aurait pu espérer mieux que
ça vidit contrearou ils ont fait nul un
petit peu comme prévu la répète à la
répète et B qui qui a joué D5 ok donc il
jouer avec le pion isolé un peu faible
il faudra
s'accrocher donc des prise prise F ça
dame F6
disons ça peut peut-être tenir non ça
peut mais oui c'est
pasta un peu moins bien voilà bon c'est
la vie
mais c'est pas simple faut jouer une
défense précise longue tuas fait une
partie de 6h la
veille c'est pas fait qui défend bien
Carana va pas lâcher la proid comme ça
donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas une
partie facile qui s'annonce
quoi et juste pour savoir
le il F4 quiment rien pass en
fait F4 c'est prend bon c'est prend et
puis va faire k C3 et peut-être tour D1
et on verra ce C3 s'il va vers B5 s va
vers E4 s'il va faire D5 D6 mais ça peut
gagner pouro
hein ça l'air assez sympa sa position h
5 jouer par
firou et donc on va voir si c'est en
prend ou s'il fait G5
d'ailleurs qui apparaît en l sur l'ESS
ouais mais peut-être qu'il a terminé sa
parti
ou alors il a laissé son ordi allumer
ou alors quelqu'un d'autre joue sur son
compte parce que là en fait il y a un
délai d'un quart
d'heure donc peut-être qu'ils ont déjà
fait nul hein qu'il est parti blitzer
possible dire je sais pas quoi vous dire
là-dessus puis on s'en fiche un petit
peu Maran ça a l'air très très par
contre S pire
ouais bah je crois que le France C5 a
amené à ce genre de position mais
peut-être fallait pas il a raté
peut-être pr 5 en plus
il est pas très bien bah c'est le
problème ce roi faible et cas noir
faible et toi ça
joue GH j'ai le prince bah ça va être la
position qu'on a vu cavalier D5 dame D2
machin H4 et c'est avantage blanc mais
c'est pas perdu c'est un peu comme la
position du PRE au final
h et Maxime et Maxime ça va ça aurait pu
être
mieux euh ouais là tout d'un coup
euh un score comme 1 demi sur 3 n'est
plus à exclure un demi sur 4 même avec
Marc Andria
h what faudra éviter quand même d'aller
jusque là a vrai moi B qui j'y crois
DOD F F3 mais dame D6 dame6 tu le coup
de l'ordi en fait tu sur qu' D5 qui veut
faire quoi juste fouprend mais ça
fouprend tu clou le
truc F4 il faut prend F7 en fait c'est
c'est pour ça que je pose la question
prend t prend C H3 joli coup et PERP
c'est beau ça il y a une partie de HB où
il avait fait ça je
crois trou
pas facile non en je connaissais le
thème mais j'aurais pas trouvé je pense
après faut l'anticiper de de très très
très loin
quoi et prè de que ça donne quoi est-ce
que tu as une est-ce que c'est quand
même important aussi ça joue on peut se
la mettre un peu en toile de fond pour
pour l' voir dans le sens en fait siil
gagne il est un peu non mais il a
toujours son pion de moins regardez est
là
ouais je l'ai je l'ai ok il a toujours
son pion de moins mais il est bien placé
mais donc tu vois
bon dire ce qui se passe exactement mais
l'ORD de dire que c'est égal
parce qu'en fait il a un tellement bon
départage lui que ah bah c'est il est
pas mal ouais il peut faire très très
mal même à camura quoi ouais ben là je
fer 5 à sa place et Touvre le fou et
c'est qu'il manque peut-être une tour
quoi sur les Chiquet
pour donc il a pris une fois et pour moi
c'est fou F3 ici hein ouais bon d 4
pourquoi pas je commencerai par fou F3
perso que l'ordi préfère dam pr 4 moi je
commencerai par fou
F3 mais parce qu'à vrai dire moi je je
suis dans le délire que ce truc là enfin
j'avais pas du tout le cavalier F4 quoi
mais après peut-être si tu vois cavalier
F4 ben il y a plus rien à faire tu Menes
forchette en les deux tu ro d prend à4
ben tuas mais plus ouais oui puis en
plus c'est pas enfin c'est ton pion il
est déjà passé quoi avec ton F en D5
installé non mais ça c'est bien écrasant
il y a même pas de F4 ou quoi donc la
chance de Baky c'est d'avoir fou F3 dame
F6
ouais bon
bon tu es pas facile
hein un petit coup de
bol moi je dis jusqu'à maintenant B
qu'il a eu la
réussite et là si s'il y croit et qui
trouve cette défense ultra difficile
Fabi peut tomber dedans à mon
avis c'est hyper dur
ou c'est dur
hein en fait après euh ouais si fait F
F3 d F6 Fabi du coup peut-être qu'il va
sentir le truc et et là tu vois et tu
fais autre chose mais il faut pas
prendre un D5 en gros pour lui qui est
pas facile parce fa F3 pour prendre en
des5 bon al resza maises de tris Barb
Maxim a perdu perdu son avantage mais
c'est bien qui joue cavalier B5 bon ça
force d'AM prend dam
h euh ok en fait en gros il a voulu
intercepter ah mais en fait c'est tout
bête il veut cavalier a 7 obligé de
faire a 6 et il bouffe
là-bas ouais
prise prise abcb
[Musique]
tuas un pion de plus et ro D7 P bah un
pion tu as juste un pion de plus pour
rien en fait
euh ok il ça ouais bon c'est pas mal pas
mal joué de sa part très bien joué la
part de
sVAN al peut-être tu dois jouer ça là
ouais tu auras chite tu tactiv ouais je
pense à celle-là mais bon est-ce que tu
es content de ce P on va passer
ouais bon c'est pas agréable
hein non mais au moins tu as un truc
central quoi
je sais pas peut-être tu fais F5 tu vois
après et tu as un genre de 3 au milieu
contre 2 et de quoi tuas un peu plus
grouper que l'autre ouais non mais jeis
d'accord dur à dire enfin pas marrant
quoi mais firou une nouvelle fois qui
est visé sur un point faible moi c'est
ça qui m'embête avec Al Reza dans
l'optique de candidat ou de tournois
vraiment de top niveau c'est qu'il a
quand même des trous béants qui se
résorbbe pas qui se résorbe pas et en
fait si les candidats c'est si dur pour
lui c'est parce que ses adversaires
réussissaient à cibler ses points
faibles et dès que tu cibles les points
faibles en fait il joue sans points
moins fort que d'habitude bon toute
façon c'est un peu tout le monde pareil
des truc tu fait bien d'autres moins
bien après ce qu'il faut ça va cacher
les points faibles etce qu'on puisse pas
te les toucher quoi c'est un peu ça le
problème
d'aliza des points fa on a tous mais lui
pour enfin pour le niveau de 1780 pour
bien remettre tout dans l'état il se
fait un peu trop souvent toucher sur son
point
faible et là le problème c'est pas la
finale c'est la structure
maroxi mais bon on avait vu par le passé
des fois les
finales donc B5 jouer je on va où c'est
obligé de prendre en fait ce que dam 6
non mais non Gerber quoi non mais tu
peux
pas bah donc tu es obligé de faire toute
la enfin tu es obligé de rentrer dans le
truc qu'on a dit he tu perds le pion
comme tu as envie de le perdre après ça
c'est ton choix
mais parce que tu peux aussi décider de
le perdre comme ça he à vrai dire si tu
as envie
hmm ça serait peut-être ça que je ferais
perso mais
bon enfin il y en a aucun qui est
grandiose hein
évidemment en fait tu as le choix entre
plusieurs trucs pourris
ouais tu as pourri et semi-
pourri mais là pour moi c'est c'est il
faut faire des stages avec Mazo
quoi côté al resa pour le maroxi bah
s'il venir à Paris fin janvier on est là
hein bah il devrait parce qu'en fait
Mazo c'est F prend des C tous les jours
hein ouais mais nous aussi ouais mais
parce qu'on a oui mais parce qu'on
connaîit
Mazo mais si tu as du Mazo dans le Range
c'est faut prendre des
qure
B plus de chance qualifier au candidat
ca ça dépend de la partie d'aujourd'hui
c'est si B qui tient
oui ça dépend aussi d' car après ouais
bon c'est compliqué sera 5050 on va dire
qu'au moment
précis selon la du jour oui mais après
faut pas oublier que Al joue pas quec
via ce tourno
[Musique]
donc il il a de shots quoi et que tous
les autres joueurs à parou on ce shot
là Caro il est très très bien oui oui
oui très
bien il est
Gucci apr ça peut lu passer sous le nez
il fait que des jusqu'au bout il a 8
points l'autre plus que avant le tournoi
il fait plus de à s field et était
derrière genre tu vois il finit 4e du
tournoi on est fait un bon tournoi mais
il est pas dans les deux joue Maxime à
la derrière qui lui laisse la partie moi
agent de joueur machin je passe les
appels donc
ouais faut vraiment que je sois AG gent
de joueur pour réussir à récupérer la
des
échecs TR ficoter un peu tout dans le
bon
sens
de chapoter un peu tout dans le bon
sens le 5 jouer par prê de C donc le bon
coup à priori pour un peu paralyser les
Noirs mais à part cette belle position
est-ce qu'on peut vraiment faire plus
quoi c'est ça les question pour pr que
si bien ça va jouer j'aime bien la
position des blancs quand même les deux
Pun là moi j'aime
bien difficile côté français bon bah qui
euh qui fait douter Fabiano quand
même en tout
cas
temporairement on ve que Fabi gagne et
que Naka gagne euh ben non là pas
vraiment en fait on veut que Naka gagne
en fait Fabi on s'en fout en fait si
Fabi gagne on s'en fiche parce que il
peut finir les de premierers il peuter
le tournoi s'il veut toute façon ça
laisse une place à ce tournoi là donc
peu importe de ce côtél ENIT on va dire
Fab anecdotique
pour c'est important c'est Naka mais
Naka le problème c'est qu' doit faire
plus de pour ce Calif je pense départage
et plus de en TR
parties ça paraî relativement compromis
non plus 1 il y a de bonnes Chan qu'il
fasse plus 2 c'est dur mais bon ça peut
mais je pense pas qui qui va chercher à
le faire absolument
non sil avait à tout risquer ou quoi il
aurait plus de chance là bah genre
aujourd'hui il a pas pris les risques il
devrait jouer pour le gain il aura pas
fait qu' h 5 et F6 donc c'est que il est
conscient qu'il peut gérer normal s'il a
un espoir de gagner à un moment il va le
faire et euh et
voilà mag doit surveiller son hlo bah il
doit faire les deux en fait en même
temps mais ça va de perire en fait si
joues bien le tournoi et que tu gagnes
des points hlo surtout contre un hlo
proche de 2008 c'est qu'à priori tu
seras dans dans le dans le bon wagon
donc donc on va jouer pour ton hlo de
toute façon ça te fait censé bien te
faire jouer donc il a fait fu F3 et là
faut avoir d'un F6 qui est dur très dur
donc on va voir c'est le moment de
vérité pour bcky parce que s'il a pas il
l'a tempo d'ailleurs allez alors ça peut
peut-être c'est très très difficile à
avoir est-ce qu'il a pour les bonnes
raison je pense hein donc on va
remontrer pourquoi c'était dur parce
qu'il faut avoir k prend des5 ça paraît
logique fou prend des5 fou prend des5 et
là il y a cavalier F4 menace cavalier E2
et touche un peu le fou mais là on se
dit bah ouais mais ça va pas fa prend F7
échec et découverte on prend la tour dB
on a une qualité un P d'avance mais a C
H3 puis on prend dame prend F2
échec roi Hin un seul coup dame F3 r G1
nul dame F2 Rin
ouis c'était vraiment très très dur à
trouver alors est-ce que il l'a vraiment
est-ce qu'il a fait F6 parce que de
toute façon tu veux pas rester dans
visàis ça je peux pas vous dire il a
joué le bon coup et il l' peut-être tout
ça c'est pas sûr qu'il l' oua mais dans
tous les cas si c'est genre de truc que
tu trouves
après prend des tu vas pas laisser ce tu
vas
bouffer sur après tu peux trouver après
l'autre option c'est
d'ailles
et tu as de nouveau cette idée de dame
pr c'est peut-être ça qu'il a en réalité
ouais tu as pas F7 à cause de dame pr et
et T prend D8 dame prend F2 et roi prend
fou prend Je2 parce que c'est plus
joli mais après il y a juste dam prend 4
qui est très fort voilà qui tu prends
pas des5 parce qu'en fait il est pas vra
comestible après faut voir qu'est-ce
qu'il ve faire est-ce que c'est cavalier
7 pour sarqueboter est-ce qu'il va te
faire un cavalier O 5 est-ce qu' euh
plutôt mieux blanc
mais mais la position dégringole pas
tout de suite tu as pas encore de pion
de
moins faut espérer que que carwana rate
ça peut et ça saverait le
demi-point après je pense si carwana
fait la partie parfaite ça ça va être
compliqué mais peut-être que F F3 c'est
pas un coup parfait du coup h mais je
pense qu'il a pas vu du coup
F6 très bien joué en tout cas de la part
du PRA qui joue le ass c'est aussi le
truc le plus résistant les joueurs
français là qui défendent bien ce soit
Baki ou ala ils ont tous les deux trouvé
les les meilleurs coups de défense B qui
qui se bat
bien fait très longtemps qu'il est plus
2008s du début son
encore il enessous si ça sarrê
là il menace de les
refranchir moi je dis qu'il
rate F à
[Musique]
T
prend 4 pas les bouffer en D5 il l'a
vu un cavalier7
et SAR bout on s bout et on espère
défendre après B a déjà défendu une
position difficile contre Guiry il était
pas bien contre raorte il a toujours
réussi à attirer le demi-point
après
après il faut pas pousser la réussite de
trop ça pourra pas passer indéfiniment
donc il va falloir bien défendre et le
coup d' d'ame F6 là cé un bon premier
pas h il va falloir encore jouer qu C
bons coups de défense comme ça et on
aura une vraie chance ouais préc pendant
un bon moment mais bon ouais
je pense tu jou déjà 4 C coups précis là
tu souffles un peu tu souffles un peu
ouais après il y a le temps aussi he qui
est un peu inquiétant mais bon c'était
la même contre Guiry et B qui avait
défendu donc on va rester
positif Maxime position intéressante à
jouer dit impression le calme de carwana
qui a réussi à voir le le piège ouais
mais le truc c'est que damfis vient
tempo et en fait les joueurs sont pas
stupides par que si k prend des C faut
prendre des C faut prendre des C par
gagnant bah il va dire s m' joué sa
tempo il y a peut-être une idée ou
peut-être qu'il l'avait déjà avantutêre
qu'il avait déjà avantç en tout cas sil
avait pas avant il va se dire c'est un
peu comm je vous expliqué l'autre jour
avec Maxime qui av donné un truc en un
coup mais il y avait un piège derrière
le mec est pas complètement C en face
quoi il va se dire oui c'est Maxime s me
don un truc
tour ouais
bon aurais pas Fall jouer tempo ouais
mais il aurait quand même pas tempo en
fait il va se demander pourquoi il me
file un pion
et fait tu vas chercher à voir ce qu' a
compris l'autre doncs par contre si si
tu vois rien tu fais pas confiance à
l'autre non bien sûr non mais ça c'est
pas pour toi enfin c'est
pourut pas assz confiance en vre
adversaire pour autant parce que vous
allez vous faire bluffer pour rien il
faut prendre les décisions rationnelles
en calculant mais le fait qu'un joueur
fort vous donne un truc en un coup de
dire bon soit il a raté ça peut
arriver mais soit il y a un truc donc ça
te demande de faire d'être doublement
vigilant tu revérifies après si tu vois
rien tu dis bon bah il a vraiment dû
rater puis peut-être il y a vraiment un
truc que tu as pas vu et bien joué mais
ça peut aussi qu'il a fait le con mais
voilà faut pas juste dire h il est
vraiment for S il a fait ça c'est qu'il
a un truc je sais pas quoi mais je fais
confiance ça c'est c'est idiot en fait
comme ronnement je pense que la plupart
des joueurs je sais pas si toi tu fais
comme ça et moi je vérifie parce que je
me dis il a dû voir quelque chose mais
de but en blan je dis quand même que
c'est un con ouais moi je suis pas très
confiance général mais bon après si je
vois pas je vois pas je fais bon on
verra bien en fait nous ce que murtass
nous interdisait hein c'est de faire ce
tu fais et tu te fais punir ou pas et
puis voilà ou mais c'est normal ouais si
tu vois pas pourquoi tu dois pas faire
tu fais
[Musique]
hein si je joue du contre je peux partir
au
principe non on sait jamais tu joues tu
vois ce que tu vois toi tu joues en
fonction de toi sinon sinon il peut
jouer n'importe quoi tu vas jamais en
profiter donc tant pis puis tu perdras
parce que tu auras pas vu un truc et
puis bah ça te marquera et tu retiendras
la fois d'après bah tu le verras et tu
auras peut-être appris quelque chose tu
verras jamais tu progresseras jamais tu
perdras tout le temps mais
bon le cavalier ça défend D5 et ça peut
se redéployer vers C6 ou vers F5
peut-être à un moment
donc il va sarqueboter
elle est pas simple à défendre mais s'il
joue des bons coups il peut la
tenir exclamation bon ça après c'est un
peu l'évaluation 7 c'était 100 % c'est
le seul coup pour pour tenir le
pionqu a B2 en l'air à la
fin
c'est vient qui
réfléchit et Sophie donc qui est dans le
dur d'après ce que je vois dans le chat
ouais mais
je
si il est vraiment bien je
pense il peut tellement bien se placer
si il a un bon départage ou pas parce
que ça fait longtemps que je le vois
devant a S pas un mauvais départage il
fait un bon tourno bien parti je jeter
un œil si tu me permets
ouais t'inquiète pas j'ai les
ref
ipenkopenka d'ailleurs c'est quoi il a
jou de sur de déjà a joué contre Sana j
pr
ma il pas joué des gros au début ça s
corsé mais il fait la course par devant
il P pas faire M faire mieux lui en
cumulatif il serait très très bien mais
bon il a joué Mar au milieu qui lui
coûte cher pte la moyen joue ouais il a
pas de B en fait mais il les a battu au
noir après Carana anaka au blanc il a
fait deux nul et rig au noir nul
écoute il fait son tournoi non non c'est
sûr mais ce truc de Mar c'est pour ça
que j'aime enfin j'en suis pas fan mais
tu vois il est derrière Baky et Baky va
reprendre de l'avance parce qu'il joue
caroana ouais bon après il a qu' gagner
sa partie spinko he et puis il passe
devant oui mais genre si B qui réégalise
plus tard dans le tournoi il pourrait le
rasser peut-être bah écoute mais ENF pas
sûr non plus dans le sens oùpenko
devrait jouer des joueurs enfin bon on
sait pas en fait mais gen là c'était
serré il y avait que quatre points de
moyenne il on aura un peu plus à la à la
suite de cette
ronde je crois quepenko le truc c'est
qu'il a déjà joué les forts en forme
mais en fait ils ont et si pian est près
de que en fait ils font deux tournois de
fou furieux bah quand tu as déjà joué
carwana Naka g c'est pas oui puis ils se
sont joué entre eux en fait je veux dire
que si tu regardes avec la forme du
tournoi c'est eux deux qui enourol il
serait euh devant Baky ouais et puis ch
keer c'est pas un ID puis jou mabayef il
a quatre là en je pour son nolo ouais en
fait
untel non mais il a battu même la partie
contre marquant elle était assez
impressionnante ENF je l'ai analysé il a
justefé Marant il jou bien les Sping ça
faait ça faisait de longs mois
qui pour moi dans les outsiders les deux
qui font le plus gros tournoi en fait
c'est pas vidit même s'il revient de
loin mais c'est près de que etcipenco
ils ont vraiment joué tout le monde non
ok mais visite c'est beau comme ouais
mais vidit pour moi c'est en dessous
pour moi enfin gen tu peux penser que
vidit enfin je je suis pas je sais plus
qu'il a fait mais c'était enfin je sais
que il a 5 sur 6 sur les dernière
parties mais
mais il il a joué il a battu 027 non
mais bon ok faut battre les mecs hein
faut Batt faut battreir faut battre faut
battre
nan c'est pas mal quoi mais oui
enfin mais jeuss bien faut se taper
Carana
er bon oui non mais je suis d'accord prê
que qui est en super forme en fait tu
t'en prends plein la gueule aussi ouais
non c'est chaud mais il a un demi- de
plus ou c'est chaud Eri au fait on l'a
pas du tout regardé aujourd'hui non mais
met la pression il jouere Kub il va
jouer pour gagner à fond c'est évident
et lui il a battu qui a b sVAN Gira mais
ils ont tous commencé à de sur de mais
ils ont pas des beau départag ouis en
fait il jou Sarana prê que Jay tuis qui
fait quand même un gros
Touren C B qui le repète la moyenne il a
pas de bol ouais g ici il faut pas qu'il
finisse trop execo avec tout le monde
faut qu' faut qu'il gagne aujourd'hui je
pense mais si je te disin on peut aller
voir sa partie si tu veux je me répète
complètement mais c'est pour ça que
j'aime pas trop ce
départage mais oui il est obligé de
gagner ou ouais bon il tente tout en
fait il a fait grand rock j'aime bien
c'estes c'estes gambidam là avec grand
rock h je trouve ça toujours des
positions très intéressantes de part et
d'autrre tu veux dire oui oui parce que
c'est dans les deux
sens mvl c'est mort de mort bah faut
tout gagner faut tout gagner donc bon
dès qu'il fera une nul sera fini euh il
en est où là bon il a une position ouis
il a laissé passer l'avantage après
c'est pas pour autant que c'est fini qui
peut plus rien faire là dans la position
mais c'était très prometteur vers le 20e
coup et il est un peu parti du mauvais
côté avec le cavalier
et et pot arrive à le chasser ce qu'
cent centr et du coup euh du coup là
c'est plus
grandchose donc s'il fait nul cette
partie oui ça sera
fini ça c'est pres que bon ok bah écoute
he il joue assez vite en faitf il
s'inquiète pas trop je pense qu'il va
tenir
h tu peux pas faire grand chose avec les
nard tu bouges pas tes pièces mais en
même temps tu les bouges pas puis c'est
tout tu bouges le roi les pions
quoi marquant il est très mal tour
risque de rentrer en B7 et puis d'aller
mat quo en gros
et B qui est-ce que ça
joue ça joue on va voir et qu'est-ce
qu'il fait c pourquoi il prend pas
H5 il entre fprend et T prend ah
ok examation point d'exclamation des
fois il est magnifique le truc non mais
en fait dès que tu laisses une pièce en
prise mais c'est flagrant que tu laisses
pas en prise puisqueil y a un clouage
sur le roi ah coup de
l'année 15 coups brillant dans la partie
mais c'est vraiment ou bon en fait ça
fait plaisir au amateurs non mais en
fait je veux dire qu'il programme comme
ça pour que les mecs quand ils font leur
petit bilan de partie il disent ah
j'étais très fort c'est bien je
progresse bien je suis très heureux je
comprends mais là en fait là on parle on
parle l'échec on est sérieux quoi tu
vois on est pas on n pas là dire 3 5
c'est un coup
donc il devrait y avoir un mode je fais
plaisir et un mode je suis normal quoi
non mais il fait plaisir bah là il est
en je fais plaisir c'est VI il va
regarder dire ou j'ai troué H5
j'ai bien réfléchi
quoi qui le genre de position qui défend
bien non non bien sûr
non a qui il est très dur à battre hein
c'est c'est c'est un beau défenseur
précis c'est vra fa un coup à trois
points d'exclamation quoi bah
oui mais enêche c'est tellement fort que
ces trucs marketing ça marche bien tant
mieux après hein ça fait
plaisir du2 pour Fab je pense qu'il veut
mettre le pion en C3 couper la connexion
de la dame avec le pion B2 et venir
gentiment attaquer D5 en fait tu reviens
vers F4 ou alors là il a fait H3 Fab
mais H3 moi ça me paraît pas stupide
tuas trop de variantes ù tu te prends un
mat du coulo le mat du couloir
ou alors après il se trouve que c'est
pas la ligne numéro mais je veux dire
que c'est pas un coup absurde non non
mais en fait le truc c'est que la partie
c'est pas le gen de position tu as
besoin d'être ultra précis sur un coup
si tu fais pas tu Vantage pendant
longtemps pour donc une défense
longue difficile mais mais faisable mais
falloiril faut pas se tromper côté noir
le coup duord côté
noir j'ai tell
[Musique]
envie
qu'il soit trois et qui se et qui
il s'envole comme une fusée
quoi ce serait extraordinaire
non qui te pop
ouis avec un
peu musique un petit
truc ch
[Musique]
ion le moment où ça
part la
chans ouis ou ça oui je sais pas combien
a de langu dedans 4
peut-être il parle en français bon il
parle en français en anglais en allemand
do mettre un petit coup d'espagnol ou
quoi je suis pas
sûr
un petit coup d'italien
aussi
[Musique]
champion une belle musique hein
ouais
ils ont bien créé ça
elle fait quelque chose cette musique
quoi c'est mais en fait elle est elle
est vraiment reconnaissable mais j'ai
déjà lu que les gens la trouvé naze
ouais mais elle reconnaissable quand
même donc mais moi je trouve enfin je
sais pas enfin je trouve qu'elle fait
bien le taf qu'est-ce tu veux faire
enfin c'est un truc d'ouvertureêtre
compris par tout le monde non c'est
comme les chqu vert de chescom en fait
ah mais c'est chescom ouais c'est naz
oui enfin si tu veux mais
tu il que allemand anglais français dans
ok que trois langue pas d'espagnol pas
d'italien
non je trouve que c'est une belle une
belle
musique c'est par Benjamin Britain et si
je dis pas de bêtises connait en musique
classique l ça connait la musique
classique par contre quand ça parle de
NAP a plus
personne il va te parler Berli il va te
parler
Mozart
par par le moi naps parle moi
bonorganiser B après pour que naps est
plus exister il fallait au début des
musiques un peu comme ça enfin il a fau
faire des des des expériences
expérimenter machin et tout pour arriver
à la S snaps voilà on a dû avoir des des
nazes comme Mozart comme betov bon
pour enfin arriver à quelque chose de
grandiose maintenant et voilà non je
pensais à
[Musique]
et puis làamation
partout
couant vasy on un message àon sur
WhatsApp je sais pas si va penser quand
je est complètement con qu'on est des
génies les
de
même surement con il va pas nous le dire
de but en
[Musique]
blanc
le tu lesexclamation qui arriv de
Dr V avec la vitesse du
truc qui sait pas trop quoi faire ti h
c'est pas con je fais pas
il va
[Musique]
souffrir te file du fric juste pour
cette idée j'espère
ouais mais non en
fait il va prendre l'idée et puis après
ça m'est déjà arrivé qu'il prennent des
idées que je leur donne et qu'il fassent
semblant que j'aurais jamais donné non
non
par exemple l'idée des chiens joueurs
d'échec des bottes des chiens joueurs
d'échec des animaux de compagnie c'est
vraiment moi qui lui écrit ah ouais il
l'ont vraiment fait mais ils m'ont
jamais dit que c'était moi ou quoi alors
que je sais que il m'a dit il était
tellementen avec le chat et tout là non
c après le chat c'est là où ils ont fait
le chien de Lvon ou des trucs comme ça
pour PN quoi je sais pas les Michat et
tout le monde après ils font que c'est
leur équipe marketing qui a trouvé mais
j'ai vraiment fait un message WhatsApp à
rench pour lui dire je crois qu'il faut
tout garder pour nous et et le truc est
sorti genre de 3 mois après coïncidence
je ne crois pas après peut-être c'est
une coïncidence he l'idée est quand même
complètement conne tu mas jamais
dit il y a eu le shadowest les ouais je
crois aussi bah oui y avait quelques
trucs
quoi d'illeurs en ce moment il y a les
il y a les les bottes
duolingo par il parle 12 langues
ais mais c'est bon
pour prendre le coréen par exemple parce
que moi en fait je suis stuck qui a 2900
chesscom du coup je vais je vais
peut-être aller en Corée un de ces quat
et euh et donc là tu as le tuas duigo
coréen ouais il te parl en coréen quoi
benah c'est absolument magnifique non
mais en vrai c'est pas mal ce
truc parle capop
quoi B lingo my il est très heureux tu
as tu as joué avec ou
pas il te fait échec il te dit échec
dans sa langue ouais il parle 13 langues
ou 12 langues ou 11 langues je sais plus
exactement non c'est pasolingo en
faitaco re
stck sur duolingo coréen
ouais je fais du diolingo ça m très bien
moi j'apprends les suringo pour être
numéro 1 auprès des latina
ais ouais c'est ça marche comment numéro
ou numéroouais non si je crois que
numéro di pour le moment je pense qu'il
est pas mal je crois qu'il est il est
sur il est sur des sur des planau AC
pH je crois qu'il se met très très bien
en
fait je vois qu'il est bientôt 35 ça êre
l'heure de la pause ouais je me dis que
peut-être serait l'heure quoi Peire le
tour des stades le tour des stades bon
ici pienco ça on va pas faire on fait le
tour des Français euh alira bah on va
voir estce
pas mais ça su Maxime ça su quand même
ça su enfin ça ça su pas pour perdre
mais ou mais il doit gagner donc ça su
Eri ça su ça joue mais ça su parce que
ça do jouer que probablement nul mais on
sait pas il peut tout se passer
intéressant ce qu'il
fait pas évident mais il va la tenir et
marquant il su bon on su en fait et
franç on suur mais mais mais Ilir des
retournement de situation on verra mais
oui pas évident pour Étienne al non plus
les deux sont dans sal DRP déjà 05 sur 2
sur les deux serait pas mal même si bon
on va voir hein euh Maxime pas évident
du tout de gagner donc ouais la journée
pour l'instant pas évidente mais il y a
rien de foutu encore au les cœur on
croise les doigts et on y croit à tout
de suite les
amis
[Musique]
he he
he he he
he
[Musique]
alors on est on est de de retour j'ai
mis les classements non on va laisser
cette cette vue on a la partie donc de
Baky en grand écoute Fabiano il joue des
coups j'ai envie de dire un normau la
jauge qui est un peu reparti côté Baky
mais ça veut pas dire grandchose en fait
ça être une longue souffrance après by
on sait qu' défend très bien donc il va
falloir tenir dans ce marathon contre
contre Fabiano la partie pour ait duré
longtemps mais comme on le disait il
avait été sous pression contre Guiry il
a il a tenu il a été sous pression
contre rapporte il a tenu il a été sous
pression contre youu il plus que tenu
puisque c'est youu qui s'est qui s'est
empalé c'est le c'est le jeu de Baky de
de jouer de jouer derrière enfin
derrière pas d'être moins bien c'est pas
son objectif mais je veux dire de de
jouer technique de bien défendre d'être
solide de mettre les barbes donc donc là
il va y avoir une une partie longue
difficile mais euh mais bah qui qui va
tout donner pour essayer de sauver le le
demi-point et garder de belles chances
de qualification dans dans ses candidats
et c'est un peu la même chose finalement
pour l'autre français aliera firouja
donc qui qui est bien classé il est
moins bien mais les derniers coups pour
la jauge là encore une fois pour l'ordi
sont plutôt favorables alors après la
position ça reste un pion de moins et
c'est difficile et c'est une longue
séance de de défense qui l'attend alors
lui il a besoin d'une nul pas forcément
pour aller se qualif la qualif paraît
quand même trs compromis pour se faire
défoncer les points hlo pour garder une
chance peut-être si carou passe pas de
rester un peu à àter de fusi apporter de
tir peut-être gagner de main revenir à
deux trois points ho et et et le raser
sur le sur le poteau de du grande chais
tour donc là les deux joueurs français
sont partis dans une bataille pour pour
envoyer la balle quoi h exactement donc
pas évident bon all on sait que c'est
passe son énorme point fort les défenses
mais après passe son énorme point forme
comme dirait Baky d'ailleurs face à top
top ouais bah c'estàdire que s'il joue
contre du top niveau genre la Carlsen on
n'est pas confiant euh mais c'est Viant
c'est bon voilà il est de 1700 c'est un
excellent joueur mais c'est pas le top
top donc il peut il peut peut-être
essayer de défendre attention aux
amortis quand même quand on est autant
derrière Fab sa ligne de fond de cours
ça fait mal ça peut être une arme
complètement parce que tu recules tu
remets tu remets mais l'amorti c'est une
arme évidemment par tu plus de terrain à
courvir pour aller chercher la bas is
donc là on peut des B qui reviennent fou
F1 t les amortis quoi il reculent quoi
très très
courte donc voilà un petit peu l'enjeu
avant avant les les not là B qu' a dam
attaqueur il peut bouger la dame pe boug
en C7 peut faire C6
intermédiaire il peut faire des choses
et Maxime on en a pas encore parler bah
lui doit travailler pour se laisser
rêver alors il a raté sa chance il est
pas moins bien mais c'est aussi du fond
de cours dans le sens comme il obligé de
gagner que la position est pas
avantageuse ça va pas être simple non
après bon il y a cette histoire de pion
A6
qui peut être un problème un jour si tu
arrives
àinil deux points d'exclamation pour SV
de points d'exclamation il a défendu le
pion sur tourage 2 il a il a sorti Fab
le pion est
[Musique]
attaqué G3 qui défend le pion et surt F2
FA je pense que tant que tu laisses ton
cavalier en prise c'est toujours de
points
[Rires]
d'clamation
bravo bravo c'estent pour ce G3
extraordinaire l'enchaînement t H5
laisse le C G3 relaisse le cavalier en
prise
et B écoute on va Voirin mais bon je
m'attends à ce qu'il fasse Ro des7 et là
on va malheureusement être obligé
d'enlever ce cavalier en l'air de de B5
en RO2 de Maxi Maxim qui rène le roi
pour défendre on refait un petit tour
bon marquant c'était c'est c'est kata
reg met pression ça chauffe ça chauffe
ouais ça chauffe mais euh il est à
l'aise dans ce genre de position près de
que il essaye il t son pion de moins
mais écoute il a bien manœuvré il a
planté un cavaler au milieu et ceraess
de monter onchangé les dames et il foncé
non non mais écoute va gagner pra que
bravo euh Fabi Baky Baki qui a commencé
Par6
le dit qui kiffe les défenses de Baki
là qui sa sur dame A3 il va faire dame
B3 je
pense je pas d a 7 cavalier G3 et
peut-être on a du
D4 c'est déjà mieux dans le P D4 ouais
ça peut tenir Fabi qui s'est peut-être
emmêlé les pinceaux
là pere qu' M C parce que dans la même
variante tu fais fr 6 et tuas 4 à la fin
ouais bon a je peux pas dire c'est si B
tu fais à 5 quoi mais peut-être tu es
mieux quoi qu'il en soit que d'avoir
cette dame en B3 qui de toute
façon pas précis
Fab pas très fin pas très précis
t prend B6 pour prend
A4 C
ou bon ça c'est juste nul il y a plus de
jeu ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre ça ce
serait
parfait est peut-être en train de
trembler
by
trembler ça commence à bien se passer
bizarrement c'est Fabi qui manque de de
précision encore fait fait mais
oui euh un coup à le trouvver mais on
peut aller voir il est où il est tout à
droite
ouis à3 c'est pas très
dur
on va voir pas si clair
ça peut bien se passer pour lui peut
rester sur B le coup est important parce
que dame
B3 si a dam à 7 et D4
après mais je comprends pas trop ce
qu'il a fait Fabi en fait avec cavalier
4 c'est un
peu
bah pas ouf replacer en avec tempo je
sais
[Musique]
pas il m' l'air de s'être complètement
brouillé
non fait le dama 3 machin je sais pas ce
que ça
[Musique]
donne plus logique pas tu tap tu tapes
un
peu
ok Mo ala ça joue Maxime ça joue ça joue
partout çavec les not ça va
pourevenenir à Maxime bon c'est égal en
soi mais tuas un petit plus quand même
cet espacee et le pion à 6
que voilà tu peux peut-être aller
gratter un jour dans une finale ou quoi
donc
donc voilà après je sais pas comment
Pichot gère ce genre de position en fait
il y a rien de spécial à faire faut
juste pas faire d'erreur et pas jouer
trop lentement mais ils ont déjà fait 33
coups tu me
diras c'est un peu stressant là parce
que ça joue
pas ça joue nulle part en
fait
roi D7 ok donc bon il il va reculer son
cavalier en C3
j'imagine bah il attaqué
maintenant donc il a plus roncer vite
donc faut
partir
faut
partir et c'est choses
faites OK on est moins bien mais
bon c'est pas tellement simple encore
pour valoriser avec les blancsut du
travail c'est dur les
échecs Master Class sur la française si
oui vous la troué on a fait des trucs
sur Youtube avec sur blitam sinon
j'avais fait ouais un contenu vidéo sur
à l'époque mais qui n'existe plus il
existe plus bah en fait comme ils sont
fait
racheter ils ont tout mis sur chessable
et ont gardé les cours originau en fait
le reste dégage parce que c'était pas
forcément fait pour leur trucends par
cœur et donc le cours n'existe plus il
on dégagé voilà donc faud j'en refasse
un jour ou voilà j'ai plus mon truc sur
la
française j'ai fait d'autres cours que
tu peux trouver mais pas pas sur la
française
a ceux qui ont acheté à
temps avir la joie de l'avoir
mais mais toi tu pourras plus la trouver
maintenant malheureusement il veut quoi
en
fait H3 j'ai pas du tout l'idée pour le
moment il veut qu'il a des 5
fouch je crois qu'il veut vraiment ça si
étonnant que ça puisse
paraître ça mérite d'être
original ouais ouais mais déjà tu pas
obligé de
faire juste comprendre l'idée quoi que
H3 c'est c'est c'est costaud
quoi je sais pas
trop non il y a plus
DVD c'est le meilleur coup
donc dama
3 après comme tu disais ouais c'était le
coup logique on espéit mais bon c un peu
espéré une chimère quoi ça aurait Puin
mais
oui fou F
B F4
non en fait si on t'avait dit que H3 F F
G4 es plutôt content
[Musique]
non
vero pas pour pas un peu plus vite quand
même parfois il reste 17 jouer 16
minutes tempo c'est pas du luxe
quoi peer s'il a pas
mieux pas mieux à priori
mais partie d' tout le monde se fout
tout le temps mal auutant en il y a pas
que lui il est pas plus mal a temp que
ses adversaires mais en tout cas dans
parti il les entraîne dans son truc
ouais faut dire il joue des trucs
tellement complexes àza à chaque fois
oui même là tu fais grand avec les noirs
on en va pas tout le temps
hein Maxim tu réfléchi là ça réfléchit
là ça réfléchit enfin ça réfléchit
peut-être tu décou ça change rien là ça
réfléchit aussi il a joué fou G4 hein on
voit fou2 fou H3 et puis
tu allez BIF au clic là il reste 14
coups
encore as après B qui réfléchit souvent
un bon ent quand même hein
ouais quand il a plus trop de temps il
fait pas vraiment les Garff en not he ça
va non non c'est un très bon joueur Baky
gère bien son
temps en fait il essaie de voir si vu
que la position est un peu désarçonnée
côté blanc peut-être s'il a pas une
manière d'égaliser en force c'est ce qu'
doit chercher dame C7 bon normal ilc G3
je suppose
oua je sais pas si c'est ça c'est mieux
que
7 mais pourquoi pas
G3 puis il faudra faire attention va
faire cavalier C5 mais je trve ça
bizarre G3
mais une pièce en en plus je trouve
qu'en fait le problème des blancs c'est
que tu as perdu du lion dans ta position
alors c'est pas trop grave parce que les
Noirs ont pas pu en profiter il y avait
pas de manière d'en profiter donc c'est
pas une erreur de B mais tu dois te
réagancer bien quoi mettre ton con G3
mettre ta tour en D4 mettre ton P en C3
ta tour en D2 enfin commencer à faire un
truc cohérent dans ton placement
quoi al
resa après il a raison enfin là je
comprends qu'il répète pas tempo parce
que tu peux dire de toute façon l'autre
va pas répéter h donc est-ce que
j'ai que je fasse je sais pas quoi ma
première vu qu' 5 c'est intéressant
quand
même que tuux faire cavalier F3
et et Maxime il va travailler Maxim
c'est une partie qui va durer partie de
fond de cours Fabi il a fait cavalier G3
fou B5 défend à6 là on s'attend à C3
ou tour d4êre tour BD4 ou parce que du
coup il a ça me prend ouis mais tour
des4 tu te remet un peu comme ça sur C6
tu auras des tours D2 tu bouffes des
ouais là tu peux mais en fait je voulais
juste dire qu'un moment donné bah
maintenant je la tour B4 elle attaque la
dame elle fait sa vie mais tu te prends
un fou B5 juste devant le nez terrible
non c'est TR plus te le prendre en C4
après jeense tu va venir en
D4 qui va mettre la tour E8 il va faire
C3 et puis puis voilà et puis ça va
manœuvrer et puis ça va manvrer vrai
ouais mais il a pas je trouve que Bak
qui a beaucoup mieux joué cette première
série de coup mais le problème c'est que
ben c'est un avantage long terme quoi
oui mais ça on avait dit en fait le coup
des erreurs blanches enfin noir sera
plus grave a un plus gros coup que que
si c'est les blancs et ALARA qui a qui
est revenu en H3 non ok normal enfin
peut-être qu' 5 était bon mais pourquoi
pas et bah c'est bienent de trouver ce
qu'il doit faire att il va pas refaire
fou F1 là ça aurait pas grand intérêt
bah c'est pour faire nul après c'est un
peu trist quand un P de plus mais bon
non mais va pas faire nul quoi je pense
pas mais bonah la même moi contre Al je
fais pas nul peut-être que lui il est
très heureux non mais tu te respectes un
petit peu quand
même non mais il fera pas je
pense tu veux dire qu'on est pas à
l'abri d'un pétage de plomb
quoi non mais bon bon tu veux dire que
toi tu aurais fait nul parce que voilà
tu en as Mar moi je m'en fous de tout
mais non j'aurais
joué çaurait saoulé de jouer
quoi qui tour
D4 va faire tour 8 c'est les coup
logique on est pas top
todaycoute non après si Baky et Ali font
nul ce sera pas une super journée mais
bon ça va de fois les Noirs finalement
ça passe après si on fait un demi sur
de ce sera pas terrible si on fait zé
sur de ce sera
bah pas très bien du tout quoi ce sera
pas ciao mais ce sera dur
quoi c'est sur le tourno c'est Chao et
oui sur le Tour c'est Chao mais il y a
encore il y a encore Ikaru il y a encore
machin il y encore les
y mais ça serait pas une bonne nouvelle
oui dans le dur ouais bon après sur on
va un peu se concentrer si ça embête
personne sur les sur la Calif quoi parce
qu'on on va essayer de suivre les les
les parties fait C5 c'était le cou de
l'ordi hein
ouais après c'est logique tu veux
changer un pion tour un peu plus le roi
ton fou de il reprend un peu de la
vie non mais il joue pas mal ce c'est
bienin c'est un très bon
joueur moi je préfèrais la position de
by à celle d'
mais par que en fait l'imession si tu
t'accroches taccroches t'accroches ti
ton
tua alors que la position quand tu as
déjà le pion tu t'accroches tu
t'accroches tu t'accroches la fin il il
fait
d il on dit que Sophie est revenu dans
la partie c'est presque égal
maintenant pu rater le gain en face
c'est une bonne une bonne nouvelle aussi
mais c'est encore c'est toujours l'école
de Murtas quoi le matériel c'est
toujours plus facile en fait je crois
que c'est vrai c'est quand même comme
c'est plus facile de défendre que
d'attaquer plus
facile quand tu es dans de position mal
le pion de MO l'adversaire il a quand
même vraiment une un plan clair un plan
clair une autoroute de gain quoi alors
quand tu as pas de maté en moins comme
chez Baky mais su que le mec s'organise
un peu mal et puis tout d'un coup ça
plus mal ça plus si mal
ouais bon pron C3 pour pour
caroana
TR c'est hyper logique
hein c'est
jouer alord dit quoi enfin le truc truc
le plus logique à 5 je trouve c'est
logique pour essayer de bloquer et
ça
et du coup on a perdu notre piion
ouais mais bon un peu d'activité quoi
oui oui tu peux peut-être la tenir la
dame à 3 elle est quand même pas
magnifique pe en jeu ouais mais elle est
pas si NAS dans le sens où elle revient
vite et elle connecte un peu mais bon tu
as du dame B6 qui est peut-être pas mal
dame C5 disons dame prend tour prend t
B8 tu peut-être un peu comme euh comme
hier comme hier ouais tu réussis deux
justesses à faire
nul bon c'est moins facile qu'hier ou
bien sûr mais mais il y a des chances
bah ki qui est vraiment à la limite mais
peut-être avec un peu de bol ça
tient il a peut-être vu en plus la
partie d'hier
ouais bon toute façon des fois quand tu
dois donner un pion pour t'activer ou
quoi bon pas un thème parfelu quoi parce
que si tu t'accroches au pion tu fais
quoi tu fais fou C6 fou
C4 mais je pense plus de chance qu' joue
comme ça en fait B3 fou
B5 je sais pas si va faire B3 h
ouais je pense il va faire fou C4 tu as
raison
pas qu'il a un truc comme ça qui passe
mais ça
va peut-être même P
6 mais bon faut faut tout
vérifier vous dites qui a gagné non
Maxime ça joue mais il met pression
quand même on va voir s'il y
arrive
fou G2 côté
firou il kiffe son fou en
G2 je trouve ça très bizarre
mais faand même le reprendre lui non pr
oufin je sais pas est-ce qu'il hésite
avec ça
ouais mais bon
Mo c'est lait quand même non mais tu le
prends et peut-être tu met fr C3 du coup
h non c'est para logique puis tu gardes
ta structure bien tu donnes pas la paire
de fou et sur fou F4 tu as pas du E5 je
CIS que c'est le coup de l'ordi mais
est-ce que ça ça peut pas
recul genre venir de partout quoi ouais
je sais
pas si je pouvais me passer de C je
préférerais quoi
il a repris du
pion alors c'est très lait quand même
oui dit en plus que c'est faute à cause
de fou G4 le coup le plus
logique des5 pu fou G4 leur dit d' roi
C7 c'est pas du tout ce qu'il veut faire
il va aller
en où en8
ouais C8 pas la bonne nouvelle hein ah
c'est horrible ce qu'il a fait
àza bah qui erreur comment ça ah non
c'est rien ouis c'est le cou regarder
c'est coup qu'on pensait qu' jou donc et
B3 fou B5 et il faut trouver d OK et
alors pourquoi c'est si
[Musique]
grave mais peut-être tu perds un pion en
fait c'est pour ça qu'il dit que c'est
grave mais il va pas trouver fabiie B
c'est chelou enfin bon après je on sait
jamais avec Fabi mais bon je pense pas
qu' suis pas très très très inquiet non
non moi non
plus après moi je joue sur la baraka B
il a un peu la baraca depuis depuis un
moment il la faut de toute façon celui
qui se qualifiera ilaura forcément dans
des tour comme ça c'est
obligatoire il f j'ai4 par contre Al
resa juste a la baraca mais il la
provoque c'est n'importe quoi en fait il
joue très mal cette partie pour
l'instant alors après on n pas un coup
de chance mais non mais gen tuis si pas
qui un coup de baraka qui trouve pas B3
dam 1 bon il a B3 Maisa peut-être pas d'
1 mais je veux dire en fait c'est la
baraca provoquée par le bon jeu
peut-être juste faire dame C1 il fait
dame B2 faute aussi enfin il a pas du
tout en
fait
C8 c'était quoi la différence avec dam
donc c'est de la Barac provoqué t C8 C4
puis on prend puis on prend fou prend et
là tu as cavalier H5 qui est beaucoup
plus fort que quand la dame en
B2 parce que peut-être que quand tu
proposes un échange des dames tu es pas
obligé d'échanger une dam5 ahà voilà tu
as tour
la on a trouvé tout de
suite donc c'est de la baraca
provoqué du coup c'est quoi ça prise
prise fou prend fou G4 je pense ça va
être ça la game he ça prise prise tour
D7 c'est pas encore sauvé ça mais bon
c'est toi qui plus pour le coup d C3 Bou
bouff cavalier E4 moi je pense qu'il a
sauve
bber inber
ça c'est pas fait mais oui bon B c'est
déjà mieux que de un P de moins et et
tout ça quoi c'est
bien4 complète
pulvériser
mais je en fait j'ai pas du tout compris
on prendf non mais on a rien compris de
Z pas faire
F4 je sais pas en
fait peux pas dire un coup qui va de la
partie en fait maisend c'est quand même
mais bon écoute après pas faire peur
d'un truc comme ça mais pas gra il est
moins bien sur toutes les lignes mais
problème c'est qu'il a choisi pire que
ça
quoi
euh
ouais alle res c'est bizarre bah c'est
pas son type de position et il les joue
pas bien puis puis voilà
enfin mais il joue vraiment pas
bien B qui au moins il défend bien
quoi non mais en fait le le problème je
dirais c'est que dans les positions où
il joue mal il joue vraiment mal non non
c'est c'est une chute drastique de son
niveau de jeu
ouais parce que là je il est dominé vs
2007 mais c'est pas il est pas un peut
dominer non mais c'est oui parti
c'est je suis certain que Baki a 100
points et l' de moins que aliera
j'aurais nettement mieux jouer la
position avec les Noirs HM
oui oui mais même Mazo en fait oh Mazo
c'est son élément ça mais oui oui mais
importe en je veux dire que quand tu es
27 80 il y a pas une position où Mao
doit jouer nettement mieux que toi
h tu sais
mais même si c'est son enfin je sais pas
tu te dis pas ça enfin je me dirais pas
ça de Maxime je vois pas dans quelle
position Mazo joue mieux que Maxime
ouais comme ça quoi que en fait je suis
sû que Mazo il est 1000 fois plus
résistant enfin il va déjà il va pas
faire qu' prend des 4 mais même en fait
là il
va Fab ça
réfléchi C de pas vraiment couure pour
Mazo parce que au
contraire
c'est beau de se dire qu'il joue mieux
que que ala mais nettement mieux genre
de positionition genre il y a même pas
de débat
quoi et même la défense en fait je pense
qu'elle aurait été
meilleure prend pas plus
am non arraché la main quoi je veux pas
non mais en fait du coup si tu pars pour
faire reprend
tu oui tu fais l'autre coup de l'ordi
fais4 tant pis il fait CD tu fais ro
prend enfin genre si tu veux éviter les
les problèmes et tu joues cette finale
enfin c'est pas grave en fait enfin
c'est pas grave tu as
tou fa ouai c'est fait c'est fait tu
continues mais en fait quand tu fais ed
c'est sûr
que en fait c'est sûr que la finale elle
est complètement foutue enfin tu as un
pion de moins tu as la structure pourrie
il y a plus de
tu te fais PIR automatiquementin bon bon
après ça c'est vient de finir mais il
est
gagnant évidemment vu tous les atouts
dans la position et qui a déjà un de
plus ce quoi non mais ça m'arrache la
gueule de devoir jouer K8 je sais
pas non mais en plus ça se voit
tellement que c'est fou G4 qui t'arrive
dessus tu vois tellement que tu asir ro
C7 mais d'ailleurs même peut-être ça
c'est moins horrible en fait
ouais bon c'est quand même pas
beau je sais pas faire fout le RO 8 et
le cavalier en
D8 allez by pour le
moment
c'est quoi Maxim changer un truc fa un
truc en E6 ouais un cavalier
euh bah écoute je sais pas
et Fabi fait tour
C1 là al dit commence maintenant à à
s'approcher d'égalité grâce à un plan
que B qui va trouver il veut k C6 tour
D1 cavalier E5 oui mais c'est t reprend
des 5 la question mais c'est k B4 c'est
ça ouais mais pas très dur
[Musique]
mais je pense qu'il va
trouver c'est
joué Fabi qui a complètement explosé
mais bon tu vois c'est provoqué les
erreurs elles sont provoquées il défend
pas mais il a même pas
essayé donc il va faire tour D1 ou tour
D2 je sais pas sur une des de cases et
cavalier5 va faire reculer ce fou de F3
en par que y aura la fourchette en D3 et
là ça va être proche d'gal non déjà ou
ça reste un peu mieux au
blanc je pense ça va c'est un beau
cavalier tu as de l'activité à droite à
gauche mais c'est mérité après tu peux
làfin il peut avoir dam 1 C4 et tu perds
c'est pas ce que je veux dire mais mais
c'est dur mais c'est dur tu le forces à
trouver les coups je dire alza là sa
partie il revient F5 qui en C6 ouais
mais c'est c'est c'est horrible
quoi on verra est-ce que est-ce qu'il va
convertir ou pas
notre notre ami séviant c'est pas encore
fait bon il a de belles Chan hein est-ce
que Bak qui va
essayer est-ce que carwana je dire va
essayer encore contre Baky ou pas moi ça
me paraît très proche des GAL là
tuessayes ce que tu essayes et puis si
c'est égal c'est
égal
fou tu penses qu'il encore unei je pense
mais en fait il a aucune chance si les
Blanc joue bien mais après ils ont de se
tromper tu vois ce que je veux dire et
juste pour info ou quoi çane quoi il
trouvé le A3 attends ici ben c'est pas
si
facile bien prê que il a fait nul ok bon
et il c'est un coup très mauvais je sais
pas pourquoi il est plutôt il a trouvé
le A3 ouais il va faire cavalier F5 D6
ça avance ça devrait gagner ouais grosse
partie SPO
Bak faut encore trouver deux trois coups
mais oui il a il a opposé une très belle
défense à
Fabi mais ouais alira le truc c'est que
ces points faibles tout le monde les
connaît maintenant et quand tu appuies
dessus
car il a fait nul il y a bien
longtemps ma j'y crois
max il va pouvoir faire G4 H4 G5 max ça
peut he en tout cas il peut travailler
bah il
essaye et B qui ça devrait le
faire
Ikar va jouer Baki
demain ah ça peut en fait B peut doubler
les noirs ou pas il a combien de fois
les BL vient dou les blancs donc oui
forcément il peut il a eu un noir de
noirs 3 noirs 4 noirs et qu
blancs donc il fait partie de ceux qui
peuvent c'est jamais
facile
Caro il consomme peu d'énergie ikarou il
fait la gestion parfaite en fait il
tente de se qualifier valgr Suisse il
voit ala qui est pas solide sur ses
appuis et du coup il est complètement en
contrôle en fait je trouve quand même
que sur la saison les deux joueurs à
part Magnus qui sont les plus forts
c'est ikarou et Fabian en fait il mérite
de tous les deux y être au candidat oui
bien sûr
ou pour moi il y a pas de doute
là-dessus hein je veux dire vidi TER ici
sur les Coupe du Monde grand Suisse
c'est pas
mal mais ils y seront probablement pas
tous B il peut y avoir le cas de figure
erci skfi ici et Caro malheureusement ça
peut ça peut ça peut bah c'est pas trop
le cas de figure qui qui donne envie
mais
bon ça
peut FA bienano est incroyable non mais
Fabiano bon il y est et c'est pas qu'il
mérite c'est qu'il surmérite en fait il
a bien joué dans tous les gros tournois
ah mais Fabiano en plus c'est un membre
régulier les candidats je sais pas je
crois qu'il les a tous joué depuis 2016
non peutêtre avant je sais pas mais il
se qualifie à chaque fois en fait
donc quand on voit la difficulté que
c'est de se qualifier lui il est Arve à
chaque fois c'est qu' il a un CR dessus
c'est tout
puis il est arrivé dès la première
tentative en ta coupe du monde il est
déjà qualifié il est devant au machin de
la race en il va passé devant gukch
normalement en tout cas ou il est
peut-être passé devant avec le
championnat des ÉtatsUnis je sais pas
mais ce truc de de race là de de tournoi
il est un peu bizarre mais quoi qu'il en
soit quand tu vois les résultats il est
obligatoirement devant Gouch h en terme
defin ah bah oui oui c'est sûr et
euh bon il regagne le championnat des
États-Unis repasse audessus de 2800 ho
donc lui il va passer dans toutes les
catégories donc il mérite clairement d'y
aller après je trouve que Ikaru il est
quand même nettement plus fort
[Musique]
que que la me non mais bon que abasov
que même que pragananda enfin passe
jamais vraiment complètement à côté d'un
tournoi il a fait troè des derniers
candidats au 4e il aurait pu se
qualifier en finissant 2e enfin pour moi
Fabiano et ikarous c'est deux évidences
en fait les trois meilleurs joueurs du
monde à part Magnus c'est clairement
Fabiano Ikaru et Yan il y a même pas de
débat c'est tu dois avoir les trois
candidats pour moi al resa mais tout le
reste c'est un cran en dessous ça peut
bien jouer sur un tournoi ou quoi mais
oui ça pas la
régularité ça pas la régularité dame C6
de Baky c'est bien joué il défense ces
deux
pions ça peut-être un peu jouer encore
quand
même j'aime bien cel-ci pienko ah oui
mais on aime bien tous ou pas enfin mais
je dire il joue bien mais c'est moins
fort il a 100 point d'écart et cetera
mais pourra faire une belle carrière il
est toujours jeune joueur talentueux bon
bagage technique tout très beau
joueur mais voilà pas
encore c'est pas encore niveau top de
mondial
quoi bien joué
Fabiano qui s'est trompé mais B comme
tous ces joueurs de haut niveau ça c'est
aussi une force des fois autant défendre
ils savent tous le faire tous le faire
toujours une grosse résistance autant
Fabiano tu vois là c'est c'est pas
facile tuas laissé passer ta chance ça
se voit que ta position s'est détériorée
mais il va te faire ce truc qu'il y en a
que très peu qui le font dans le monde
bahas ce qu'on a cité là est vraiment
plus fort c'estil va se resserrer pour
enc te represser encore quoi qu'il en
soit et épuisé quoi
c'est clairement ce qu'ils
veent et
alira je sais pas qu ça bah c'est la
même position juste C Viant il il joue
des coups pour arriver au 40e
j'imagine ils ont aussi la régularité
c'est ouais c'est carwana c'est machin
alors là attention très grave dam
F6 te dit cavalier E3 très grave mais
c'est très dur cavalier très grave je
non mais c'est dur sans être dur tu es
attaqué tu bouges
mais quoi que ouais c'est le
coup mais bon je comprends ce que veut B
qui Caval 3 il veut faire k
G6 et là il veut dame C2 le truc
c'est tu c'est sur cavalier F5 qui prend
D5 prend D5 D5 ok bon cont ton P et
pourquoi en C2 plus qu'autre chose tu
vas genre en
D2 cavalier F4 ouis parce que tu dois
reprendre de la dame et tu repèes ton C3
tu repes tu repèes ton C3 ouais c'est
bon trouvable mais pas facile hein c'est
un peu comme dame 1 VI dame B2 bon ouais
mais bon un jour tu peux trouver aussi
he allez la baraca en c'est pas vraiment
de la baraka comme je disais mais bon
faut pas qu'il trouve mais après même
s'il trouve hein ce sera pas encore
terminé mais c'est mieux s'il trouve
pas
et Haroun ou Haroun il va peut-être la
gagner quand mêmein il peut la perdre
aussi mais ce que j'avais pas remarqué
c'est le temps peut-être un tout petit
peu rester là-dessus par que c'est
importantou mais il est souvent mal au
temps mais là un moment ou il va tomber
du4 il va faire un truc pour faire
bouger et puis on va
voir jouer là
secondes bon pe-êre le moment pour
envoyer au
4 param qui va win il va revenir à
combien il revient à 5 et demi
aussi euh param il avait autant de
points qu'
ouais donc il va revenir enfin il
revient égalité dans le groupe de dem
des leaders et compagnie par je t'av dit
il avait les Noirs contre Taran c'était
peut-être sa chance d'essayer
cl noir c'est pas mal ouais tu vois il
envoie le 4
il a raison c'est le coup normal att la
position veut çaasit F3 et compagnie tu
veux jouer au 4 et prise j'aurais pris
de F prendre de la ah parce qu'il veut
retaper peut-être la tour C8 en fin de
variante par est-ce que c'est signé
par il serait bien prob Fabiano il a
joué le cavalier E3 en cavalier G6 de by
c'est logique et si a le dame C2 faudra
faire D4 on reprends D4 et jouer la
finale donc par mais très bien il a pas
encore gagné mais il est bien vraiment
bien
vugof Sindar il a fait nul c'est par of
Douda bah qui c'est chaud c'est
chaud euh Sarana
rapport Sarana est plutôt mieux à priori
on verra
c'est de mal en
pie bah il a fait il a fait le cavalier
G6 et là faut pas qu'il a dame C2
quoi bah il peut
l'avoir il va avoir envie de bouger sa
dame maintenant faut qu'il trouve où
peut-être la mettre en
G4 don envie non
G4 reprends
C3 prend des5 tu fais une forchette
c'est c'est bien dame G4 alors dame
G4 dame G4 je pense le problème c'est
cavalier F4 hein et tu peux pas gagner
le pion parce qu'il a C TR en l'air mais
bon tu peux dire j'ai G3 machin
peut-être que c'est pas peut-être c'est
pas un mauvais coup he dame F4
ouais le truc c'est que dame C2 en fait
je comprends c'est vraiment relou parce
que si tu dois faire D4 t prend D4 dame
prend des 4 on prends des 4end T prend
C2 ça avec les Blancs tu joue tous les
jours en demain pourir peut-être la
tenir by mais ça ça va être relou mais
c'est une autre histoire enfin avec cl
blanc tu es forcément heureux deentrer
là-dedans mais c'est pas dit qu'il le
voit bon et ala ala il se fait
désarçonner le fion désolé pour le
langage
mais c'est non mais je comprends pas
comment il fait ça en fait
pourquoi il y a F4 qui arrive au
prochain ces pièces c'est n'importe
quoi
et Maxim il presse hein je pense qu'il
va nous la gagner notre
maxime kzob a fait une erreur on nous
dit bon mais ENF je sais pas si la fait
mais en tout cas la position est très
dure à jouer tout court et avec 30
secondes à la pendule c'est l'enfer
quoi est-ce que Maxim il peut avoir un
meilleur départage qu'un qu'un param ou
un truc comme ça non mais Maxim il a
joué personne mais param peut-être non
plus
non c'est dur de je sais pas qu' a joué
par en il rejoue enfin là il joue mais
param a plus de points que Max oui mais
bon il fait une nul
et Haroun c'est chaud Baky je stresse et
al je suis
dégoûté
il a joué qui il a joué personne non
plus en fait Maxime il a un mauvais
départage mais en fait s'il fait 4 sur
qu je pense vraiment qu'il passe hein
parce qu'il y a aussi des mecs qui
reviennent de derrière là qui ont des
départage tout aussi pourri que
lui il a joué non il a joué personne
enfin il a joué des joueurs de 26 50 ou
quoi mais aucun plus de
2007 jou C bof mais coup M korobof naer
sadani Bartel aravine TER saakarian
c'est tout plus de 2006 par contre
mais gen le terqu là il lu enin bien non
non mais bon tu es content de le jouer
pour le battre hein c'est pas fait de
battre avec les noard erreur adversaire
de Maxime B ilont pas enfin dur à dire
ouais c'est beau ce qui veut faire l'ORD
c'est pas facile il veut se doubler les
pions pour aller te faire le pion passer
de l'autre
côté B qui faut faut que ça faut que ça
craque côté
carwana dame G4 excusez-moi messieur
coup mais bon le coup est pas mauvais au
demeurant
ouais mais bon c'est le coup appelé
parce qu'en fait sinon c'est Dame C2
donc j'ai cherché un coup cohérent qui
marchait pas
Fab stressant et cavalier 7 bah faut
faire mais tu es passif c'est bon après
B qui sil voit que F4 va pas il il va
pas
faire il a les coup B qu'il a je pense
qu'il la
tient donc là il attaque ces
trois ça attends je vais virer les trucs
qui sont finis là marquan c'est terminé
aussi ça va bientôt
l'être non il défend vraiment bien bon
après son adversaire r aussi les
opportunités mais pas facile à trouver
non mais dam C tu as juste pas envie de
jouer le coup en fait mettre en face
d'une tour pique les yeux par rapport à
dam G4 oui mais genre donc tu peux
trouver dain tu peux trouver ça fait tu
peux trouver évidemment c'est tris
occases
raté c'est trois trucs pas facil mais
c'est tris tris sur
TR ça joue pas il y a monde qui peut
jouer le
gainut une connerie en face
quoi une belle
connerie ah non B qui qui défend bien
bah déjà contre Guir il avait il avait
une position très difficile comme
aujourd'hui il a réussi à
défendre tant que ça passe faut
prendre
ouais bah qui gagne du vlo sur il doit
gagner bien 15 je sais pas trop combien
mais par là
ouais c'est pas encore terminé quand
même il gagne 155 bon si celle-là il
fait nul il reprend encore de points
peut-être peutêtre un peu moins mais
pas sera bien plus 17 il fait nul là
quoi alle resa qui joue pas
c'est mais c'est bien que c'est gagnant
mais c'est pas sûr qu'il arrive enfin tu
t quand même enfin tu fait bloquer c'est
normal mais faut en ouais bon il il a
pris deux piant ilass B4 sûrement et
euh est-ce que ça tombe en face non il
va pas tomber mais peut juste sa
position peut tomber par
contre mais du coup il les joue pas mal
cette
position o il
part grand ro attends ça a joué che ça
joue pas chez by ça joue chez Maxime qui
a raté le K4 mais qui était vraiment
extrêmement dur ça change pas dans le
fond la position il veut jouer pour D4
en
fait il reste coup c'est maintenant ou
jamais
c'est maintenant ou jamais parce que je
fa pass je P c'est
fini clinique
en est tellement
gagnante plaisir de se mettre aussi mal
quand
Mme T
b56
[Musique]
mais c'est sûr je pas mais il va faire
je
[Musique]
pense et B ça toujour pas
jouer remarque il reste plus que de
coups j'avais pas remarqué en fait je
toujour mais c'estra qu'il reste plus
énormément de coups mais c'est bien pour
by plus jovski je sais pas mais car a
joué deux dans ce tournoi alors avec un
ordre de coup avec ass au 4e mais il l'a
joué deux fois il a tenu les deux fois
pourquoi pas F pr G3 mais je fprend B7
ou bon après tu peux peut-être faire FPR
G3 tu vas tu te fais raser les pions et
quand tu fais fprend F2 le problème
c'est que fprend F2 F2 il y aura roi3
qui qui attaque tout le monde qui
attaque un peu tout le monde
ouais c'est un peu dernière chance mais
ça joué tour des4 côté
Fabiano pourquoi
pas
il reste plus que deux coups on récupère
le
temps à 5 ouais bien
joué je comprends pas trop ce qu'il veut
faire
Fab va faire quoi il va faire dame D1
peut-être
maintenant mais je sais pas si'il sait
lui-même he il bon il tourne un peu dans
la
position hmm
5 c'est bien joué c'est logique mais en
fait les blanc ils sont peut-être
bloqués dans la
position cétait le dame C2 peut-être la
dernière chance bien là maintenant c'est
peut-être c'est peut-être fait
tour à 4 en fait il peux pas faire tour
à 4 parce qu'il y a le pion en l'air
c'est pour ça que j'ai peut-être qu'il
veut dame D1 pour dame
D3 mais remettre cette tour en D1 je
sais pas où ça nous mène avec les Blancs
je pense que ça nous mène nulle part
mais maison ça peut être une tentative
quoi mais c'est bien le fait qu'il
qu'ilion TR liges de H qui bloque un peu
les blanc tout ce qu'ils veulent
faire mais tu vois c'est ce qu'il veut
faire bon écoute on va passer le 40e ici
on va passer le 40e partout en fait
Fab Maxime le 40e est passé j'imagine
ouais depuis belle
lurette je vient de passé ouais depuis
deux coup mais svant svant ça va passer
non il faut qu'il finisse peut-êtreon
peut rester là et puis faire une pause
après du coup ouais attends on peut
regarder le 40e de by parce que ça va
être joué après aller voir s Viant
comment svant croque à resa parce que là
B qui va il va
jouer
en fait je crois juste que tu as
vraiment Fabiano il a vraiment laissé
passer sa chance j'ai l'impression CIS
les noir tu peux jouer plus ou moins
n'importe
quoi les blancs sont mieux mais je crois
qu'ils peuvent
plusorganiserce qu' non il est toujours
symboliquement moins bien on va
dire C5
oua
ok 4e mais je pense faire
tour les
[Musique]
pions je pense ça va ça va être nul
rapidement en réalité ça va perdre
rapidement ça jouer long ma ça va jouer
longtemps
ouais B qui bah qui en fait le truc
c'est que son adversaire il a il a plus
enfin Fabiano il a plus
les enfin il y a le pion isolé mais il a
plus les les ressorts pour le pion isolé
et les pion le pion D5 mais il a plus
les ressorts pour l'attaquer parce que
B3 et C3 sont
faiblebl fou B6
prend G3
IL3 qure coups
ouais 6 du coup B7 va sauter
ou3 d'abord si je vois pas pourquoi
mais
ou là ça va abandonner pour
ala donc le 40e est passé vous inquiétez
pas à propos du
temps très bien aussi contrôle le fou
ça très
raisonnable prendre B7
prendre6 faire de pion de plus tr pion
de
plus plus le RO faible en face
ouais bon possible d'abandonner en fait
la position ouais ouais bah il doit
avoir le SAM après bah mauvaise partie
[Musique]
voilà ça arrive
malheureusement
etir les autres sont finis ouais bon ça
c'est gagné
ouais et
ici 37e c'est il y a rien de faire en
fait il a bien survécu le bu
ouais
est-ce que by peut win non ça va faire
nul mais c'est quasiment
sûr je pas contre qui va jouer demain
B je sais Pasir résultat le groupe de
points il peut jouer du param il peut
jouer car iler des gens comme
ça il est peut-être plus petit non il a
peut-être pr que
encore
aprèsas déjà joué tout le monde
donc est-ce qu'il peut se retrouver à
jouer du cviant ce qui serait
parfait il on les couleurs qui
correspondent il peut jouer param
aussi je pense joue pas double noir par
contre si tu joues C tu as les blanc
contre lui tu es
content l'ordi annonce une préion de 100
% alors ça c'est ça c'est pour la partie
Bacro carwana ça m'étonnera il y avait
beaucoup d'erreurs dans la partie pas
qu'elle était pas d'une bonne qualité
mais bon 100 % c'est pas
possible et donc il reste deux coups de
Z not mais là ça va être ça va être
abandon il a quatre pions de
moins quelle heure on a les appariments
c'est généralement vers
23h ch des parties qui durent
donc les deux ont manqué dam euh je
crois qu'ils ont manqué en fait juste
l'idée avec C4 globalement parce que
dame B2 C4 cétait aussi pas si mauvais
je pense que les deux ont raté mais
c'était vraiment dur à
voir et du coup si Bak qui son trouve
moins bien c'est qu'il a pas été à 100 %
avant oui forcément donc euh et si fa ne
trouve pas c'est qu'il a pas joué à 100
% bon res ça va abandonner reste deux
coups de Z not on fera la pause
après il a la partie de Maxime qui va
durer
elle je pense qu'on va pouvoir s'arrêter
c'est le 40e on va faire une petite
pause Fab ouais justey fais voir si
c'est fini enfin si le 40e est passé
on peut regarder le 40e ici on s'en fout
y pas
il va peut-être faire nul hein il se
battent
kzubof possible ouais c'est hyper bien
accroché parce que ça paraissait
complètement je n'ai pas cher de sa peau
il y a 10 coups quand il avait 30
secondes contre 10 minutes et et moins
bonne position mais il s'accroche
fort
avant d'Al resa ouais ben éoute normal
40e passé il y a plus rien à faire bon
mauvaise partie très mauvaise partie
voilàès ma pare partie horrible à
montrer dans les écoles d'échec pour le
coup pour montrer ce qu'il faut pas
faire dans le maroxi il faut jouer faut
prendre qu
ouais B écoutez on va revenir et puis on
suivra max ettienne et puis un peu
peut-être s y a d'autres parties 40e kit
joue au moins
on voit le 40e
quoi 30 secondes pour le
faire oui en vrai la partie d' c'est une
partie à montrer dans les clubs quoi
ouais non mais c'est vrai pas pour
montrer ce qu'il faut faire mais ce
qu'il faut pas faire c'est bien aussi
mais c'est bien aussi
ouais ici ça reste quand même compliqué
pour tu as quand même bouffer
B6 fait tour6
G3 tours de bon faut encore faire nul
c'est pas fait encore non ça
joue oui ou bien
sûr ver quel point moi B qui je
m'attends à nul dans l'HE
avenir si vite pas si vite mais ça va
arriver allez à tout de suite les amis
[Musique]
à
he
he he
[Musique]
he
alors les amis on est de de retour comme
comme souvent il se passe pas grandchose
euh au 4h de jeu là parce que il y a il
y a les 50 minutes de rajout Baky ça
semble très tranquille
après après voilà il y a un peu le
physique qui peut jouer quoi je sais pas
la fatigue il faut toujours faire
attention les heures de jeu s'additionn
le tournoi est long non évidemment mais
la position en soit va très bien tu es
jamais à l'AB d'une gaffe ou quoi mais
concrètement si on parle juste d'échec
et de ce qu'on a sous les yeux sur les
chiquers objectivement tout va très bien
pour pour Étienne et on a du mal à avoir
un plan constructif pour les blancs
alors peut-être ce qu'ils doivent tenter
de faire un jour ou l'autre c'est jouer
C4 dépr C B
prcé tuas un pion C contre un pion a et
tu as un peu la colonne ouverte tuas
peutre le C TR pour mieux placé donc tu
as trois micro arguments ici ou là ce
qui suffise pas à gagner mais tu es pas
obligé de faire nul tout de suite et
donc voilà comme disais une partie à
l'usure petit à petit et cetera
peut-être que les blancs peuvent essayer
quelque chose comme ça mais très
objectivement il y a pas de grand danger
dans la position Haroun on va on va
faire les choses dans dans l'ordre du
classement un petit peu contre kuzubov
il semble que kzubov est passé le plus
dur et ça c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que ça bloque des joueurs kzubov il a
cour en départage oh bon il a il a joué
pas mal de faible donc il nous gênera
pas non après bon s'il marque des points
c'est autre chose quoi ouais mais bon
c'est mieux de voir ça que de voir i
s'échapper oui et
revenir et revenir vers la t il a plus 4
K mais il a plus il a ah mais il a perdu
une en fait son nombre de victoir par il
doit pas être bien c'est pour ça que ça
va en fait donc ça c'est plutôt bien bi
bon il faudra tenir jusqu'au bout mais
ça s'est très bien passé gag S a gagné
contre alira donc alira à mais il faut
pas faire n'importe quoi dès de mains
parce que le ho va être très important
et
prédominant Maxime il essaye il essaye
il fait plus essayer hein Maxim en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a comme argument c'est
cette dame gens qui peut partir de
l'autre côté dès que le C 3 sera parti
il peut aller vers A7 ou vers B6
attaquer le pion A6 et D6 faire des
clouages ou quoi plus potentiellement
des pousser à l'roit donc il est plutôt
pas mal et et sipenko
euh bah il est plutôt gagnant il a de P
de plus alors lui on va revoir un peu
son départage par curiosité ouais il a
joué c'est ça il joué prê que marizi
après il a joué Naka
caroana erigizi et la Ker et il jouerait
demain contre vidit ouais donc continue
sa sa tournée de 2007 qui
doublerait attends lui il a déjà il a eu
quoi 2 4 5 ah oui il a eu beaucoup les
blancs en fait ou il aura no noir donc
il aura les noir contre vidit ouais
ouais c'est sûr que ça va vidit il a
est-ce qu'ils peuvent jouer ensemble en
fait bah oui mais tu as pas des cas où
tu as des mecs qui peuvent plus
redoubler les redoubler dans le sens où
ils ont trop doublé avant non sur c'est
les deux seuls
tu tu joues ensemble quoi on t'oblige
quoi ouais est-ce qu' y a des parties
qu'on a pas vu dans les mecs de tête je
sais pas dans le dans le tableau
là alors ah vet sec d parce que d a
l'air ah oui de a l'air chaud ouis dech
a l'air gagnant en fait alors dech il
avait quoi et ben il rent av ai il rient
en tête ah mais ils étaient tous à 5 en
fait et lui départage c'est quoi il a
joué tari Enriquez m il pas un très bon
départ
il départage pourable frérot mais il va
revenir ah oui donc il peuent être 3 à 6
quand même non mais faut se dans ce
enfin c'est pas une blague quand on dit
qu' faut
pour être sûr 7 ennemi ça peut passer
avec un départage à la baquille quand
même mais oui ah oui le premier va
gagner à 8 c'est
sûr ils vont se jouer
[Musique]
entre ça veut dire qu'il peuvent être 3
à 6 ça veut
dire que
Fabiano ah c'est peut-être iarou qui va
faire le flotteur sur des
HAAC par
[Musique]
exempleou blanc des
ou
[Musique]
dou qui double mais ils aiment pas trop
doubler non les trucs
suisses ah mais regard qui sera en tête
donc ça veut dire que
c'est noir non mais ça té sipenko en
fait qui va aller en
bas qui va jouer avec les Noirs ouais ou
pas parce que le problème c'est queinko
il a déjà joué contre Fabi il a déjà
joué contre
ikarou un moment faut qu'il joue des
gens contre qui il peut jouer quoi
donc ce qui me semblerait logique pour
moi c'est si
Pinko
vidite
et qui doublerait pour moi et ikarou qui
monte sur de Hatch ou Fabiano qui monte
sur de Hatch mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est que by va pas forcément jouer
ikarou
ouais mais je il a jou un peu tout le
monde et puis dans dans le groupe là qui
arrive donc B qui sera combien il sera à
5 et demi est-ce qu'on peut un peu
essayer de comprendre qui sera à 5 et
demi de de notre côté Sarana il sera
combien il a 5 et demi 5 et demi ça peut
correspondre à Baki et en plus c'est pas
un joueur c'est un joueur qui peut lui
correspondre il va tout tenter Sarana ah
oui ouais c'est un fou furieux c'est VI
5 et
demi je par of Doua ça donne
quoi pas trop ouais ça va ça va faire
nul hein euh par param 5 et demi et ça
s'arrête là
ouais donc Baki va il va sûrement jouer
Sarana ou svian ou param ou param
ou fedos
ou fedos h kuzubof il peut pas à mon
avis étonnant mais bon euh est-ce que
c'est bien ouais c'est bien alors après
pour le départage faudra calculer à la
fin fin
fin tu suis en train de réfléchir
au au le truc c'est tu as déjà eu des
affrontements des mecs peuvent pas jouer
certains et cetera
donc et Maxim il reviendra à 5 enfin
attends faut la gagner
déjà mais oui c'est il revient
5 donc devant il en réalité ah devant il
oui 4 et demi et queur un demi-point de
Baky un DEM de by ouais
il revient de du Diable vaau Vert TR
victoir de suite tu tu vas vite
hein non mais juste c'est intéressant je
sais pas si ça vous intéresse qu'on se
fasse ces petits points parce qu'on fait
un peu le point comme vous quoi on voit
un peu où on en est les forces en
présence qui peu monter descendre c'est
intéressant de de de voir un petit peu
mais donc ikarou demain aurait les
blancs donc contre récipien non il a déà
jouépenko non c'est pour ça je pense
quepenko et VI vont
jouerarou mais deatch il va se faire
déchirer
le tu sais pas bah il est moins fort
qu'ikarou hein ça c'est sûr mais après
tu souens une fois il a bien tenu
peut-être battu même Maxim en Roumanie
ouais mais il était foutu et Max non
mais du coup ce que je veux dire ça peut
arriver c'est pas je dis pas qu'il va
ou ikarou mais c'est pas évident qu'il
va faire de toute façon pour moi Ali
resza il a plus aucune chance ào si
ikarou
euh il a trop de retard àir on va aller
sur 2700 de chess mais il il rattrapera
pas le hlo de ikarou c'est pas
possible là l resa il a 12 points ouais
ça commence être beaucoup c'est beaucoup
12 points d'ailleurs ce sera même 13
parce qu'il a 68 contre 81 ouais après
on ouais non si ça s'arrêtait là ouis il
s'arrêtait là non mais 12 points de
toute façon c'est trop faudrait qu'il
gagne la signeup avec 6 sur 9 faut faire
plus 3 il fera pas plus 3 a priori non
et même plus 3 est-ce que ça suffirait
c'est cé suffire ça fait 15 points ais
mais il a plus d'élo que les autres par
que la qui bon on parle un peu à côté du
dum mais il y a pas beaucoup de coup
grand cha
tour ouais mais ça j'y pensais en fait
quand je te disais ça la
place
event en fait c'est la h
participantpana Maxim
dou c'est faire plus 3 le
plateau Magnus mais après plus 3 doit
passer parce qu'en fait tu as quand même
que des gros morceaux ouais par que y
mais c'est avec cette là donc serê de ah
non oui ce sera avec l'élo de
novembre seraê de série numéro 1 du
truc gu qui prend cher et ou mais gu
aura le même aussi ce que je veux dire
c'est que tu prends pas ta fa 5 en le
bend presque mais ça peut jouer un point
près comme ça de toute façon on n est
pas encore mais oui ça devient un peu
inquiétant
ça devient complètement inquiétant en
fait c'est la h totale bah il est pas
très
bien et si ikarou passait il a combien
de non mais c'est car passe la T large
si
commencefin c'est beaucoup mais ça point
mais il joue tous les deux enfin gen là
s'il continue à faire de la de la merde
on va pas parler aut ah non mais c'est
si s'arrête là le tour je dis Siou perd
encore de rondes bon ouais mais genre là
s repd sil refait nimp à coup à coup
même des même même TR nul à coup de deux
points tu es tu as plus que 10 points
d'avance sur 100 quoi enfin il qu' te
Batt c'est égalité hein même 10 points
c'est pas mal il suffit qu' te bat enfin
il fait un point de plus que toi c'est
fini en fait mais bon sachant que so il
compte pas ouais mais so combien de fois
il a fait du 5 et demi sur 9 une s fi
enfin il les a dans dans les dans les
jambes mais il peut il peut mais il les
veut pas en fait ouais mais il peut moi
je te dis que pour que là c'est
cataclysmique là pour pour la France là
le grand Suisse au final ah pour
l'instant on a zéro genre là à l'heure
actuelle on a on a Baky qui qui qui nous
sauve mais je veux dire ça pourrait
difficilement être pire que ce qu'on a
là maintenant c'est tout ce que je
dis non mais je veux savoir si tu es
d'accord ou pas je dis juste que là si
on arrête les les candidats les
candidats moi le grand Suisse maintenant
ou si on se projetait en début de
tournoi où
on en fait on va dire le le
truc le truc oui les pire c'est que bah
Maxime finit pas dans les deux et que
ala perd des points par rapport à carou
qui finit bien mais pas dans les deux
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
donc oui forcément c'est pas le scénario
rêvé après en soit en soit Siou
pasza a quand même une énorme avance sur
sa mais pour moi Ikar il est il est pas
du tout favori parce que il a b des hat
demain il est refavori il a un
demi-point de retard sur trois mecs qui
ont un meilleur départage que lui donc
c'estàdire que si lui gagne et que les
deux autres font nuls ikarou sera que 3e
oui mais il reste encore des rondes et
j'ai dis pas le contraire mais c'estàd
que si on se retrouve à la même dans la
même situation
qu'aujourd'hui dans 3 jours non oui là
c'est pas bien ikarou ne passe pas enfin
c'est sû non non mais je sais mais bon
après bah et si Pinko et vidit ils vont
jouer d'autres mecs ils peuvent perdre
ils peuvent je sais pas quoi dire enfin
non mais je dis juste après moi je dois
dire que pour te qualifier tu dois le
mériter mais si tu joues comme ça tu le
mérites pas et c'est tout en fait enfin
on va pas toujours espérer des miracles
et des cas de figure hyper improbable
qui nous arrange c'est un moment tu dois
aller chercher ta calife non mais je
sais mais genre là pour le moment le
scénario c'est le scénario cauchemar
mais euh mais disons malgré le cauchemar
on tire pas mort donc c'est déjà
beau mais euh
ouais
ver en tu
vois demain il peut gagner il regagne
une autre il fait
nul bon ok il est il finit pas dans les
de ici mais au classement il est
plusarou et peut-être que
plus très dur de se projeter c'est SR le
temps s'arê ce soir dur mais comme il
reste TR
rondes il peut se passer des choses
en tout cas ce que je vois ce que je
vois c'est que si on m'avait dit il y a
2 ans non mais si on dit 2 ans parce que
tu VO les sont de 2 ans au dernier grand
Suisse prochaine phase de calivo grand
Suisse tuas Aliza qui a régressé de ouf
il a régressé de ouf et tu as Maxime qui
joue plus la
calife je t'aurais
dit on peut pas voir pire quoi enfin moi
tout ce que je dis c'est que
là
globalement
bah les échecs
français on nettement régressé depuis 2
ans en fait c'est tout ce que je
dis après je sais pas à quel point mais
oui enfin en tout cas sur la campagne de
Calif ça pe été terrible la Coupe du
Monde on coupe du monde on a rien menacé
on a même pas menacé de menacer grand
Suisse il y a Baki qui menace mais comme
dis c'est un peu un un miracle en fait
mais c'estfin c'est beau mais je veux
dire c'est pas non mais avant le T tu t
attends
pas mais je veux dire par là qu'on
construit pas sur sur nos joueurs qui
peuvent être champions du monde qui eux
sont vraiment enfin moi c'est tout ce
que je dis en fait je discute parce que
c'est un peu le PMU parce que de toute
façon on attend il y a rien à dire et
euh mais après de toute
façon après ok hein c'est je suis un peu
mon je suis un peu mon Daniel Riolo quoi
5 minutes quand même euh j'ai 4 de jouer
par Maxime juste voir ce qu'il
veut euh euh sur sur H4 pour fermer hein
je dirais ouais il doit vouloir dégager
le cavalier ouais il rentrer de en
forceant à7 est-ce que l'autre il ramène
sa
dame et après qu'est-ce qu'on
fait en fait on va fallir faire D4 un
jour ouais et puis et puis F4 peut-être
que HG c'est plus fort en fait quand tu
te prends D4 F4 tu restes encore avec H4
faible alors que si tu fais HG ça l'
moins sécurisant de Prim bord quand on
VO la position au tout début ouais mais
ouais mais en fait ça t'enlève
casse-etête al juste pour rebondir sur
sur ce que dit ti r parce que le travail
est insuffisant finalement il y a que
Baky qui s'est mis un objectif ro clair
alors ça c'est vrai mais pas
complètement et tien en fait
euh Maxime c'est aussi mis un gros
objectif juste il est vraiment tombé
malade genre là c'est vraiment la faute
à pas de chance quoi Maxime ah ou on
peut pas dire queil est pas bossé enfin
moi pour vraiment bien le connaître il a
vraiment retravaillé pour revenir à
niveau ouais il a fait son équipe il a
fait son répertoire mais après c'est pas
parce que tu travailles bien que tu vas
bien jouer franchement il y a eu
d'énormes progrès côté Maxime là sur les
derniers mois ça s'est vu en Inde ça
s'est vu sur le tournoi
internet il joue vraiment mieux et puis
ça se voit même là maintenant gre depuis
qu'il est remis il vient de gagner deux
parties va peut-être en gagner une
troisième il va quand même être devant
al res c'est il sera qu'un demi-po de by
enfin en réalité oui oui Non Non
mais il a très bien joué en Coupe
d'Europe des Clubs aussi il a fait très
bons résultats là ça fait 3 4 on voit
que le travail commence à porter ses
fruits après juste tu te tapes un
vraiment salale virus enfin comme je
disais il crachait du sang quoi enfin
non mais non mais je
sais c'est quand même bon c'est dur de
dire à Maxim tu as pas travaillé ouais
bon enfin tu as travaillé juste non mais
le truc après c'est que toute façon tu
as que un tournoi il faut être dans les
deux et tu as beau tourir bien fait
avant c'est dur d'
enfin c'est pas facile quoi donc donc
voilà de toute façon c'est dur de ce qu'
fait candidat pu il a pas eu la réussite
le machin par contre sindarov il a
vraiment pas la réussite dans son match
de Coupe du monde ça ça veut aussi red
dire beaucoup de choses on en parla un
petit peu plus tôt mais là B qui a aussi
la la baraka elle est méritée parce
qu'il va la chercher mais gen par là
s'il trouve les coups en face il trouve
les coups il gagne enfin il y a des
moments où les parties elles peuvent
être enfin elles sont perdu quoi enfin
perdu sur un jeu parfait on se comprend
mais genre Maxime contre sindarov ben ça
a le droit aussi de bien
tourner le mec mal il te sort la
première ligne de A à Z enfin ouis bien
joué bravo VO tu pe dire grand chose tu
peux rien dire donc
euh les échecs tu peux pas les résumer
sur un tournoi sur la saison Maxime je
trouve qu'il est quand même bien revenu
surtout dans la deuxème partie de saison
non bien sûr ben ce qui a de dommage en
fait c'est que les deux seuls tourns il
peuvent se qualifier bah ça se passe pas
ouf mais celui-là écoute on va pas
l'enterrer tout de suite alors il a très
peu de chance de se qualifier ce qu'on
dit depuis 3 jours mais s'il gagne tout
il sera et il essaye là après il pas la
réussite contre karakin bah contre
karakin c'est absolument horrible en
fait ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
vraiment la réussite mais bon ben la
réussite tu en as besoin en fait c'est
c'est quoi l'histoire contre kakin se
rappelle pas le départage de Coupe du
Monde Kin il voit il joue un coup il
voit rien a longtemps ou il voit rien
céit une partie a une sorte de système
de lond ouais mais il trouve que toute
la première ligne après les coups sont
que forcés pour les Noirs il se trouve
que c'est plus que plus 04 à la fin et
que bon avec les Blancs c'était
tellementimpression que tu es gagnant
que tu tu utilises tout ton temps et tu
perds mais c'est juste la malchance
absolue quoi
il a ce côté bon défenseur non mais je
comprends tuas rien vu si c'est plus 4
c'est plus
4 aucun je suis pas si étonné que ça
tombe sur kak quoi le me sait bien
défendre comme gen carp quoi même un
vieux carpof il va jouer il peut jouer
quand raté quand tu as raté que que
visuellement en fait ça perd
instantanément et que non c'est
chat
mais
mais bon après il y a d'autres moments
Maxim issu de la réussite hein il a pas
que jamais de réussite mais je veux dire
là c'est un peu je trouve ça un peu
sévère sur Maxime autant alira je suis
d'accord on sent qu'il y a pas eu de
progrès du tout là il retombe un peu
dans ses travers dans un maroxi on sait
que c'est son point faible et il se fait
remassacrer dessus donc là oui je suis
d'accord que c'est un manque de travail
après là sur Maxime vraiment je suis pas
d'accord en tout
cas depuis quelques mois depuis cette
année on peut pas lui reprocher quoi on
voit qu'il est qu'il donne vraiment tout
pour revenir et ça paye sur d'autres
tournois g en fallait gagner bien sûr
bien sûr mais de toute façon comme je
dis tu peux pas décider que tu vas
gagner un T et gagner à la demande c'est
juste arrivrive tu es dans la meilleure
forme possible tu fais de ton mieux et
tu vois
mais mais donc bref ouais
mais ok celui-là il est pas encore fini
comme je
disais tu es pas objectif c'est
complètement objectif en fait non mais
c'est
incroyableon gagne en un an rapide mais
il gagne en un an rapide mais regarde la
Coupe d'Europe des Clubs il a super bien
joué il a vraiment fait des très bonnes
parties tout le
long Magnus le truc en rapide sur
internet je là il y a personne qui
trichait faut quand même le battre
Magnus quoi c'est quand même c'est pas
c'est pas gagné
quoi
non mais oui c'est normal de le défendre
c'est un ami mais en plus le truc c'est
que c'est pas des
argumentabis cé quoi c'est assez
réel c'est encore du rapide oui mais bon
c'est les tournois il y A4 prix enfin je
sais pas quoi un moment donné tu gagnais
les me jouent le plus sérieux c'est
encore rapide Coupe d'Europe des Clubs
c'est quoi c'est rapide aussi c'est pas
rapide quoi c'est du long et il te tient
Magnus qui é en super forme et qui
défonçait tout le monde et il a fait un
super score max je exactement combien
mais il jouit vraiment bien il a gagné
des points ho là-bas ouis pas mal de
points ho enfin après je dire tu arrives
à un tournoi tu es vraiment
malade et puis je veux dire là il fait
quand même pas n'importe quoi en genre
le tournoi il se passe mal au début bon
il fait 4 nuls il per ça rich il va
peut-être te faire tro sur TR il a
peut-être même pas perdre de hlo au
final ou marginalement oui bon j'imagine
s'il gagne aujourd'hui bah il en perd
peut-ê ou deux mais c'est pas voilà tu
tu joues plus moins ton niveau quand
c'est comme ça et euh mais comme je dis
c'est 11 rond tu compes les maisons à la
fin du village
donc dur de faire direct des plans sur
plus Magnus d'avant non mais arrêtez en
Coupe d'Europe il a gagné le tournoi
avec le champagne don tout pour gagner
des se pas gagné noncore très bien jou
hyper fort la
coupe cont ma plus ou
MOS oui 5 sur mais bon il te B tout le
monde en fait il y a que Maxime qui l'a
stoppé avec les Noirs en
plus
mais non non carlen joue bien enfin faut
pas croire carlen joue plus bien et
qu'il a stoppé enfin là tous les tour
qu'il a fait c'était pour gagner alors
juste au catar évidemment il a pas été
ouf mais c'est son seul raté en fait à
Carl depuis depuis un petit moment là
quand même la Coupe du Monde il a gagné
les inter il jou bien la coupe de rapide
l'a gagné je peux pas dire
que
pardon
quand Mme mois faut écouter peut-être le
podcast de Carana
et je Maxim est moins bien joué qu'à une
époque c'est sû tu tombes pas de 2820
2720 sans raison donc il a moins bien
joué il a eu une période de crise çaon
c'est indéniable il a joué moins bien et
prob même maintenant il joue moins bien
quand il son méga top 5 ans on va dire
mais juste en fait là le débat de base
c'est juste je sais plus dans le chat
qui disait oui il y a pas de travail et
Kevin réagit à ça dit bah écoute si
regarde machin et voilà en fait c'est ça
que magnetim est déjà mieux joué que ce
qu'il fait là bah oui mais disons le
côté de travail là on peut pas peut pas
lui
reprocher ici maintenant en tout cas
voilà c'était ça le le truc quoi je
disais Ikar Ikaru et carwana ils pensent
qu'il y a une déflation de 20 à 30
points en gros au top niveau que 28
d'avance 2780 et que enfin c'est très
possible parce que en
plus en plus tu as l'histoire des 08 qui
compte plus donc ça te tire vers le bas
déjà très tôt
et et que en fait avec la nouvelle
manière de jouer avec les ordis les
prépa très importantes ou quoi ça
c'était l'argument de Carana mais il a
raison c'est qu'un joueur autour de 2005
quand il a les blancs sil a bien
travaillé qu' est encore motivé qui qui
plante les d'ordi tu vas pas le battre
tout Caron que tu seras en tout
cas on va dire tu feras pas du tout 100
% quoi et donc il dit bah ouais mais ça
coûte des pointso ça donc ok gen les
blan de temps temps je vais les battre
mais quand j'ai les Noirs je vais suer
et et que ça ça coûte et que bon voilà
cétait son argument pour dire voilà ben
ça tire vers le bas et puis tu as tous
les joueurs un peu sous-classé qui de
certains pays bah là on a vu le kazak
dans ce tournoi mais tu as beaucoup de
joueurs indiens qui sortent pas trop du
pays puis quand ils viennent en Europe
faire la tournée des tournois il te il
te fut une r et voilà donc bon faudra
peut-être un moment que
ça se remette à Flo mais que peut-être
en ce moment voilà c'est pas
complètement au hasard qu' a plus que
carlon au de 2008 et qu'ils ont tous
perdu des points en
fait
évidemment donc voilà c son podcast
après on peut discuter il peut avir
raison il peut avir tort il peut avoir
semiraison sur certains points pas sur
d'autres mais c'est touours intéressant
d'avoir la vie d'un joueur de haut
niveau
et son ressenti quoi je trve les gens
généralement souvent très très dur
envers Maxime
qui quand même fait fait fait le boulot
quoi j' quand même deuxème des candidats
enfin c'est pas non non bien sûr non
mais à une époque sur de travail on pe
se poser la question dire il a T même
répertoire pourquoi il change pas tatati
tata mais tout ça là il l'a corrigé donc
voilà là on peut pas trop le reprocher
grand-chose de ce point de vue
là mais non mais la le j'ai pas de
grande critique à dire ce que j'ai lu
dans le chat là cétait mais des fois oui
on est un peu sévère parce que on qui
aime bien châti bien et tu as envie que
voilà mais là en fait il y a des fois tu
as pas grand chose à reprocher tu as pas
grand chose à reprocher c'est comme ça
hein en plus il est
malade de le tacler sur un trucôle pas
vraiment
genre tu peux pas dire il est tout le
temps malade avant les tourno ça tombe
vraiment
là il y a certains virus qui sont très
contagieux et qui sont un peu chiants à
soigner donc si tu le chopes bon a moi
j'ai fait j'ai dit avant c'est juste tu
vis pas à Paris et tu tévites beaucoup
de problèmes mais bon ça après c'est non
mais tu rigoles mais c'est vrai mais
après ça c'est des choix tu peux pas
reprocher au mecs de vivre enfin
oui si quand même non mais si vous me
dites ok Maxime son défaut c'est de
vivre à Paris et Machin je vous dis oui
bon là je suis obligé d'acquaisser je
dis oui bon VO faut changer ça c'est
vrai qu'il pourrait faire l'effort de
plus vivre à Paris enfin c'est même pas
un effort normalement c'est juste tu une
libération c'est vouis c'est tu
t'upgrad mais ça après c'est c'est un
autre débat mais bon après peut-être qu'
est tellement fort qu'il se pénalisent
il dans cette ville
quoi STO qui dit rien à voir mais un
livre pour apprendre à jouer le pion
isolé ou les pions pendant alors si
c'est si tu as rien contre les DVD
format vidéo on a un petit truc à te
proposer
intéressant il est trouvable toujours
il est trouvable toujours pour le encore
ok donc bah c'était ce que Kev avait
fait avec Vlad c'est vraiment très très
bien après si tu veux absolument un
livre moi je sais pas je trouve que le
livre de babourine était bien je sais
plus comment ça'appelait P structure
peut-être mais je suis pas sûr c'est un
vieux livre des années 90 mais il est
bien voilà mais mais après donc
recommandation numéro une le le contenu
vidéo de kevad et en deux le livre de
babourine et puis peut-être il y aura
d'autres suestion son dans le chat vous
pouvez voir ce que vous dites mais moi
si je devais répondre je dirai ça est-ce
qu'il y a damass 7 ici on regarde
volontairement plus la parti de Maxime
parce que la partie de Baky ça semble
vraiment nul et là il y a encore
peut-être des petites choses à faire il
veut dam7 en fait à chaque fois qu'on
dit DVD c'est pas vraiment un disque que
tuas c'est vraiment un contenu numérique
qui peut être téléchargeable et tout ça
mais c'est juste l'appellation générique
DVD même moi quand je dis je fais des
DVD chest bas ou quoi tu peux l'avoir en
DVD DVD mais façon tu as une clé
d'activation et tu peux aller sur le
chessvass.com et et le télécharger donc
en fait il y a il y a pas de DVD où tu
as besoin du lecteure façon je sais bien
que maintenant les ordis il y a plus
tellement de lecteur DVD c'est damage 4
le coup plutôt que damage 3 je vois
l'ordi et ça c'est un filtre donc oui
non le contenu vidéo il sera il sera
téléchargeable quoi il est
téléchargeable il a regardé en ligne
mais vous PZ vousouer pour le
télécharger et donc une exigence par
rapport à Maxime c'est sûr qu'il un peu
non mais en tout cas il a un grand
talent et donc forcément tu es exigeent
avec des joueurs comme ça qui sont très
forts mais mais après il une diffence
avoir l'exigence et être trop sévère
euh pas dire stash et gris ou je sais
pas quoi enfin c'est deux choses
différentes mais être exigeant c'est
normal tu as envie enfin tu es plus
exigeant avec quelqu'un de de fort et de
talentueux quic quelqu'un que tu sais
que bon bah il fait ce qu'il peut c'est
pas un foot de guerre et bon tu te bats
tu mouilles le maillot et c'est déjà
bien quoi bon bah qui sait enfinf faut
rien faire mais oui fa à jouer je pense
qu'il sa à ne rien faire ouis mais il
réfléchit machin et tout faut faire
gaffe non on a envie qu'il fasse des
choses énormes après ouais moi j'étais
le premier déçu hein mais oui F la c'est
exactement ça pour l'instant vu les
joueurs qu'on a j' don pas plus que bien
se battre et tout donner on n propose un
truc intéressant 7 qui F4 qui C5 j'aime
bien DESS qui prend le 5 ouais ça a
l'air
de ça l'air de bien jouer mais du coup
Damas
7 dame F7 cavalier C5 DC qui
pr faut
F7 F7 du coup si je fais ro C3
intermédiaire en fait je veux répéter le
truc4 à nouveau qui je sa pas TR on va
mais on se place quo
F3 j'imerais bien
AC mb7 il faut vite trouver un en
B
revenir fa Mo je jouer tout ce truc là
quoi non mais c'est une pour les blan je
vois bien00 maisen fait l'option A comme
ça il serait beau
et7en très bien
est-ce que Fabi va essayer de faire G3
H4 non mais dirais globalement dans le
sport les gens dans dans tous les sports
que tu regardes ils sont très result
oriented non toujours oui mais même les
suiveurs même les commentateurs même
même quand tu vas lire le journal le
lendemain et et les soit-disant experts
enfin il sont experts en fait mais qui
alors que le contenu compte évidemment
non mais je vois tu regardes par exle
les matchs de la finale Nouvelle-Zélande
Afrique du Sud HM la Nouvelle-Zélande il
nont pas de super note alors que mais je
veux dire en fait l'arbitre il SIF
pénalité à la dernière seconde quand le
mec il met les mains sur le ballon il
SIF pénalité qui doit y avoir pour les
All Black les All Black gagnent c'est
all black qui vont avoir des super notes
incroyable à 14 qu'elle exploit oua et
et les les Sud-Africains oui très grave
vous mais en fait c'est c'est le même
match c'est le même match et c'est une
faute d'arbitrage en plus à la fin mais
c'est qu'en fait la faute d'arbitrage
elle l'oriente toute vision toute ta
vision du match en c'est pas c'est
complètement con en fait oui mais je
sais pas
comme dis on essaie d'expliquer les
faits plutôt que de déorer le processus
bah ouais mais fait mais en fait du coup
les gens ils ont pris cette habitude en
fait il y a plus que le résultat qui
compte et en
fait bah tu fais tu fais un truc
flamboyant et tu as pas de bol tu es nul
et tuas full chat et ça gagne enfin un
génie tu es un génie ouais mais
c'est c'est dans tous les truc en fait
mais oui quel que soit quel que soit le
sport tu retrouves ça et c'est moi je
trouve ça assez désagréable en fait en
fait à force mais genre même en tant que
spectateur non mais après ce qui
compte on va dire quand tu es athlète
sportif c'est le
résultat mais en fait après quand tu
regardes que tuanalyes ou même que quand
tu discutes tu dois être objectif sur ce
que tu as vu quoi et que là bah tu peux
tu sais quand c'est tu le coup de pouce
du destin pas de chance que tu as tout
bien fait mais bah c'est comme
ça après on perd pas par hasard là je te
donn un exemple par exemple l'arbitre il
se trompe juste en fait c'est pas par
hasard pénalité tu gagnes il donnes pas
pénalité tu perds enfin il donne
pénalité à l'autre tu perds es pour rien
en plus tuas raison tu vois la vidéo
après que tu as raison qu'est-ce que tu
veux y faire c'est fait c'est
fait G sont lés globalement ça je suis
d'accord avec toi Toir mais le problème
c'est que le public a pris cette
habitude là aussi h et donc tout n'est
plus qu'orienté par le
résultat
l'important c'est les trois
points dans le SP il y a que le résultat
qui compte bah je suis pas d'accord bah
pas vraiment en fait puis encore moins
quand tu es dans un processus de
formation mais je vais te prendre
l'exemple on parle souvent avec Maxime
euh et tu vois des fois il peuent comme
il sa que je regard toutes les parties
tu vois on discute un peu et tout et en
fait je sais que le premier truc qui
regarde c'est le contenu pour voir si ce
qu'il fait c'est bien ou pas tuis direis
ça va j'ai mieux joué j'ai mieux calculé
là c liges là les lignes je les avais je
les avais pas des fois il peut avoir
gagné une partie jou GG Maxime et tout
il me d non j'avais rien j'ai
j'ai eu du bol et tout c'était pas bien
dans le calcul puis une autre fois il va
il va faire nul et tout il dit non mais
bon j'avais tout et c'est enfin tu vois
en fait les les sportifs eu même ils
regardent
ça je suis sur la bonne mais au final
enin si c'est un truc qui compte
vraiment tu jouis un Ding NPO final
champion du monde non mais ça c'est
différent diff c'est r en fait ce
scénario ce moment là en fait avant tuas
tout un processus et et voilà mais
d'ailleurs Ding nepo quand tu regardes
le match à postéori tu sais que c'est
NPO qui a dominé nepo mérité de gagner
bien sûr mais en fait tu le dis enfin
ouais c'est juste mental là mais gen en
terme d'échec il a juste mieux jouéou et
après il a implosé pour d'autres raisons
mais et je dire bon ok au départage Ding
a bien joué mais sur toute la durée du
match tu gagé 10 fois ouais 10
fois non mais tennis des fois tu
regardes des matchs aussi enfin je sais
pas tu es à 6 5 machin le gars il
commence à faire une lette après il a un
haok match des machins et en fait il
doit jamais gagner puis il gagne et puis
quand tu parles à des joueurs de tennis
professionnel pareil il disent ouis mais
il faut de la réussite quoi non mais il
en faut un peu dans les moments clés
mais après voilà il une différence
entreir full chance etir provoquer un
peu et il faut que ça tombe du bon
côté
donc bref mais ce que je c'est que le le
le contenu est souvent trop analysé là
je parlais évidemment le résultat est
important ou quoi mais c'est souvent
analysé que par le prisme du résultat et
ça c'est c'est bête en fait c'est un
c'est un réflexe que tout le monde a
parce que voilà les journalistes ont
donné cette manière d'analyser les
matchs systématiquement mais du coup dès
que quelqu'un perd faut trouver une
explication il a pas assez travaillé il
a mal joué ou quoi enfin des fois juste
Ilas pas de chance en fait
oui tu referais le truc une semaine
après une semaine avant le lendemain G
on peut reprendre l'exemple du rugby en
fait France Afrique du Sud moi je je
déteste critiquer l'arbitrage au rugby
et je veux dire il y a eu des décisions
les des deux côtés mais tu vois bien que
tu es un tout petit peu arbitré
différemment tu te qualifies quoi tu
perds qu' un point tu es pas défoncé de
50 points ah ouais puis mais ce qu'il y
a de fou c'est que quand j'ai vu les
gens dire oui que Galtier donc resta là
te tout le travail de à la
poubelle pour un match où ça se joue à
rien rraac enfin c'est les boxes qui
finissent champion du monde qui sont
champions du monde en titre qui te
battre d'un point sur un match que
franchement dans le contenu tu audessus
franchement moi le truc le plus tu vois
après en direct moi le l'interception
des CB je la vois en arrière aussi moi
je la vois en avant mais
voilà c'est sujet interprétation au
moins tuapp la vidéo non mais je même
c'est sujet interprétation mais on va
dire que l'arbitre il a pas forcément
complètement tort ou complètement raison
tu peux l'arbitrer des deux côtés moi je
la vois en arrière il en a d'autres qui
la voit en avant bon on sait pas mais en
gros si l'arbitre en disant elle est en
avant parce qu'il met que une main et
que normalement les interceptions quand
pas sûr il faut mieux que ce soit de
main il essaie de rabattre admettons
qu'il il peut vraiment sujet
interprétation mais il peut
l'interpréter comme comme essai de
pénalité carton jaune en fait il a le
droit aussi bah en fait s interprète
comme ça ben 14-0 ils sont ils sont 14
c'est on gagne peut-être pas quand même
mais je sais pas mais oui c'est un autre
match et puis tuas un moment donné tu as
un grattage aussi où il met les mains au
sol comme contre les Black et on peut
repasser devant et après le match on le
perd tout seul c'est un autre débat mais
j'arêtre aussi sévère pour un truc
où la pièce elle t vraiment pas de ton
côté je pense tu joues le match 10 fois
tu le gagnes fois quoi ou se fois bon
bah pas grave mais c'est comme
ça il des trucs objectif la transf
contré ouais bon contré ça après
peut-être qu'il la met
pas non mais V puis bon c'est comme ça
mais
euh mais je encore une fois genre en
fait la France c'est pourri je il te
donne la pénalité encore une fois sur
exactement le même joueur qui met les
bras au sol Ramos la passe ah l'équipe
de France des génies il s'arrache contre
les Blacks machin du pont hom 10 match
enfin oui alors c'est le même match
alors c'est exactement le même match
c'est juste l'arbitre qui d'un côté ou
de l'autre et en tout cas donc tu peux
être déçu de dire c'est dommage tu peux
quand même réfléchir à ce que tu auraas
pu faire de mieux parce que finalement
tu pourrais être encore plus fort et pas
être assez coup du destin près ou quoi
bon c'est dur hein mais mais en tout cas
tu tu vas pas commencer à dire ouais si
Gal on le dégageait et ce qu'il est si
bien et Machin enfin
je prenais un exemple un peu que tout le
monde connaît oui puis récent et récent
et c'est dans tous les sports pareil
c'est dans tous les trucs
pareil pareil au tennis et tu vas perdre
97 dans le Super t du
dernier moins bien joué machin dans les
points importants làbas tu as une rafale
devant et tu oui vraiment très fort
enfin c'est moi je trouve ça
insupportable à
force et du coup moi je pense que c'est
les journalistes qui
ouais qui veulent raconter une histoire
mais les gens en fait veulent qu'on leur
raconte des histoires qui ont aucun
rapport avec la réalité mais qui sont
très faciles à comprendre tu as perdu tu
es nul tu as gagné tu es bon enfin mais
que la réussite ou quoi ça rentre ou que
machin ou que tout soit vraiment
nettement plus complexe ça non ils nous
prennent pour des cons mais ils ont
raison apparemment on est cons donc mais
on nous prend pour des cons ça c'est sûr
mais est-ce qu'on a raison de nous
prendre pour des con malheureusement
peut-être
[Musique]
M
V te manquer de colomoani ouais non mais
là bon c'est le GO adverse qui fait un
gros arrêt ça c'est la vie he
mais parti à l'écran qui compte bouge
une pièce et pire en fait si quand Mme
avec la dame tu veux rentrer mais
peut-être tu peux pas parce que tu te
fais
contrer la position de Baky a une petite
évolution donc ça dépend mais
visuellement tu ça l'air très bien pour
les blancs visuellement tu vas sur la
bot line quoi ou au top c'est plutôt le
top je pense P pas à lol mais à lol je
pense que là c'est le top et là c'est la
bot line je pense
et là c'est mid quoi ils font n'importe
quoi comme d'hab toujours le bordel je
je je veux pas trop y
aller euh ouais ça va pas trop évoluer
en même temps faire G3 H4 non mais ça
peut durer très longtemps C histoire et
la nu est pas encore dans la poche
mais mais euh mais voilà on va voir fa
muter la map nous zap d'ailleurs j'ai
découvert zap qu' avait une
une basilique
saintolaf ça met extrêmement
bien c'est mon perso sur ilvoie des ha
je joue plus tr tu jouer là j'ai pas le
temps mais sinon faut que je progresse
sur mon trinda
là chaud pour qu'on fasse un petit
Football Manager C sort dans 4
jours mais donc il a il y a la basilique
Saint-Olaf je suis très
heureux
benah je me sens un peu tu souffles
comme tu V Olaf tu dis ok c'est
important quoi
ouais moi je vais attendre bah déjà là
on a pas trop le temps tu on passe nos
journées à regarder ça pendant 6 he
donc non mais après en plus on doit
faire le recap machin faut qu'on mange
un peu et puis ben les jour pas vite
donc euh cousous quoi oui il n en
reste mais mais quand ça sera fini
pourquoi pas j'aimais bien jouer ça fait
quelques versions que je joue plus parce
que j'ai moins le temps de
ouis si ça peut un peu streamer ou quoi
dus on peut streamer à fond oua ouais
mais par contre faut que tu fasses gaffe
au langage parce que c'est vrai que tu
peux facilement insulter les joueur
ouais bah surtout qu'on va remonter en
Ligue 1 avec l'OL avec l'OL Mo avec l'OL
oui peut-être aussi si on joue à FM 2025
FM 2024 2023 on va remonter avec la SSE
faut peut-être pas que je joue en live
en fait il on on fait des coupes
partout et on peut tomber contre l'OL et
puis ça peut ça peut mal se passer quoi
h je pense que même sur football en le
derby contre l'OL tu es très chaud non
ah bah
oui tu les déteste en fait
c'est bizarre tout déjà à un moment ça
devient ça devient important en fait
alors que c'est un jeu on s'en fout
quoi à cause de toi vraiment dès que
tuas un gars qui me dit qu'il vient de
Lyon j'ai une truc négatif quoi
attention ouais mais ça peut être un
connard de lyonnais tu vois j'ai aucune
raison j'en ai rien à en fait
mais à cause de toi j'ai attention c'est
un Lonis enfin j'ai une impréhension
négative et ça c'est à cause de
toi j'ai j'ai pas dit grand chose quoi
je non mais à force de ce truc de fou
des supporters des machins je
m'intéresse non mais en plus lon
souhaite pas de
descendre donc je suis
pas pas je suis pas je suis pas un
méchant quoi al qu'ils sont très gentils
c'est une très belle ville d'ailleurs
non la V est sympa en plus je plus je
joue pour Lyon cette année aux échecs
donc tu vois non mais c'est une belle
sais moi dans un moment je voulais
réellement aller vivre à Lyon non mais
c'est pas mal enf parce que j'aime bien
c'est bien placé c'est pratique pour les
events
c'est bien mais peut-être je relancer le
projet enfin peut-être je serais très
bien à Lyon enfin la ville est en plus
c'est très proche de Sainté donc là
forcément c'est un gros point fort quoi
mais c'est proche de tout c'est enfin
j'aime bien en fait donc fait genre j'ai
aucun a priori négatif enfin je suis
très heureux d'aller en vacances à Lyon
c'est même Lenna qui que je saoule parce
que souvent je me dis quand elle veut
partir en weekend tiens on pour aller à
Lyon enfin je suis très heureux non mais
c'est bien Lyon c'est un petit Paris et
c'est non mais c'est très bien mais à
cause de toi ou grâce à toi j'ai je me
dit attention quand même non mais sois
vigilant mais mais il peuvent être sympa
aussi tu peux bien manger tu peux çavoir
c'est quand même un Lionnais quoi tu tu
vois
et mais pour le coup ouais comme je te
dis moi je je le souhaite pas de
descendre en Ligue
2 nous ouais alors que du coup moi je le
souhaite mais toi tu es toxique donc
descend en Ligue 2 en National aller
voir ce qui se
passe
enfin en tout cas tout ça pour dire que
j'ai de base j'ai plôt a priori positif
la ville est plutôt jolie on mange bien
c'est bien placé pas loin des Alpes des
Alpes vite tu vite par tu dois traver
mais tu pas Paris non plus un aéroportas
un aéroport ouais tu es pas loin de
Genève tu peux aller en
enfin hyper bien placé tu tues pas très
loin de Barcelone d'ailleurs 4 He ouis
tu fais 45 minutes de train tu es dans
le
chaudron c'est c'est hyper bien en fait
il y a plein de points positifs mais bon
c'est Strasbourg ouais je suis déjà allé
c'est pas mal Strasbourg mais euh je
connais pas très bien
mais on a quelques villes pas mal en
France et la vieille ville de Lyon est
vraiment très joli pour le coup
HM le climat est moins bien qu'acan
ouais mais euh tu as d'autres points
positifs ouais bon après c'est des
histoires de vie de choix de après c'est
cher aussi non Lyon c'est un peu cher
c'est devenu cher mais parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui sont ven par enfin
c'est bah c'est une grande ville enfin
c'est
V des qui trop ok mais c'est pas ville
des frères Lumière
si pas trop c'est
intéressant qui on prend c'est quoi
c'est juste d' prend
[Musique]
ou les Chan de qualification d'IR via le
grand Suisse c'est terminé la partie
elle est vraiment horrible et Ben qui
euh il attend il a raison
ouais c'est dur à trouver ce
que tour
prend de ouais tu profites de qu' prends
échec de plus es heureux il a encore ça
mais bon
oui on comprend qu'on soit plutôt
bien c'est hyper dur il va jamais
trouver on ben pourquoi pas mais bon en
même temps tu es pas obligé de faire C3
je vais F6 trouver4 non mais ça ok enfin
je de devoir faire C4 un jour mais
pourquoi tu
m avec la tour mais bon puis alors enfin
ça joue ouis donc non je il a fait tour
mais oui bon faut pas faire TR pr C3
quoi mais ça ça se voit enfin
is bah qui a encore une partie à
rallonge he h non mais Carona il peut
jouer des parties bah on se souvient la
partie contre Maxime justement au
candidat ça avait duré duré duré ah mais
en plus qui est incroyable avec B avec
by moi avec bakiwi aussi mais avec
Fabiano là c'est que Fall quand même
d'enchaîner le tour le championnat des
États-Unis il est dans un tournoi où il
était obligé de jouer avec les contrats
machin enfinon peut qu'il aurait quand
même pu se retirer mais peu importe il a
décidé d'honorer ses trucs bon ça
motivation il est déjà au candidat il a
gagné le
truc il a pas de motivation il joue
depuis 25 jours d'affilé au bout d'un
moment tu peux dire bon là il B il a
réussi à faire nul bravo by
encoup fait je le J à fond en fait mis à
part lui Yan je pense qu' aurait tenté
ouais c'est par qui a battu Douda c'est
chaud ça mis à part TR qu joueurs au
monde qui ont qui qui peuvent être des
empêcheurs de Tournon et qui donne tout
enfin c'est quand même à souligner B qui
qui trouve d'AM
F6 là C4 ça me paraît pas évident quand
même quoi d'autre mais bon
ou que là tu me V de le prendre en fait
c'est pour refaire tour C1 bon
bravo
donc ça logique
mais après B qui va la tenir celleel on
connait B
qui Sophie qui a fait nul très bien bon
résultat surtout je crois qu'elle était
pas bien B qui trouve tout ça abusé B
après là comment
dire tu devais c'était le seul coup en
fait c'était pas vraiment à trouver
après il a laissé une petite chance à
Fabi mais
petite
en fait by il est dominé quand il c'est
égal et dès qu'il est moins bien c'est
un mur te met les Barb c'est un
mur c'est qu' per mais je pense pas
qu'il a perde
après non mais tout t j possible mais
franchement il fait sa
partie il pas de raison atts et chez
Parin il a combien du coup il revient
avec B et tout ça vient seulement avec
Baky il dépasse pas
non il fait quoi je sais que c'est plus
ou moins censé êre égal mais dech il a
gagner ça c'est
signéizi il va pas la gagner va pas
gagner ok il peut s'en prendre un peu à
lui-même là che parinov qui remonte
c'est quand même je sais pas trop quel
temps il a fait chezpin je crois qu'il a
pas fait grandchose en
fait je crois qu'il fait de la dobe en
fait il par grâ nul arogant nul nul
c'est mais a il pas de B qu' joue bien
il se fait défoncer sa moyenne c'est bon
ça va tu as tellement joué d'autres que
tu es pas devant les mecs ont fait tout
par devant mais tu fais quand même ton
tournoi quoi deou il pas de
B
et OK et ça aussi du coup c'est un autre
gars 5 et demi
qui
dou la descente aux enfers bah il fait
ouaisilà par rapport à Maxime sur lequel
vous étiez un peu sévère Douda c'est un
peu le même profil en moins fort et lui
par contre on voit qu'il a vraiment
régressé depuis un moment contrairement
à Maxime qui revient en fait il une
pente descendante mais il a pas de
rebond pour le moment ça peut arriver al
que Maxime on sent qu'il y a quand même
un ré rebond dans le jeu
donc à 5 de va y avoir
qui n il va y avoir on vous dit un petit
peu va avoir
ici avir son 5 dem on dire entre fa
Fabian
ETTI
prorme groupe et en dessous mais bon
norm c'est un groupe très peu d'espoir
mais tu auras des v des me comme ça qui
sont à 5 des
[Musique]
maximeeir
il a pas d'infiltration rien ok donc5is
cé coup de l'ordi donc en fait c'est mon
signe il a fait des 5 assez vite ok donc
il s'est il s'est ouvert les cases
noires c'est pas mal pour un cavalier
pour la dame pour tout ça B qui il aura
le deuxè départage mais après c'est des
choses qui peuvent un peu changer on
verra il faudra gagner une partie pour
Baky voir peut-être même deux une
devrait suffire mais c'est pas garanti
mais ça peut elle sera dure à gagner
mais mais bon tu joues contre un parinov
qui prend qui va jouer sa partie enfin
c'est faisable après faut tenir
aujourd'hui comme disais il a un peu la
réussite B dans le tourno quand
Mme moi comme j'ai pas mal jou au poker
je crois au R en fait à cause de ça je
crois que les rush c'est c'est très
fort Mo je pense quand tu as de la
chance tu as de la chance quoi et quand
en as pas quand pas tu en as pas comment
dire surtout un truc où tu es obligé
d'avoir de la chance globalement de
toute façon pour passer je miserai plus
sur quelqu'un qui a de la chance pour en
être arrivé là quelqu'un qui en a pas eu
quoi mais c'est comme hier comme néo
quand soign c'est comme hier en fait il
a besoin du temps qui revient et ça Tom
pile sur le 60e en fait je pas c'est
trop de signes comme ça où c'est full
réussite et je crois la full réussite en
fait regarde l'Afrique du Sud au
rugby si on compte pas que mais bon on
va dire que les arbitres sont honnêtes
parce que c'est le plus probable
d'ailleurs à chaque fois c'est un tuas
la réussite en réussite en demi tuas
encore la réussite en final enfin moi
j'y crois à ce truccl de
réussite donc je me dis B qui a plus
s'il regagne une partie sur les trois
dernières il va passer en fait parce que
ça se passera
bien
éorme gaff Dey non quoi non vrai
peut-être que l'ordi a dit un truc ouais
il s excité et puis la jou remise
mais
on attend le coup de Pichot et on
souffle 5 minutes et on revient pour par
que Pichot à priori il a un seul coup à
peu près jouable qu' F4 c'est pas le
plus dur d'ailleurs il l'a joué parce
qu'il était hor jeu et que ça paralise
un peu la dame adverse pour pour
rentrer
euh mais j'aime bien la conception de
Maxime alors après c'est pas simple
parce que la dame elle peut rentrer en
B1 elle peut rentrer en D3
si mais de c'est donner à cas C5 pour le
cavalier c'est cool et on joue cont le
mauvais fou adverse
et ça dur de parer tous les il y a un
espoir quoi et et B qui sa raté en face
on souffle ça jouer B4 mais c'est pas si
naz c'est un peu le même genre de délire
mais ça a raté un avantage une nouvelle
fois
ouais mais c'est pas naz comme C non
mais c'est dans le tempo de la partie en
fait où c'est pas le top top mais ça
reste ce que je disais quand tu as la
réuss s parce qu'en fait tu jettes un
peu une pièce comme bil dit souvent he
de toute façon le clic au hasard ça
vient de là hein c'est pas c'est pas de
moi ça de base mais c'est vrai que tu
jettes un peu une pièce à certain moment
et j'ai l'impression qu'elle tombe du du
meilleur
côté alors après évidemment c'est aussi
parce que bah on l'a comparé avec la
partie de bakier d'alierza alerza il
permet à l'adversaire de jeter la pièce
du mauvais côté là liresa il a il y
avait plus d'erreurs possible HM
h je crois que ça peut faire nul en
force en
fait estce que regarde en fait cavalier
prendre des5 ça va pas passer parce qu'
y a un dame C3 à la fin je pense il est
tombé quoi que il veut ça ça ça ça ça
il a tour C de et tu vas te
derrière et oui ouais bon ça ça va être
sé et du coup si tu fais tour F4 qui
était le coup Gal moi je pensais tu as
dame C3 dame dame oua C j' déjà en train
de bon du
coup
aller
ça donc je crois que B4 c'est vraiment
une une
erreur pasuc
surciucattend 15 c'est un bug en fait
c'est
un
ok on on paette ouais on fait une petite
pause et on revient pour la fin à tout
de
suite
[Musique]
bon alors il y a eu ce qu'on attendait
dans la partie de Baky apparemment la
seule chance pour mettre la pression
c'est d'avoir dame prend C3 t prend C3
et cavalier G4 al c'est pas une énorme
pression mais c'est c'est le seul truc à
partir de maintenant à mon avis qui
force à trouver des choses ça
m'étonnerait sûement que c'est pas forcé
ce que tu as trouvé non plus dame 2 pour
prend B4 qui
D1 taper un peu partout bah tu pièce je
pense ouais dame 2 du coup tu peux faire
tour
B7
qui a l'air
d'aller Fab à chaque fois qu'il a dû
trouver quelque chose pour un peu faire
la DIF il l'a raté
aujourd'hui les dam C3 t C3 cavalier G4
est-ce que ça peut poser un Véel
problème peut-être un tout petit peu
genre ro F8 cavalier
E5 F5 ouais bon ça a l'air d'aller quand
même
si coup c'est prend G6 pour prendre les
risques à la con il va pas le faire et
si tu fais
G4
G5
ok bon mais après je sais pas
visuellement les noirs peuvent se
tromper quoi non bien s tu peux dire que
tu rentres làedans parce que ça te fait
suer j'en sais rien moi mais même ça
est-ce que c'est
si
complexe
mettons que tu fasse ça ça
ça tu prends et ça
ouais mais bon oui oui oui ça va ça ça
ça ça ça mais ça ça doit être nul c'est
que des échecs en
fait mais bon tu peux espérer de faire
un échec là prendre là si
tu non mais tu fais encore un peu je
suis d'accord ça ça pas juste pour
expliquer genre ça et là on aimerait
bien avoir tour B7 pour faire nul tout
de suite mais ça ça doit perdre
ou ça peut perdre en tout cas ça peut
perdre mais bon Fabiano il a pas
trouvver les coups quand il devait les
trouver aujourd'hui donc
euh mvl c'est quoi l' évaluation que dit
bah il est pas mal mvel parce que il
propose d'échange des dames quand on
échange alors cert tu peux gag un P H3
mais le problème c'est qu'il y a le roi
blanc qui a une route toute tracée et
que le fou c'est un
plot donc après faut voir peutêtre
de aussi ok pas non non c'est pas l'ordi
c'est moi là mais en fait je vois pas
trop comment tu fais une dame quoi non
non mais faut essayer G6 et je sais pas
quoi leur dis la mis les noir mais moi
j'aurais hyper
peur
ordi c'est
précis non mais toute façon en fait le
truc c'est que picho il peut pas trop
éviter un tel scénario et donc c'est
çaid de Maxime donc elle est plutôt très
intéressante son
idée après est-ce qu'il peut échanger
les dames et courir avec 3 7 pour vite
aller en C7 mettre le fon c'est vite
très passif mais peut-être que ça peut
tenir ou
ou pas ça une sal gueule en génér quand
tu jou comme ça
mais ça tient ça tient il peut y avoir
des Zang parce que tu peux ne plus avoir
de coups à un moment
donné qu' repart de l'autre côté ouais
je pense si tu échanges des cavaliers
déjà ce sera
perdant en C5 avec G4
ouais
donccoute très bonne ESS de Maxime quoi
qu'il en soit que ça suff à gagner je
sais pas mais il y a de vraies Bell Chan
c'est bien joué ce qu'il a fait ok prise
c pr
C2 pr H3 quand
même plus précis ça gagne des
cavalier pas de
cavalier plus malin de comme ça il va
faire3
çaajoute
partout spingo c'est fini ou pas
euh c'est fini yes ok il a gagné il
rejoint donc vidit en tête et D et on
espère que Maxime rejoigne kimer
voilà il a pris H3 OK et c'est signé nul
ou c'est signé nul ok donc il reste un
demi pointo derrière les leaders
on espère qu'il rejoigne Fabiano et
Étienne qu'il se fasse rejoindre par
euh ok bon c'est juste attendu vu ce
qu'on avait vu il y a pas eu de ch ou je
sais pas
quoi Maxime qui peut vraiment la gagner
hein on des tris jouer
évidemment Fabi qui tank fort for va
regarder les dames
de faut absolument que Baky évite ikarou
demain
ouais ben ouais éviter ikarou c'est
toujours une bonne chose
ouais surtout qu'on a dit que Siou s'il
joue ikarou il redouble les Noirs
ouais mais il peut il a doublé les
blancs ouais donc qui double les
Noirs c'est pas interdit quoi on va dire
surtout le H comme demain la ronde est à
11h30 pour eux il a pas jouer très
longtemps puis les matinal le H stream
souvent le matin pour les
États-Unis puis il est enfin c'est un
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d'énergie enfin
je pense c'est pas c'est pas le bon
moment pour le prendre demain
h donc demain
demain c'est midi et demi la partie ne
ratait pas oui il change l'horaire he
pour je sais pas pour le car pour le
carnaval de l' of man il y a un truc
demain
ouais ça joue pas ni d'un côté ni de
l'autre pour Max une chancep mais non si
Maxime il fait 6 points il passe hein
s'il fait 6 points si fait 6 victoires
d'affilé donc 8 points bah on pense que
oui après si sont trois execou à
non mais c'est sûr parce que je pense
que Bakil a une bonne chance avec son
départage de gagner à 7 pass à 7 et demi
enfin il a une chance mais Maxim s' fait
8 en fait qu'il aura éliminé quelqu'un
au
passage au bout d'un moment si tu gagnes
tout tu les tu les enlèves ouais c'est
un pe comme un f guys quoi tu les tires
quoi en fait s'il gagne là il se
retrouve à 6 quand il sera à 6 si B qu'
finit de moin ENF il jouera un mec de ce
groupe là donc s' le bat il élimine et
puis une fois qu'il est à 7 il rejo un
mec qui normalement tu passes quoi ça
serait juste le cas de figure incroyable
où tu as trois mecs à vite non mais je P
mais ce que je c'est qu'en fait à la
dernière ronde tu joues soit quelqu'un à
7 qui fera pas 7 et demi si tu le bats
ou soit quelqu'un qui a 7 et demi et qui
fera pas 8 si tu le bat en fait je pense
juste que par le fait de tu sais tire la
corde quoi non mais normalement oui mais
il y a des cas de figure où non mais il
y a rare cas de figure mais ce sera pas
le cas genre tuas demain ou DH gagne et
les autres se mettent sur la gueule il y
en a un qui gagne ils ont déjà le nombre
de points qu'il faut et que après ils
rebattent d'autres et puis bah c'est ils
sont ils sont catapultés je sais pas où
je pense qu'à la dernière il joue Maxim
il tire ouais mais Maxim j des mec comme
lui il a d'autres tirer il doit tirer
Carana il do tirer carou enfin qui les
tire
quoi me qui arrive par derrière il te
quoi Bonot qui vaéchir qui va se tromper
à un
moment
et Carona qui tente le fameux k
G4 mais bon pense que c'est trop
tard a faut encore défendre le truc ça
demande de nouveaux efforts à Baki à la
ronde de
demain après il récupère bien Baky
généralement quand même ouais mais le
matin c'est moins mais le matin c'est
moins son truc
ouais ah disons qu'il aime bien bien se
préparer mais bon après il connaît bien
B s'inquiète pas mais il aime bien bien
se préparer et
donc finir vraiment tard ce soir ce qu'
a déjà fini vraiment tard hier mais bon
il est solide
Baky faut qu'il appelle Kaido quoi il
casse la gueule de son adversaire et
puis c'est fini on parle plus toi tu le
connais bien ce Kido ou pas bien non
mais j'ai déjà joué contre lui je l'
déjà croisé il est hyper barque est il
est costaud il est sympa mais il est
vraiment ah il est grand et ouais il il
est quoi il est ouvert il est il est
gentil ou il est un peu renfermé non il
est gentil est
gentilur so je sais pas trop mais il est
non il est gentil il discute machin
enfin ça va c'est pas c'est pas un ours
dans sa
grotte donc il y a plusieurs manières de
faire nul hein comme on l'a vu mais il
faut pas se tuer quoi même àg passe en
fait là tout passe mais il peut y avoir
un moment dans quelques coups où ça peut
être plus plus facile ou plus
dur joue le dragon accéléré à mon av
joue
tout je crois que c'est un personnage
dans One
Pièce après c'est un manga je connais
pas du
tout
pièce je connais pas trop non
plus s'appelle KEDO
il est costaud aussi ah je sais pas je
regardeis je sais juste que personnage
principal c'est
Luffy G qui a un chapeau une genre de
casquette B plus que
930 ah je ça sèche aussi ouais mais il y
a peut-être un truc avec les deux tours
où va falloir être précis à moment donné
pe ça peut un peu te faire suer ouais
mais c'est rien en fait objectivement
mais faut AR à bien juger quoi non mais
là il y a beaucoup de trucs qui vont
hein HD ça va kf5 ça va F ça va bon
beaucoup de coups vont quoi tuas tous
les coups que tu as envie de regarder
ils vont
[Musique]
donc
Maxime il est parti avec 3 des7 son
adversaire
ok donc il cherche pas le contre avec le
RO g G6 F5 ou quoi comm on a pu voir à
un
moment mais
je j'y crois bien pour
Maxime mais bon va voir parce qu'en fait
il ce qu'il veut faire c'est
squeboter Pichot mettre le fou en C8 le
roi qui tient le fou bon ça défend a ça
défend machin l'autre qui qui verevolte
un peu à droite à gauche et euh bon on
verra c'est
tendu faudrait qu'on ait le duolingo en
coréen pour savoir comment dire c'est
étendu encore
rien je ni pour Envel ni pour Baky moi
je pense qu' vont faire un DEM sur de là
B qui je vois pas la
perdre après pour moi l'important sera
qu'il ait les blancs demain comme ça il
peut bien faire une petite nuulle et il
reste de
GAM au cas où sil a vraiment plus
l'énergie parce que ça peut être
être
difficile
et et Maxime toute façon il a pas le
choix est-ce que Carana pe faire une
gaffe non gaffe de Carana c'est pas
possible bah qui peut jouer param demain
oui oui il peut par il m'a l'air
fortandme non il peut il peut vraiment
j'ai
pas
pr que pour Baky possible je pense pas
avec son très proches je pense pas mais
après ça peut si pr que tellement joué
trop de joueurs quand Mme lu trouver un
adversaire dans son groupe de points et
que machin
mais je pense vasy je prends ça vas-y
vas-y on a le Fab
qui nous quitte une petite
minute le Fab qui
su donc là on va voir un Baky 6 minutes
il prend bien son temps comme je disais
le seul enfin tout est tous les voyants
sont ouverts pour Baky le seul truc
c'est que demain la partie est plut tôt
ça c'est vraiment pas de bol par contre
on parlait de la réussite avant ça c'est
pas de bol de de jouer aussi longtemps
avant une partie qui débute 3h plus
tôt
Maxime après c'est le même problème mais
bon Maxime il est tellement au pied du
mur à devoir tout gagner que bah faut
prendre la victoire et
voir c'est à cause de la fête foraine ou
je sais pas quoi ou carnaval ou parce
que B il joue moins vite et je pense
c'est c'est un petit signe de de fatigue
de pression c'est parti difficile il est
il est moins bien pendant
longtemps
feu d'artifice ouais ou mais bon feu
d'artifice do bien avoir des trucs avec
hein alors ça c'est une faute
c'est hyper facile à expliquer en fait
roi FC5 il a cavalier D3 mais
apparemment si le cavalier vient en F2
c'est problématique pour les noirs et je
suppose c'est parce que si tu remets la
pression par ici ben le cavalier vient
en D3 il va te contrôler ah il veut
peut-être faire cavalier H4 bon je sais
pas alors c'est
complexe pour le moment qui
tankque mais bon il y a tellement de
coups qui font nul il faut
choisir il a fait cavalier F2 Maxime et
sur cavalier G6 il va vouloir autre
chose
ah j'ai compris sur qui G6 il a cavalier
H3 facile à trouver parce que j'ai eu
sans
ordi donc maintenant le roi va venir en
D8 le cavalier va venir en C5 le fou va
venir en C et le cavalier va venir en D3
et ça c'est horrible pour Pichot parce
que sil recule bah il va perdre G5 et là
ben on a la finale qu'on aimait déjà
bien mais avec un pion de plus et sil
prend en D3 on va pouvoir reprendre du
roi ou du cavalier et ramener le
cavalier H3 gagner le pion et la finale
elle va gagner
probablement donc Maxime Maxime là ça
prend forme maintenant une petite nulle
de Baky on n pas si
mal mais Maxime incroyable quel dommage
quand on voit avec le recul qu'il est
qu'il est commencé le tournoi malade ça
lui a coûté vraiment cher en entrée et
là on voir qui revient fort tro
victoires
consécutives ça se dessine pour maximeot
qui a fait cavalier F4 grosse erreur ça
va laisser du cavalier H3 cavalier prend
G5 pot qui qui a craqué cette fois-ci by
qui réfléchit alors attention de pas
avoir le cocktail la tu il a pas de bol
parce qu'il a que des coups qui marchent
donc faut choisir choisir et des fois ça
me fait penser au livre de galfand quoi
des fois c'est le pire h tu aurais pas
de choix il a super bien défendu sans
choix B et là il va encore forcément il
va trouver le coup gen en fait comme il
a pas le choix B il se met mal au temps
et peut-être au moment du coup faudra
trouver le coup sans choix ce sera plus
dur mais après je pense que la position
est tout à fait solide donc ça va tenir
mais attention quand même là côté Maxime
il lui manque plus que cavalier C5 fou
C6 et cavalier CD3 mais qui est
complètement dans les cordes de Maxime
puis dégag tu tu prends G5 et tu gagnes
facile après qui les contre mauvais fous
euh très bien en facile faudra encore
bien manœuvrer mais bon ça
va on connait ce genre de truc ouais P
avec la main tu un moment ah bah
tiens et B qui qui a joué roi
F8 quiétait un des coup CIO 5 F5 et on
parlait de G4 ou alors il y a le fameux
qui prend G6 de l'ordi mais je pense pas
qu'il trou je pense pas même pas qu'il
l'essaye mais bon tour 6 qui menace tour
G5 du coup tu dois repartir avec le
cheval quif je crois que tu te fais
planter part recette ouais
ouais tu dois vraiment pas aller là
vraiment aller en H8 peut-être qu' va te
prendre H5 un jour c'est
ça il
continue
ça c'est la chance que ça perde pas
ouais donc qui a raté
ça complètement raté ça c'est
sûr ça c'est hyper
dangereux apr estce que Fabi vair
ça par chance trouve que même si a ça
perd
pason
après le truc c'est qu'avec blancs tu
res pas trop parce pire tu as ça oui oui
laiss pas trop le P on va voir c'est
quoi le live il a pas joué
non là ça peut être la baraca jusqu'au
bout mais normalement quand Bara je dis
la Bara c'est jusquau bout cavalier des
TR pour
Maxime ou mais c'est faites confiance au
j poker le vie quandas la baracaas la
baraca
par contre truc sévère au poker quand la
baraca s'arrête c'est fini ouais ça peut
faire très très
mal faut mieux se barrer merci au revoir
je prends m gain je prends marrêes de 3
jours quoi souvent après tu perds en
lucidité en fait tu av tellement de
réussite que tout pass tu crois que ça
devient normal que en fait même les
trucs qui es devenu un peu large que tu
avais la baraca tu pensais que ça passe
en fait c'est pas vraiment que tu as
plus de chance mais c'est genre
quequili mais vraiment tu avais
tellement l'habitude que tu pouvis un
peu abuser parce que tout passait que
bah tu continues sauf qu'en fait c'était
objectivement pas le
meilleur mais je pense c'est un peu
pareil aux échecs genre tuas tout qui
passa du et tout d'un coup tu commences
à perdre toutes les parties les mecs
trouvent tout et
tu je comprends plus pourquoi mais je
pense pas qu'il va l'avoir cavali5 et il
prend G6 après c'est trouvable quand
même en partie bah il peut hein juste la
saison k 5 tuas envie de faire non k 5
fait c'est le coup que tu vas faire F5
c'est forcé ouais tu peux penser que
Bou oua moi j'aurais pu le faire en fait
là tiens tu t 6
ah en fait ça tu vois c'est un truc
j'aurais pu le faire en blitz mais
peut-être pas mais en longue ça m'aurait
fait
chier mais bon je suis con quoi en blit
j'aurais largement pu le faire si j'y
pense he mais Caval 5 F5 je dir tiens
j'ai rien G4 passe pas 3 on verra
pousser les pions
ouais
bon allez baraka time il il l'a pas il
fait cavalier F6 t C4 qui prend D5 prend
F4 qui prend F4 D4 monsieur sur pr 7
tuattend
bien F4 d'ailleurs t' env mais bien ch
du coup qui tente un
cavalier2 attends F regarde C 5 C7 et
FEM F un truc joli genre tu fais
n'importe quoi tu fais cavalier1 qui C3
qui D3 qui B3 Matth
ça tu'as mis pas bien non tout d'un coup
ouais tu as sué non quand tu l'as vu
chance roi C5 il va te faire roi C7 ah
il a cavalier G1 du coup tu V faire qu
ouais il prends la case H3 de merde ah
ouais ok ben faut faire TR ah en fait tu
le comprends vite en fait
ouais du coup mais il fait ça quand même
ouais mais du coup tu es plus content
d'avir ton roi là que bloqué là-bas
parce que tu le ah mais tu arrives pas à
le manger
tu fais C 5 et deux attends veut pas
l'attraper l'autre oui au pire tu tu les
changes oui mais c'est ce qu'on voulait
tout à l'heure mais la
D4 c'est pas pas facile encore mais
l'ordi dit que ça ça gagne quand même
donc 3 vas-y ça D4 non mais on défend on
l' mis ah oui l' mis en C1 cavalier
E1 et si je joue pas
bon il va
faire7 ah C2 k D4 car E2 ah c'est pas ah
non c k D4 ro D2 roi E1 roi F1 ah ça y
est on le bouffe je le vois mal à l'aise
ce k G1
connard
ah cha
cavalier bon qui réfléchi qui fait cer5
F5 tempo et c'est le
moment alors l'ordi est moins chaud que
tout à l'heure mais aussi tour non mais
il était jamais chaud de rien en il se
trouve ça gagne pas donc c'est pas
meilleur pour lui auou moins bon
mais on a du ball parce que je pense ça
aurait gagné il aurait joué je pense
qu'il y a à
penser
je pense qu'il a vraiment penser toi
aussi il peut y avoir penser pas
facile la baraka est avec nous je suis
très
confiant après Fabiano c'est incroyable
quoi parce qu'il fait pas la meilleure
partie de son année mais il te met quand
même la pression exactement comme il
avait fait contre Maxime HM où il était
pas dans son assiette enin genre dans le
tournoi tu vois que c'est pas son
meilleur tournoi que c'est les candidats
qu'il a le plus raté c'est un de ses
pires tournois en fait mais il est quand
même allé de gagner une partie au
forceceps quoi et tu sens que là c'est
un peu le non mais il est euh il est
méritant dans son ça qu'il est pas à 100
% il il est il est un peu voilà il a
joué beaucoup de tournois mais il est
numéro 2 mondial et il veut pas te
laisser un demi-point quoi même s'il est
même s'il s'en fout mentalement en fait
que ça pas de valeur de gagner faire nul
ou quoi autre que 5 point mais c'est pas
grave il te il va tout te jouer et si et
si S un petit espace il il y a 95 95 %
de chance de nul 5 % de chance de
victoire pour lui depuis tout à l'heure
et il va te jouer 2 heures il y a la
rond demain 11h30 il a pas vraiment
intérêt à le faire mais par principe ça
c'est beau quand même enfin gen faut
reconna c'est admirable ouais c'est
enfin c'est ce qu'on veut voir quand on
regarde du
sport des compétitions c'est ça c'est de
voir des gens qui qui V au bout quoi de
même et Ben qui pareil hein genre là les
deux hommes vont au bout de même c'est
beau mais genre c'est c'est Fabiano qui
l'impose quoi dans un moment où il en a
absolument pas besoin il vient d'être
champion des États-Unis machin bon merci
au revoir hein mais pas du
tout bah c'est pour ça aussi qu'il est
numéro 2 mondial et qu'on mettait lui N
NPO et Ding aussi qui a ce côté-là
négation totale quand il joue bah c'est
pour ça que ils sont au-dessus des
autres he des guiris des tu vois
j'imagine pas gu faire ça contre Baky
l'a pas du tout fait Westley l'aurait
pas fait c'est des joueurs qui sont un
cran en
dessous le joueur du calibre de Fabiano
bah aussi il a peut-être appris ça quand
il a joué son fameux match contre Magnus
oui il le faisait déjà oui mais il ait
vu que Magnus il a mis mais il lui a pas
laissé un demi-point quoi
il lui jou des Hees m les foot couur
opposé complètement nul je me rappelle
il a un pion de plus la finale foosé nul
c'est
jé
mais
plus
G
peut-être qu'il veut éviter les c pr G6
il d comprendre
aussi il va faire tour D4 ici oui ça
j'imagine il fait peur la bquille
bon des pas
juste VI 7 encore
ça fait pas nul
direct il y a T à
5as un peu poussé tes pions un peu trop
des petites faes ici ou là là et ça
ouais ok qui tient va faire B5 quand
même ça doit tenir ou pas en fa dis G4
h4antme jouer ah ouais c'est chaud allez
reste coup pour by 45
secondes mais quelle abnégation de la
part de Fabi et quelle défense de la
part de Baky et cavalier C6 ah alors
c'est pas la fin du monde mais c'est pas
le mieux il a dû rater t à 5 ou quelque
chose
ça peut encore faire nul mais là après
depuis le début allez depuis le début
Fab a jamais trouver le truc qu' mettait
vraiment devant il va fa qu' prend C6
façon ouais mais peut-être tour a 5
c'est pas si simple
ouais sinon c'est tour à 7 mais tour à 7
7 C4 m t C4 en fait si tu vois que T C4
t tu lui fais le même
avant mauvais truc qui qui te gagne le
cavalier ouais allez Maxime c'est ça by
il faut espérer que ça rerate encore
côté
Fabi et Ben qui va encore défendre hein
c'est pas
terminé çaass au buus skim là ben je
pense aussi mais bon j'essaie de
laisse-moi
arriver il veut pas laisser rriver ce
skim là mais je crois c'est il est il
est 22 ou 23 ce skim là c'est un trèson
joueur peut-être même plus il joue très
très bien je connais dans le chat en
fait les pseudos des gens qui racontent
pas n'importe quoi les mecs disent trop
de trucs pertinents je leur demande leur
hlo et un peu quis sont enfin je sais
pas qui c'est IRL mais ok vraiment
bizarre qu'il ne soit pas plus con que
ça 24 ouais voilà 22 23 plus bah r quoi
enfinis pas content que je lu dise qu'il
est 22 23 mais tu vois je savais plus
mais
bon non mais tu vois il est pas
complètement con quoi ça il dit des
trucs complètement sensés non mais du
coup je le
remarque tiens lui il est il est pas il
est pas comme les autres pertinent quoi
to tu te démarques du l'au quoi
je vais te donner un chocolat quoi on va
voir s'il la tour à 5
mais l'ordi est pas complètement
catastrophé il dit de jouer tour prend
pion prend roi e non mais en fait je
comprends que ce soit pas catastrophique
peut-être mais mais moi j'irai en un en
D1 et derrière ouais ouais ouais bien
sûr et puis je sais pas mais ça on va
voir enfin on va jouer quand même ouais
ça on va jouer ouais puis peut-être
c'est nul mais j'en sais rien enfin ou
pas d'ailleurs mais ouais non non tu as
raison désolé j'ai eu une hallucination
parce que je regardais ce qu'il disait
il a joué tour à
5 mais quoi qu'il en soit Fabiano
pouvait pas arriver mieux que ça il y a
quelques coups là ça su et tour
D6 F4 j'aime bien donne la route pour le
roi GF en fait il te fait tout reprend
il t'attaque là tu reviens il peut
revenir ici bon monre le roi et il les
rend à 4 un jour
ouais tu peux faire ça non mais ok enfin
tu peux ça peut mal tourner ou pas mais
[Musique]
bon ro ou roi D4 ouais pour bloquer roi
D6 H4 un petit Z ouais mais tu as les
Zugang avec la tour
[Musique]
là il vient du côté où il vient pas et
pour moi c'est le capable enc alekin
alekin capable en
d'ailleurs bon ça c'est plus dur que
mais oui oui mais c'est quand tu connais
l'autre mais ok bon ben c'est pas facile
je veux dire mais mais je crois que je
jouerai tour D6 là moi moi
aussi F4 c'est pas simple non mais enfin
bon tu peux avoir parce que il est
relativement logique mais oui oui tu
peux tu peux choisir ça et tu peux
peut-être faire juste 3 F1 d'ailleurs
bon faut la
baraca tour C5 tour à 4 ouais ça
j'aurais pas fait fait là faut la baraka
ends c'est 5 c'est la même idée que T D6
tu Fanton pion mais en pas la bonne case
quand Fabi joue pour rien il joue pour
pour jouer quoi pour gagner quand il
peut gagner pour le ho parce qu'il
devait jouer mais mais il joue son rôle
hein r le trouble fait il a fait tour C5
j'aurais vraiment pas fait VO la tour à
4 c'est + 3 C 7 à C5 j'aime pas du tout
le coup en fait tour à 4 tu es forcéou
tu es obligé c'est sûr et tu C7 tu vas
faire A6 c'est sûr tour a 7 tu dois et
quoi tu ro7 ro E2 roi
D3 roi D3 ça je défendre comme ça c'est
pas facile ça ça peut perdre à tout
moment parce que toutes les finales d'
vont perdre tuou en vrai pour expliquer
genre même ça
ouais mais tu drit trop loin et c'est le
danger
ouais là après en plus et le problème en
plus de ça c'est je crois que tous les
coups sont évidents pour les blancs7
après je sais pas à quel point ça perd
vraiment mais 6 tour C8 à 7 tour à8 F1
D6 en
fait8
à oui et plus prendre des tours à 6 qui
vont revient jamais derrière ou non
c'est fini là c'est bizarre
C5 même t
D6
probablement mais oui c'est biz enfin en
tout cas si tu en as tu as plus de
chance Maxim devrait gagner de son côté
ouais Maxim c'est fini euh parce
queettre le cavalier là ça va faire une
route pour ro pour aller chercher le KG1
euh mais en plus fa il calcule jusqu'au
bout parce que c'est tour C8 forcé ouais
ça c'est A7 c'est ça forcé RO1 c'est ça
forcé roi i c'est ça forcé et puis voà
ça c'est ça forcé en fait vou prendre le
prend non ça c'est oui en fait si tu
prends pas le pion tu as pas de coup tu
C6 C6 3 C6 je te fais même F3
tour 1
n'importe quoi D6 tour à 6 ouais ouais
c'est
fini c'est élémentaire à gagner ça juste
il a vérifieré parce que cétait un peu
étonnant il SAF que tu as le temps tu as
le temps tu
calcules et
Ben qui qui a défendu défendu défendu
défendu Fabi qui c'est
pas super c'était pas le plus grand Fabi
qu'on ait vu mais sur sa qualité
l'abnégation il a réussi à faire
craquer donc dernière chance pour les
candidats
Maxime si carou
gagne pour B mérit mieux
ben ça a pas mal tourné pas mal tourné
pas mal tourné et
ouais gros match ouais non c'est sûr
ouioui mais Fabiano il il laisse pas il
laisse pas respirer quoi il te donne pas
la nu franchement à part Fabiano Naka
Yan Magnus Ding et Magnus les cinq il y
en a aucun qui gagne là il a abandonné
by bah infinito ouais il r Oui mais bon
oui non mais la position la final il a
implosé
quoi il a
implosé bon ben c'est vous il trou le
j'ai 4 machin encore le dernier petit
espoir de
incroyable bon on va attendre que Maxim
ça finisse mais ça va finir il va
gagner mettre le
cavalier4 et il va juste ramener le roi
le CEN enfermé en fait donc ça va
vite Maxim le dernier des moan quoi
comme
toujours bon et après évidemment revenez
demain le tournoi aura 12h30 le début
mais encore beaucoup d'importance
puisquil y a encore la course à ikarou
qui doit enfin il y a encore beaucoup de
choses qui se passent mesdames et
messieurs dans ce
tournoi mais Maxim revient sur bil en
fait c'est ça ouais qu'il joue demain
d'ailleurs il ont les couleurs qui
correspondent
mais pense
pas ça peutf je te dis pas
que je pense que Pichot va pas tarder à
abandonner
là son cheval tu es trop loin quoi oui
mais il veut peut-être le mettre là
sacrifier à ce
momentl tu as toujours ton fou
quoi fait F4 en faitumilie en vrai s ta
gueule c'est marrant ou comm tu
sacrifies
pas est-ce que c'est mort pour by ouais
là c'est mort bah en fait en gr il est
dans le même qu F que Maxime mais autant
Maxime on sait qu'il peut peut-être te
faire le 3 sur 3 et que c'est très
improbable mais ok B qui non
ouais puis en plus il a le scénario puis
il doit être fatigué
puis
c'est épuisant ce qu'il a dû faire B
hier aujourd'hui
machin Mo j'aime bien ce que personne
méritait mieux mais d'un autre côté fa
ne méritait pas moins bien un peu
ça s
bien un
combat
mais là Maxime d'autant plus le 3 sur
tris passes parce que du coup Fabi il
est bien donc il va sûrement prendre une
place à quelqu'un quand même au pire il
fera trois nuls et ça fera des mecs à 7
et demi et Maxime avec il passe mais bon
gagner les trois dernières ça paraît dur
heinon tu prends les trucs des un après
les autres et
puis puisisis on voit quoi des fois il y
a des montada dans le sport un truc
imprévu qui j'en ai vu une récemment un
truc bon un match complètement con en
Italie c'est cari qui recevait je sais
pas qui ils sont 20e dernier du calcho
de la série euh ils sonté 3-0 à domicile
c'est 75e minute bon ils ont gagé 43
quoi
ouais mais
bon
donc notre meilleur shot ça reste pour
ou mais même ça oui il
peut mais du coup flotte plus ils sont
quwana les deux autres qui jou
ouais plus du tout plus du
tout qui c'est qui double je pense que
double les blanc sur Carana probblement
nul
ils ont tous les blanc en fait vidit je
pense qu'il va doubler les blancs contre
c'est pas s remarque non il peut il peut
tellement mavais départage que la Calif
ça semble
dur à moins qu'il a un meilleur
départage que
vidit non pas du
tout ah c'est ça mais le problème c'est
que V il améliore son départage parce
qu'il a joué contre Nakamura Nakamura le
BAE contre c'est dégueulasse ce truc en
fait que les un cont enfin c'est pas
normal ça que tu que tu rencontres
quelqu'un et que toi tu lui améores son
départage et le dégueulasse enfin c'est
vraiment illogique comme
départage et du coup les autres c'est
sien mais d il a un départage pour
nak il est pas si mal mal au départage
en plus il a jou en PL aujourd'hui non
non il oui mais en je veux dire il a
joué jou plus
fort non mais c'est trop en fait on
devient premier supporte de Naka quoi
c'est improbable mais c'est horrible
bientôt on va être pour Gotham
chess bientôt on va dire allez Gottham
il faut absolument que tu gages non mais
bon j'en peux plus en fait c'est quoi ce
trquenard
quoi dans 3 jours on a les tyfog Gotham
c'est c'est trop fable
là
pour H c'est Gotham quoi
dans c'est on est ridicule en fait mais
oui les Français qui ratent complètement
leur tournoi enfin bah qui du coup qui
le réussi mais je finalement comme
objectif c'est de se qualifier à TR
rondes de la fin on a quasiment enfin on
a plus jouurs qui peuvent se qualif
quasiment Maxime ouais mais on a Maxime
qui
revientover et il est toujours pas
favori du
tout le seul gars du T qui crache du
S qui remonte quoi de de du diable va
vert mais genre si on t'avait dit avant
le grand Suisse qui TR rondes de la fin
ah oui non ben non c'est pas que un
joueur qui peut faire 100 % et qui a une
chance de se qualifier enfin du non je
suux
pas non c'est pas que je suis pour pour
pas qu'il descende c'est que je leur
souhaite pas de descendre s'ils doivent
descendreon déjà je pourrais pas y faire
grand-chose je vais pas te dire que je
vais me mettre des écharpe de
Nol cri et la cazette pendant les matchs
quoi mais
euh
B pour moi leur place c'est quand même
plutôt en première division quoi donc je
leur souhaite pas de descendre
et mais B a autant de points que mvl
pourquoi il pourrait plus jouer laif en
fait le truc c'est que Maxime il est
nettement plus fort que
by donc tu te dis que 3 sur TR c'est
déjà impossible même pour un tel que
Maxime mais bon tu rêves parce qu'il
vient de faire 3/ TR et que tu dis c'est
peut-être le phénix mais dis donc que
bon tu donnes 1 % de chance non ben qui
ce qu'on voulait c'est qu' bah il fasse
nul aujourd'hui peut-être nul demain il
en G nul et tu vois que ça se passe
comme ça quoi mais
euh onimagine pas enchaîner les gains
les uns après les autres quoi et F4 le
coup précis c'est
Maxime Maxime quand il joue bien c'est
c'est caviar he h qu'est-ce qu'il est
fort tu Jinx
Maxime c'est pas Maxime là cellelà il va
la gagner puis j'ai dit que c aut membre
imprable qu'il se qualifie pas donc je
pas ce que je peux Jinx mais c'est 1 %
de chance quoi alle les
deux après si demain il gagne au
noir il passe à 10 puis 20 et 40 à la
dernière après il redouble les blancs il
défonc il se qualifie au candidat et et
je monte à Paris pour pour l'accueillir
ah mais après il par peut-être direct
aux États-Unis sur repasse par Paris je
monte à Paris je monte aux États-Unis
l'accueillir sur repasse par Paris je
prends le TGV lundi matin et je vais je
vais le chercher à
l'aéroport avec une bouteille de Ruinard
blanc de blanc c'est
annoncé je prends le TGV à 6h30 j'ai
rien à
chez moi je crache du S aussi tous crev
à cause de
ça non mais là il est remis
là
allez faut le finir
pot G4 tu libères pas le cheval parce
que on te le mange ce pion donc il sert
pas d'appui quoi tu V H3 en fait tu tu
vas nulle part
fait et
voilà enfin bref tu vois ce qu'on veut
dire quoi donc non suffit pas après il a
fait G6 c'est très bien
enfin il est résistant quand même
ben il essaie de de faire ce qu'il peut
je pense tu prends G5 tu prends6 tu fais
D8 ah mais il a F je con A8 ce
fou dit ça do être si mal mais on a
peêtre plus simple
oua peêtre pu on prend prend tu ramè
l'autre en D3 puis tant pis pas de
cavalier mais tu vas ver C5 tu vas
prendre ok je comprends qu' abandonne
pas direct mais j'ai une question en
fait F4 qui parer si fort d'près l'ordi
pourquoi on fait pas juste 3 des de en
fait
ça l'amuse vas-y
ouais ça je penserais que ça serait
plus des
trêtre gagnantme m non non je sais pas
si c'est plus simple de faire ça ou
l'autre maisok je questionner donc TR
donc il joue vraiment pour celle-là ou
il va vers C 5 et tout ça et KG1 n'est
pas mort mais il est loin du jeu et
l'autre est tellement imp plot
que là il veut prendre avec ce cavalier
je
pense a ça
aussi j'ai un
retour R
de du coup tu as la même
maisong
oui il a rien qui va ok ça va
gagner quand il abandonnera quoi ça peut
être maintenant
d'ailleurs c'est beau quoi c'est c'est
incroyable ce
Maxime est tellement mal depuis le début
du tournoi c'est lui qui va être la la
dernière chance
française en partant de très très
loin allez monsieur Pichot il faut
abandonner on a envie d'aller manger
notre Coustous à
Fab
donc demain je pense qu'on suivra mvl et
Naka en fait ns deux
chances puis on un comme ça pour comme
d'ab quoi
mais on regard un peu les tablees une
table 2 ce qui se passe parce que
bon c'est pas pareil s font B
déjà
B ça peut être demain ouais ça ça ferait
nul je pense bah qui va mettre le bus ah
oui bon de toute façon mais après Maxim
de toute façon il doit jouer pour le
gain à fond qu à perdre
mais peuvent pas ils peuvent pas faire
nul en en rapidos quoi non mais
tellement dur de batt ber avec les les
Noirs ah oui je sais mais comme je tu
prends t les risqu et puis au pire tu
perds mais c'est pas gra une chance à
quoi
ouais en fait et puis peut-être ça
passeousit peut-être et euh et puis
sinon ça passe et puis voilàin parce que
Maxime il tentera tout et c'est la
meilleure chance pour Baky de gagner
c'est jouer contre un joueur contre
comme Maxime et la meilleure
chance donc bon pour Maxime aussi parce
que bil essaiera vraiment de contrer je
pense
non mais B qui va jamais laisser Maxime
gagnerer évidemment ouais mais après bon
il va garer le bus il va essayer de
faire un contre mais il va pas faire
comme yyangi quoi que mais non je pense
pas tent quand même yongi il avait juste
même pas essayé de jouer le G avec Maxim
Maxim lui donné toutes les chances du
monde lui tentera s'il peu je veux dire
et tienne surtout après deux longues
parties comme ça puis celle là perdu tu
es un peu déçu bon ben demain tu les
blan tu un mec à 2700 et quelques tu dis
bon benah nul c'est bien et puis je
garde mes je marque des points les do
j'ai fait un bon tournoi je vais pas
m'enflammer maintenant non mais c'est
donc c'est normal d'avir cette attitude
et Maxime bah lui il doit jouer pour le
G à tout prix donc ça serait ça
l'affrontement quoi si Maxime laisse une
chance à Baky d'être mieux de jouer le
gain il fera pas commeangi a jouer la
nulle B jouera le gain bah si s'en rend
compte parce que tu appment tu es trop
crevé tu dirais tu veux tellement faire
nul
que
apparemment pas déjà lieu tant qu'il y a
des parties en cours tu peux pas faire
d'appariment ENF on extrapole on dit si
il se joue demain mais il a tellement
d'autres joueurs dans ce groupe de
points mais c'est c'est possible c'est
pas voilà je sais pas trop combien de
joueurs ou quoi mais ça peut allez ro F2
ro G3 ro
G2 c'est trouvé mais ça risque
d'abandonner inccessemment sous peu
ok il qu'une case c'est G1 et sur R 2 il
a plus de case du tout il va encore
faire qu' de pour qu' prend de ESS de
bouger son
ou non
non on s'abandonne mais il doit avoir le
se non mais écoute il s'est bien battu
il a fait sa partie p chot et puis sur
un grand Maxime ça pas suffi a pu tenir
la nulle mais partie instructive quelque
part avec ce joli D45 là Maxime allez on
finit sur une bonne note quand même
aujourd'hui malgré une
journée finalement mal passé mais on
finit on finit quand même sur une
victoire de Maxime donc ça c'est cool
les amis on va se dépêcher parce que
nous faut encore qu'on Dine qu'on
prépare le le recap et qu'on soit là
demain à 12h30 donc on a encore forte à
faire donc merci d'avoir suivi ce live
jusqu'à maintenant et on se retrouve
demain pour la suite des événements à
12h30 je vous le rappelle